THE SENATE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE, ONE ON
EDUCATION WILL COME TO ORDER. I
WANT TO WELCOME SENATOR CORTEZ,
WHO HAS BEEN APPOINTED TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE SINCE, OUR LAST
MEETING. WE APPRECIATE HIM BEING
HERE. WE KNOW HE'S A FORMER
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER AND HAS BEEN
INVOLVED IN EDUCATION ISSUES FOR
MANY, MANY YEARS, INCLUDING HIS
BUS TRIP YESTERDAY WHERE
EVERYBODY CAME UP FROM HIS
DISTRICT FOR EDUCATION. SENATOR
WILK WILL NOT BE ABLE TO BE HERE
TODAY, AND I SHOULD ANNOUNCE
THAT IT IS OUR GOAL TO TRY TO BE
DONE AT 1230. AND IF WE GET
CLOSE, THAT MAY LIMIT OR DECIDE
HOW MUCH PUBLIC TESTIMONY WE CAN
TAKE. SO I WILL MAKE A JUDGMENT
ABOUT THE LENGTH OF THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY WHEN WE COMPLETE THE
DIFFERENT ITEMS. LET ME JUST
BEGIN BY MAKING A FEW COMMENTS,
BECAUSE I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THIS IS AN AWFUL BUDGET
YEAR, AND IT'S GOING TO REQUIRE
US TO MAKE SOME REALLY DIFFICULT
CHOICES. AND GIVEN THE SCALE OF
THE BUDGET CRISIS, WE HAVE TO
PUT EVERYTHING ON THE TABLE AND
THE STATE BUDGET IS A SOCIAL
SAFETY NET, ON WHICH MANY PEOPLE
DEPEND FOR EDUCATION, FOR HEALTH
CARE, FOR CHILD CARE, FOR SOCIAL
SERVICES AND MORE. AND MANY
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN DEPEND ON
SERVICES IN ALL CATEGORIES. SO
CUTTING ONE TO SAVE ANOTHER IS
AN ACTION THAT NONE OF US REALLY
WANT TO TAKE, AS THE SENATE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIR FOR
EDUCATION, I'M GOING TO WORK
WITH ALL PARTIES TO FIND THE
OPTION THAT BEST PROTECTS
CLASSROOM FUNDING WITHIN OUR
FISCAL CIRCUMSTANCES. A VERY
SMALL INCREASE FOR K THROUGH 12
EDUCATION, WHICH IS PROPOSED.
AND WE ARE GOING TO DISCUSS
THIS, IN THIS HEARING, IS IN A
BUDGET THAT CONTAINS CUTS ACROSS
STATE PROGRAMS. IT'S ACTUALLY A
CHALLENGE FOR LOCAL DISTRICTS
THAT HAVE LABOR CONTRACTS IN
PLACE AND ARE TRYING TO KEEP UP
WITH INFLATION, AND WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO REALLY LOOK AT
INVESTMENTS IN SCHOLARSHIPS, IN
HIGHER EDUCATION THÀNH TO SEE
WHAT WE CAN DO. IN THESE
DIFFICULT CIRCUMSTANCES, WE HAVE
HAD SEVEN BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
HEARINGS IN SUBCOMMITTEE ONE SO
FAR THIS YEAR, AND THIS IS THE
FIRST HEARING AFTER THE MAY
REVISION. AND IT WILL REALLY,
COVER ISSUES, ALMOST ALL OF
WHICH WE HAVE AIRED ALREADY, BUT
WHICH WE AIRED BEFORE. THERE WAS
THE MAY REVISION BASED ON THE
CURRENT REVENUE SITUATION AND
BASED ON HOW THE GOVERNOR,
REFINED THE BUDGET ON THOSE
ISSUES THAT WE ALREADY HEARD. AS
I MENTIONED, WE WILL TAKE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY AFTER FOR ALL THE
ISSUES. AND, AND DO IT AS BEST
WE CAN. BUT LET ME JUST SAY NOW,
EVEN IF YOU COULDN'T BE HERE
TODAY, OR IF YOU DON'T GET A
CHANCE TO MAKE PUBLIC TESTIMONY,
YOU ARE HERE. WE WILL TAKE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY AT THE WEB PAGE
, OF THE BUDGET COMMITTEE,
EITHER THROUGH THE WEB PAGE OR
IN WRITING, ADDRESSED TO THE
ADDRESS THAT IS ON THAT. SO WE
REALLY VALUE THE PARTICIPATION
OF THE PUBLIC AND WANT TO HEAR
EVEN IF YOU CAN'T BE HERE,
TODAY, TO TESTIFY, THERE ARE TWO
PARTS AND PART A, WHICH WE ARE
ABOUT TO GO TO. SO I WOULD ASK
THE PANEL FOR PART A TO MAKE
THEIR WAY TO THE TABLE, PART A
IS REALLY ABOUT, THE OVERALL
FUNDING, PROPOSITION 98, IN
PARTICULAR AND ALL THE, THE
PERMUTATIONS OF THE FUNDING. AND
WE, WE HAVE THREE PANELISTS
SCHEDULED AND, ALEX SHOPE FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, DAN
MERWIN FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION, KEN KOPPEN FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
BUT WE KNOW WE HAVE OTHER PEOPLE
FROM THE VARIOUS, STAKEHOLDERS
TO ADD OR ANSWER MORE DETAILED
QUESTIONS. AND SO WE WILL TAKE
OPENING STATEMENTS IN THAT ORDER
, STARTING WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. SO WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
SENATOR ALEX SHOPE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, SO THE
MAY REVISION FORECAST THAT THE
PROPOSITION 98 GUARANTEE AMOUNT
FOR 2425 WILL BE $109.1 BILLION,
FOR 23, 24, THE GUARANTEE WILL
BE 102.6 BILLION. AND FOR 22,
23, THE GUARANTEE WILL BE 97.5
BILLION, IN THE THREE YEAR
BUDGET WINDOW, THE MAY REVISE
SHOWS A DECLINE OF ABOUT 3.5
BILLION COMPARED TO GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET, INCLUDING DECREASES OF
ABOUT 800,000,000 IN 22, 23 AND
3,000,000,000 IN 2324, SO MOVING
TO, THE PROP 98 ACCOUNTING AND
ACCRUAL PROPOSAL FROM GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET, THE MAY REVISE MAINTAINS
THIS PROPOSAL TO ADDRESS THE
DECREASE IN THE 2223 GUARANTEE,
THE ONLY DIFFERENCE IS THE TOTAL
HAS INCREASED TO 8.8 BILLION, AN
INCREASE OVER THE AMOUNT IN
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET OF ABOUT 800
MILLION, OUT YEAR ACCRUALS NOW
TOTAL ABOUT 1.76 BILLION PER
YEAR, WHICH IS AN INCREASE OF
ABOUT 154 MILLION OVER THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL. SO
FOR THE PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM
STABILIZATION ACCOUNT, THE MAY
REVISE ALSO INCLUDES CHANGES TO
THE PROJECTED DEPOSITS AND
DISCRETIONARY WITHDRAWALS FROM
THE K-14 RAINY DAY FUND. WHEN
COMPARED TO GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
SO THIS INCLUDES A SMALLER
DEPOSIT IN 2223, ABOUT $272
MILLION, THEN MANDATORY
WITHDRAWALS OF ABOUT
1,000,000,000 IN 23, 24 AND 2.6
BILLION IN 2425. AND THEN
FINALLY A DISCRETIONARY
WITHDRAWAL OF ABOUT 4.8 BILLION
IN 23, 24, BECAUSE THE REMAINING
BALANCE IN THE RAINY DAY FUND
WILL BE ABOUT 2.6 BILLION AT THE
END OF THE 2324 FISCAL YEAR,
SCHOOL DISTRICT RESERVE CAP
REQUIREMENTS, WOULD NOT, BE
TRIGGERED IN 24, 25, AND THE
2425 MANDATORY WITHDRAWAL WILL
LEAVE. $0. NOTHING LEFT. AS THE
BALANCE IN THE RAINY DAY FUND,
FINALLY. THEN PER PUPIL FUNDING
IN 24, 25 IS 17,502 PROP 98 PER
STUDENT, AND 23,878 PER STUDENT.
WHEN ACCOUNTING FOR ALL FUNDING
SOURCES, SO MOVING TO AVERAGE
DAILY ATTENDANCE, ADA. THE
PERCENTAGE CHANGE IN AVERAGE
DAILY ATTENDANCE FROM 2324 TO
2425 IS EXPECTED TO BE 0.74, SO
INDICATING A SLIGHT INCREASE,
ADA CONTINUES TO BE A LOWER
SHARE OF ENROLLMENT THAN BEFORE
COVID. HOWEVER, UPDATED MAY
REVISE DATA INDICATES A TREND OF
IMPROVED ATTENDANCE IN THE YEARS
FOLLOWING THE PANDEMIC, SO
MOVING NOW TO THE PROP 98
REVENGE. OF COURSE, THE,
GUARANTEE WAS REVENGE TO REFLECT
THE CONTINUED IMPLEMENTATION OF,
UNIVERSAL TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN AND PROPOSITION 28,
SPECIFICALLY, THE GUARANTEE WAS
BENCHED IN 2425 TO INCLUDE AN
INCREASE OF 938 MILLION FOR PROP
28. PER THE PROPOSITION FINANCE
ESTIMATES THAT REQUIRED ARTS AND
MUSIC AND SCHOOLS ACT SUPPORT IN
2425 WILL BE ABOUT 907 MILLION,
THEN THE REVISED, UNIVERSAL
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
REVENGE AMOUNT IN 2425, IS ABOUT
1.515 BILLION, WHICH REPRESENTS
A DECREASE OF ABOUT 300 MILLION
RELATIVE TO GOVERNOR'S BUDGET,
SO THE MAY REVISE PROPOSES
SEVERAL BUDGETARY ACTIONS,
INCLUDING SOLUTIONS TO BRIDGE
THE ADDITIONAL SHORTFALL THAT
HAS DEVELOPED SINCE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET, THE GOAL OF
THESE SOLUTIONS IS TO MAINTAIN
CORE PROGRAMS AND AVOID
NEGATIVELY IMPACTING SCHOOL
FUNDING, WHILE, OF COURSE,
BALANCING THE BUDGET AND THE
BUDGET YEAR AND THE FOLLOWING
YEAR. SO THE INVESTMENTS THAT I
WILL DETAIL BELOW, JUST A FEW OF
THE KIND OF, BIGGER INVESTMENTS
THESE ARE INCLUSIVE OF BOTH
GOVERNORS, BUDGET ADJUSTMENTS OR
BUDGET INVESTMENTS, ADJUSTMENTS
TO THOSE INVESTMENTS. AND THEN
OF COURSE, NEW MAY REVISION
INVESTMENT S, YOU'LL BE ABLE TO
SEE THE INCREMENTAL MAY REVISION
ADJUSTMENTS IN FINANCE. LETTERS
THAT THAT WERE POSTED RECENTLY,
SO ON THE K TO 12 SIDE, THIS
INCLUDES A REDUCTION OF ABOUT
1.3 BILLION, OF WHICH, ROUGHLY 1
BILLION IS ONE TIME FOR THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA
LCFF, TO REFLECT DOWNWARD GROWTH
ADJUSTMENTS DUE TO DECLINING
ENROLLMENT IN PRIOR YEARS.
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
EXPANSION AND A 1.07% COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENT, A NEW
INVESTMENT OF ROUGHLY 395
MILLION, ONE TIME FOR GRANTS TO
DISTRICTS TO ACQUIRE ELECTRIC
SCHOOL BUSSES. PROPOSED INCREASE
FOR UNIVERSAL MEALS OF 317.9
MILLION, OF WHICH 118.9 MILLION
IS ONE TIME FOR 2324, AND 198.9
MILLION IS ONGOING FOR BOTH
GROWTH AND COLA IN 24, 25, AND
THEN FINALLY, AN ONGOING
INCREASE OF ROUGHLY 89.2 MILLION
TO FUND A 1.0, 1.07% COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENT, AND CASELOAD
ADJUSTMENTS FOR THE VARIOUS
CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS, AND THEN
AS FAR AS SOLUTIONS ON THE K-12
SIDE GO, THIS INCLUDES SAVINGS
OF ABOUT 73.7 MILLION ONE TIME
PROP 98 GENERAL FUND FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM, IN ADDITION TO THE
445.7 MILLION THAT WAS SWEPT AT
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET, PULLING BACK
250 MILLION AND CURRENTLY
UNALLOCATED INCLUSIVE EARLY
EDUCATION EXPANSION PROGRAM
FUNDING TO INSTEAD SUPPORT THE
ELECTRIC SCHOOL BUS GRAND
INVESTMENT, A DISCRETIONARY
WITHDRAWAL, AS I MENTIONED
PREVIOUSLY, OF ROUGHLY 4.8
BILLION FROM THE RAINY DAY FUND,
WHICH IS IN ADDITION TO THOSE,
MANDATORY WITHDRAWALS THAT I
ALSO MENTIONED, IN ADDITIONAL
700 MILLION TO BE RECOGNIZED IN
25, 26 THROUGH 2930, DUE TO THE
REDUCED REVENUES ATTRIBUTABLE TO
2223 AS PART OF THE PAST YEAR.
SOLUTION AND THEN ADDITIONAL
REAPPROPRIATION AND REVERSION
FUNDING TOTALING 317.3 MILLION,
OF WHICH 254.7 MILLION IS TO
SUPPORT ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
ELECTRIC BUSSES AND 62.5 MILLION
IS TO SUPPORT ONGOING LCFF COSTS
IN 2425, SO MOVING QUICKLY TO
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES, SOME OF
THE MAY REVISION INVESTMENTS, OR
THE LARGER INVESTMENTS ON THAT
SIDE INCLUDE AN ONGOING INCREASE
OF ROUGHLY 100.2 MILLION TO FUND
A 1.07% COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT FOR THE STUDENT
CENTERED FUNDING FORMULA CFF, AN
ONGOING INCREASE OF ROUGHLY 28.
AND I'M GOING TO LET YOU GO
HERE, BUT WE HAVE SEPARATE ITEMS
ON COMMUNITY COLLEGES LATER. SO
KEEP FINISH YOUR THOUGHT. OKAY.
I'LL JUST GIVE YOU SOME OF THE
TOP FINISHES, SO 28.1 MILLION TO
SUPPORT ENROLLMENT GROWTH WITHIN
THE SRF, ONGOING INCREASE OF
ROUGHLY 13.1 MILLION TO FUND A
1.7 1.07% COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT, FOR SPECIFIED
CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS, AND THEN A
ONE TIME INVESTMENT OF 227.9
MILLION TO SUPPORT THE COST OF
THE FC F IN 2324. AND THEN THE
PROP 98 SOLUTIONS ON THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SIDE, INCLUDE
ADDITIONAL RAINY DAY FUND
WITHDRAWALS OF APPROXIMATELY 192
MILLION ADDITIONAL PAST YEAR
ACCOUNTING SOLUTION OF
APPROXIMATELY 100 MILLION AND
THEN REAPPROPRIATION AND
REVERSION FUNDING OF ABOUT 262.9
MILLION 227.9, WHICH I MENTIONED
IS TO FUND THE SRF WITH
REMAINDER, GOING TOWARDS VARIOUS
OTHER PROGRAMS THAT WILL BE
COVERED. OF COURSE, ON THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SIDE, AND THAT
CONCLUDES MY REMARKS. AND THEN
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY JUST THANK
YOU. AND WE'LL DO QUESTIONS
AFTER EVERYONE JUST BEFORE WE
MOVE TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION ACTION. I FAILED TO
FORMALLY, EVEN THOUGH WE'RE NOT
TAKING OFFICIAL ACTIONS, I
FAILED TO FORMALLY ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. SO COULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL? SENATOR LARRY, HERE,
SENATOR CORTESE HERE. SENATOR
WILK, WE HAVE A QUORUM. AND THEN
LET ME ALSO SAY I WAS GOING TO
SAY AT THE BEGINNING THAT WE
HAVE THE SEPARATE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISCUSSION, BUT OUR
DISCUSSION ON PROPOSITION 98
WILL PRIMARILY TAKE PLACE RIGHT
HERE. SO THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO
HAVE THAT AGAIN FOR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. WHEN WE GET
THAT, AM I GATHERING? YOU'RE
PULLING THE MIC OVER BECAUSE
YOU'RE JUST PREGNANT WITH A
QUESTION? NO, I WAS GOING TO
TACK ON THE GENERAL FUND
ADJUSTMENTS IN K-12, IF YOU
DON'T MIND. MY NAME IS CHRIS
FERGUSON, THEN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, SO JUST A
COUPLE A HANDFUL OF GENERAL FUND
SOLUTIONS THAT WE WOULD NOTE IN
K-12 EDUCATION, ONE IS FORGOING
A PLANNED INVESTMENT OF
375,000,000IN THE SCHOOL
FACILITY AID PROGRAM. ANOTHER
WOULD BE, FORGOING A PLANNED
INVESTMENT IN 2025, 26 OF 550
MILLION TO SUPPORT THE
CALIFORNIA PRESCHOOL,
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN AND
FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN FACILITIES
GRANT PROGRAM. WE THINK THAT
CONVERSATION AROUND THAT 550
MILLION WOULD BEST BE HAD WITHIN
THE CONTEXT OF EDUCATION, BOND
DISCUSSIONS AND THEN LASTLY, WE
DO HAVE TWO, IT'S JUST UNDER $50
MILLION FOR PRESCHOOL
INCLUSIVITY THAT WE WOULD
FOREGO. AS WELL AS THAT GROWS TO
100,000,000IN 20, 25, 26, OR
SORRY, 2627, AND WHAT THAT WOULD
DO IS WE WOULD EFFECTIVELY STOP
THE REQUIREMENT, THAT PRESCHOOL
PROVIDERS SERVE AT LEAST A
SPECIFIED PERCENTAGE OF STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES AT 5, INSTEAD
OF CONTINUING PROGRESS ON TO
SEVEN AND A HALF AND THEN 10.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND NOW WE'LL MOVE TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. GOOD
MORNING. GOOD MORNING, MR.
CHAIR, NO PREPARED REMARKS FROM
CDC TODAY. JUST HAPPY TO TRY AND
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. OKAY. THANK YOU.
THEN WE'LL MOVE TO THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND SENATOR KEN
KAPLAN WITH THE ANALYST'S OFFICE
. WE HAVE A HANDOUT THAT COVERS
OUR MAIN POINTS. I THINK THE KEY
NUMBER TO FOCUS ON IN THIS
REVISION IS THE DROP IN THE
GUARANTEE. 3.7 BILLION, LESS
PROPOSITION 98 FUNDING OVER THE
2223 THROUGH 2425 PERIOD,
REFLECTING THE DETERIORATION IN
STATE GENERAL FUND REVENUE
ESTIMATES. SOME OF A SMALL
PORTION OF WHICH IS OFFSET BY
SLIGHTLY HIGHER LOCAL PROPERTY
TAX ESTIMATES, TURNING TO PAGE
TWO, IN TERMS OF THE OVERALL
SPENDING STRUCTURE FOR SCHOOLS,
I THINK THE SIMPLEST WAY TO
THINK ABOUT THIS MAY REVISION IS
THAT JUST ABOUT EVERYTHING THAT
YOU SAW IN THE GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY BUDGET IS BACK, AND IT'S
BIGGER THAN EVER. SO THIS MAY
REVISION HAS 2.1 BILLION IN NEW
K-12 SPENDING, OR ABOUT 760
MILLION MORE THAN WHAT WAS IN
THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET,
MAINLY DIRECTED TOWARD THREE
AREAS COVERING A SLIGHTLY HIGHER
COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT
FUNDING HIGHER COSTS FOR
UNIVERSAL SCHOOL MEALS, AND
FUNDING AN ADDITIONAL 395
MILLION FOR A ZERO EMISSION
SCHOOL. BUSSES TO COVER THAT
ADDITIONAL SPENDING. AND AS WELL
AS THE DROP IN THE PROPOSITION
98 GUARANTEE, THE PRIMARY
STRATEGY IS THE LARGER RESERVE
WITHDRAWAL. THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET WOULD HAVE LEFT NEARLY
3.9 BILLION IN THE PROPOSITION
98 RESERVE. THE MAY REVISION
DRAWS THAT DOWN TO ZERO BY THE
END OF 2425, TURNING TO PAGE
THREE, THE BUDGET DOES ACCRUE AN
ADDITIONAL 666 MILLION IN PRIOR
YEAR PAYMENTS TO SCHOOLS, TO
FUTURE BUDGETS DOES NOT CHANGE
THE ACTUAL DISBURSEMENT OF CASH,
BUT RECORDS THEM IN FUTURE YEARS
INSTEAD OF IN THE PRIOR YEAR.
AND THERE'S ALSO AN ADDITIONAL
327 MILLION IN REPURPOSED,
UNSPENT FUNDS FROM PREVIOUS
YEARS. SO TURNING TO PAGE FOUR
IN OUR COMMENTS. I THINK THE
CHAIR SET THE STAGE WELL WITH
THE COMMENTS ABOUT THE OVERALL
BUDGET CONDITION, THIS MAY
REVISION IS UNFOLDING AMIDST A
SIGNIFICANT BUDGET SHORTFALL,
WITH BASELINE STATE TAX REVENUES
ABOUT 10.5 BILLION BELOW THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET. AND A
SIGNIFICANT PART OF THE WAY THE
MAY REVISION ADDRESSES THAT
SHORTFALL OVERALL IS TO ALIGN
SCHOOL FUNDING WITH THOSE LOWER
ESTIMATES OF THE PROPOSITION 98
GUARANTEE. IF YOU WERE TO NOT DO
THAT, THE STATE BUDGET SHORTFALL
WOULD BE EVEN LARGER AND YOU'D
FACE EVEN MORE DIFFICULT
DECISIONS FOR OTHER PROGRAMS.
AND ANOTHER AREAS OF THE STATE
BUDGET, THINKING ABOUT THE
REVENUE ESTIMATES IN THIS
BUDGET, OUR ASSESSMENT IS THAT
THEY'RE WITHIN THE REASONABLE OR
PLAUSIBLE RANGE, THOUGH PROBABLY
ON THE HIGH SIDE OF THAT RANGE,
UNDER OUR BEST ESTIMATE, STATE
GENERAL FUND TAX REVENUES ARE
8.6 BILLION LOWER, IF THAT'S HOW
REVENUES ULTIMATELY CAME IN, THE
PROPOSITION 98 GUARANTEE WOULD
BE 3.3 BILLION BELOW THE MAY
REVISION LEVEL. THE MAYOR
REVISION DOES RETAIN THE
PROPOSITION 98 FUNDING MANEUVER.
WE THINK THIS PROPOSAL HAS THE
SAME DOWNSIDES AS JANUARY.
ADDITIONAL OBLIGATIONS ON THE
STATE BUDGET, LESS TRANSPARENCY,
AND NEW NEW PRECEDENT FOR
SIMILAR MANEUVERS LIKE THAT IN
THE FUTURE. THIS IS, OF COURSE,
A BUDGET OF TRADE OFFS WITH
DOWNSIDES TO EVERY SOLUTION. BUT
THE DRAWBACKS TO THAT PROPOSAL
SEEM PARTICULARLY NOTABLE,
TURNING TO PAGE FIVE. THE MAY
REVISION ALSO SETS UP A FUTURE
SHORTFALL FOR SCHOOL PROGRAMS BY
USING 2.3 BILLION IN 1 TIME
FUNDS TO PAY FOR THE ONGOING
COSTS OF THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA. THIS APPROACH
DOES AVOID IMMEDIATE REDUCTIONS
TO SCHOOL PROGRAMS, BUT IT
LEAVES A HOLE IN NEXT YEAR'S
BUDGET WHEN THOSE FUNDS EXPIRE
AND THAT HOLE IS GOING TO BE
MORE DIFFICULT TO ADDRESS NEXT
YEAR BECAUSE THE STATE WON'T
HAVE THE SAME BUDGET TOOLS TO
ADDRESS IT. SO MOST NOTABLY, THE
STATE WON'T HAVE FUNDING IN THE
PROPOSITION 98 RESERVE, AND IT
ALSO WON'T HAVE THE SAME ABILITY
TO PULL BACK ON ONE TIME FUNDS,
BECAUSE A LOT OF THE UNSPENT
FUNDS THAT WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT THIS YEAR WILL BE
COMMITTED OVER THE COMING YEAR.
WE'D CONTINUE TO RECOMMEND
REJECTING THE NEW SPENDING
PROPOSALS, BOTH THE ONES IN
JANUARY AND THE NEW ONES IN MAY,
THAT WE THINK THEY LOOK EVEN
LESS AFFORDABLE NOW, IN LIGHT OF
THE LOWER ESTIMATES OF STATE
REVENUE AND THE PROPOSITION 98
GUARANTEE, A FEW OF THOSE
PROPOSALS MIGHT BE WORTH
CONSIDERING WHEN THE FISCAL
PICTURE IMPROVES, BUT THEY SEEM
MUCH LESS COMPELLING IN SUCH A
TIGHT BUDGET SITUATION, TURNING
TO PAGE SIX. YOU STILL HAVE
OPTIONS THAT WOULD ALLOW THE
STATE TO OBTAIN BOTH ONE TIME
AND ONGOING SAVINGS. YOU'VE
HEARD QUITE A BIT OF ABOUT THAT
FROM US IN PREVIOUS HEARINGS,
BUT SOME OF THEM INCLUDE
RESCINDING UNALLOCATED
COMPETITIVE GRANTS, REFORMING
CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS AND ADD ONS
TO BE LESS COSTLY AND MAKING
TEMPORARY REDUCTIONS TO SCHOOL
FUNDING THAT YOU COULD MITIGATE
BY GIVING SCHOOL DISTRICTS MORE
FLEXIBILITY OVER LOCAL RESERVES
THAT ARE CURRENTLY RESTRICTED.
THOSE ACTIONS WOULD PRODUCE
SAVINGS THAT YOU COULD USE TO
MAKE THE STATE LESS RELIANT ON
SOME OF THE ONE TIME WHEN THE
GOVERNOR AND TO EASE FUTURE
BUDGET PRESSURE AND SOME OF YOUR
CORE PRIORITIES, YOU COULD ALSO
WE'LL TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE,
ISSUES IN THE NEXT PANEL, AND
WE'RE HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I WANT TO, ASK THE LAO A SERIES
OF QUESTIONS TO STEP THROUGH THE
DIFFERENT OPTIONS ON PROP 98.
BUT I CAN'T LET MR. FERGUSON
COMMENTS GO WITHOUT A QUESTION
BECAUSE YOU TEASED THE ISSUE OF
A BOND. EVEN THOUGH A BOND ISN'T
TOTALLY MENTIONED IN THE IN THE
BUDGET. SO IS IT YOUR INTENT TO
HAVE DISCUSSIONS ABOUT A BOND?
YEAH, I THINK AS WE SIGNALED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET, IT
CERTAINLY REMAINS OUR INTENT TO
ENGAGE THE LEGISLATURE ON WHAT A
POTENTIAL EDUCATION BOND COULD
LOOK LIKE AND GIVE THÀNH THE
THIS BUDGET THAT'S IN FRONT OF
US DROPPING OUT ALL FACILITIES
MONEY. IT MEANS THAT WE THE BOND
MONEY FROM THE LAST BOND RAN OUT
ROUGHLY THREE YEARS AGO. AND
THERE'S BEEN BOND MONEY BEEN PUT
IN ANNUALLY IN THE THREE YEARS
SINCE. WITH YOU DROPPING OUT THE
FACILITIES MONEY IN THE PROPOSED
BUDGET, UNLESS THERE'S A BOND
SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION WOULD
ESSENTIALLY STOP THROUGH STATE
SPENDING THAT WAY. IS THAT
CORRECT? I THINK OUR CURRENT
PROJECTIONS ARE THAT REMAINING
FUNDING WITHIN THE PROGRAM COULD
RUN THROUGH TO THE END OF THIS
FISCAL OR THIS CALENDAR YEAR, I
DON'T KNOW THAT I WOULD SAY THAT
SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION WOULD END
BECAUSE THERE ARE OTHER
RESOURCES THAT LOCALS DO USE FOR
SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION. THEY DO
USE, OH NO. I WAS CAREFUL TO SAY
THE STATE SUPPORT ON THE STATE
SUPPORT SIDE THERE. IT IS
UNLIKELY THAT THERE WOULD BE ANY
SIGNIFICANT OR NOTABLE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE TO SUPPORT CORE NEW
CONSTRUCTION AND MODERNIZATION
PROJECTS THROUGH THE SCHOOL
FACILITIES PROGRAM. OKAY, I
WOULD JUST SAY WE WOULD LOOK
FORWARD TO THOSE CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT A BOND. AND I THINK IT'S
JUST IMPORTANT TO GET THAT
INFORMATION OUT THERE. THEN THEN
LET ME TURN TO MR. COUPON FROM
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST. AND I
THOUGHT THE ISSUE OF THE DAY IS
PROPOSITION 98 AND WHAT THE
DIFFERENT IMPACTS ARE OF THE
DIFFERENT OPTIONS. AND, AND
MAYBE MY FIRST QUESTION IS NOT
THE FAIREST IN FINANCE CAN
COMMENT BUT BUT TO START IT
WOULD BE WHAT IS THE PROBLEM WE
ARE TRYING TO SOLVE FOR HERE
WITH WHATEVER WE DO ON
PROPOSITION 98, WHAT REVENUE
SITUATION AND THINGS ARE WE
PRESENTED IN THIS BUDGET THAT WE
REALLY HAVE TO DEAL WITH AND,
AND HOW WE TAKE ACTION ON
PROPOSITION 98? YEAH WE'RE
CONTINUING TO CRUNCH THE NUMBERS
TO COME UP WITH AN OVERALL
BUDGET DEFICIT SHORTFALL NUMBER.
I THINK THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
ONE ALREADY, OURS, I THINK BASED
ON A LITTLE BIT OF A DIFFERENT
METHODOLOGY FOR CALCULATING IT
HAS BEEN HIGHER. IF WE LOOK
SPECIFICALLY AT THE PROPOSITION
98 BUDGET, I THINK THE WAY TO
THINK ABOUT IT IS THAT IT, WE'RE
GOING TO LOOK OVER A THREE YEAR
PERIOD FROM 2223 TO 2425. IN
JANUARY, THE PROPOSITION 98
GUARANTEE OVER THAT PERIOD,
DROPPED 14.3 BILLION COMPARED TO
THE ENACTED BUDGET LAST JUNE.
AND IT'S DOWN AN ADDITIONAL 3.7
BILLION IN THE MAY REVISION. SO
OVERALL, THE STATE'S DEALING
WITH AN $18.1 BILLION LOWER
PROPOSITION 98 GUARANTEE. AND
THEN IN ADDITION TO THAT,
THERE'S ABOUT 2.4 BILLION IN NEW
SPENDING FOR SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. SO WITH THAT
KIND OF, SHORTFALL, THE STATE
NEEDS 20.5 BILLION IN K 14
SOLUTIONS, ASSUMING IT'S GOING
TO FUND AT THOSE ESTIMATES OF
THE PROPOSITION 98 GUARANTEE.
AND THEN LET ME JUST ACKNOWLEDGE
TO SHORT CIRCUIT A LOT OF PUBLIC
TESTIMONY THAT THERE ARE VARIOUS
STAKEHOLDERS THAT HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT WHETHER THE GUARANTEE IS
REACHED THAT WAY, AND WE'LL LET
THAT DISCUSSION PLAY OUT. BUT I
JUST WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT.
AND THEN WE HAD A MAJOR HEARING
ON THE GOVERNOR'S MANEUVER
ALREADY. AND WHILE THE NUMBERS
CHANGED, A LITTLE IN THE MAY
REVISE, THAT STRUCTURE IS VERY
CLEAR. WHAT HAPPENS IF THE
LEGISLATURE DOES NOT APPROVE THE
GOVERNOR'S MANEUVER IN TERMS OF
FISCALLY, WHAT WHAT WOULD THE
IMPACT BE TO THE BUDGET IF WE
DID NOT APPROVE THE MANEUVER?
IT'S GOING TO BE A LITTLE OF A
LONGER ANSWER BECAUSE, A LOT OF
IT DEPENDS ON WHAT YOU DO.
INSTEAD OF MANEUVER THE STATE, I
THINK SOME OF THE WAY THE
ALTERNATIVES HAVE BEEN TALKED
ABOUT THIS, THIS SESSION IS
THAT, WELL, WHAT IF THE STATE,
INSTEAD OF FUNDING SCHOOLS AT
THE REVISED LOWER ESTIMATE OF
THE GUARANTEE IN 2223, INSTEAD
PROVIDED OR SPENT THE SAME
AMOUNT ON THEM AS IT DID BACK
WHEN IT WAS ESTIMATED IN THE
GUARANTEE LAST JUNE. SO IN 2223,
THAT DIFFERENCE IS $9.8 BILLION.
SO IF YOU WERE TO DO THAT PLAN,
FUND SCHOOLS AT THE JUNE 22ND,
JUNE 23RD LEVEL IN THE PRIOR
YEAR, THE STATE OVERALL DEFICIT
IS $9.8 BILLION LARGER. SO YOU
WOULD NEED SOME ACTIONS TO
ADDRESS THAT BEFORE YOU'D HAVE A
BALANCED BUDGET. THAT WOULD BE
SOME COMBINATION OF MOST LIKELY
DEFERRALS, SHIFTS, REDUCTIONS,
ALL OF THE THINGS, FOR EXAMPLE,
THAT WERE IN YOUR 17 BILLION
EARLY ACTION PACKAGE, YOU'D NEED
9.8 BILLION WITHOUT SPECULATING
ON WHAT THE DIFFERENT ACTIONS
WOULD BE THAT WOULD BE REQUIRED
TO TAKE. IF NOTHING IS DONE,
THERE'S $9 BILLION THAT OF
SOLUTIONS THAT HAVE TO BE COME
UP WITH AND SOME. SO YEAH THE
MINIMUM IS YOU NEED 9.8 BILLION
IN SOLUTIONS. AND ADDITIONAL
IMPLICATION OF FUNDING THAT
LEVEL IN 2223 IS YOU'D HAVE THE
PROSPECT OF WELL THAT'S A HIGHER
BASE AND IT'S GOING TO FEED INTO
THE CALCULATION OF THE GUARANTEE
IN 2324 AND 2425. NOW WE'RE
STILL LOOKING AT EXACTLY HOW
THAT WOULD AFFECT THEIR
GUARANTEE AND WHEN AND HOW MUCH
HIGHER MIGHT THE GUARANTEE BE IN
THOSE YEARS IF YOU WERE TO,
PROVIDE THAT FUNDING IN 22, 23?
BUT AT A VERY AT A MINIMUM,
YOU'D HAVE TO COME UP WITH A
9.88 BILLION. AND THE THING IS,
IS IF IT IF YOU DID WHAT IT
TOOK, THAT THE 9 BILLION WAS
ACCEPTED INTO THE GUARANTEE AND
WHATEVER PROCESS OR HOW THAT
HAPPENS, WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS
IN THE OUT YEAR, THAT WOULD MEAN
AN ADDITIONAL, AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT'S NOT BUDGETED. AND WITH
THE GOVERNOR HAVING PRESENTED A
BALANCED BUDGET FOR THE BUDGET
YEAR AND THE OUT YEAR, IT
DOESN'T JUST HAVE A BUDGET YEAR
IMPACT, IT HAS AN OUT YEAR
IMPACT IS THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
SUGGESTING? YEAH. ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES IS THAT THAT WAS A
VERY QUICK. YEAH ONE OF THE
CHALLENGE CHALLENGES IS THAT IT
DEPENDS ON A LOT OF THIS. THE
ANSWER DEPENDS ON YOUR ECONOMIC
ASSUMPTIONS. SO IN GENERAL THE
BETTER THAT REVENUE IS THE LESS,
THE DECISIONS YOU MAKE IN 2223
ARE LIKELY TO AFFECT THE
PROPOSITION 98 GUARANTEE IN
FUTURE YEARS. THE WORST THAT
REVENUE IS THE MORE THAT YOUR
DECISION ABOUT 2223, AFFECT THE
CALCULATION OF THE GUARANTEE IN
23, 24 AND, AND BEYOND. SO IT'S
SOME OF IT COMES DOWN TO WHAT WE
ASSUME HAPPENS WITH REVENUES IN
THE FUTURE YEARS. AND AGAIN,
THAT'S THAT'S SOMETHING WE'RE
STILL LOOKING INTO TRYING TO
DEVELOP OUR OWN OUTLOOK. TOTALLY
KNOW THAT RIGHT NOW. THEN LET ME
ADVANCE TO THE ISSUE THAT THERE
HAVE BEEN SOME SUGGESTIONS THAT
WE SUSPEND PROPOSITION 98. NOW,
IF THERE WAS ACTION TO SUSPEND
PROPOSITION 98, WHAT WOULD IT
MEAN WITH REGARD TO THE 8
BILLION IN THE PRIOR YEAR? THE
WHAT IS THIS YEAR? WHAT IS THE
FUTURE YEAR? WHAT WOULD A
SUSPENSION MEAN FISCALLY? SO I
THINK THE CONFUSION ABOUT
SUSPENSION IS THAT IT THE WAY
IT'S BEEN TALKED ABOUT THIS YEAR
IS THAT IT'S PAIRED WITH, IT'S
KIND OF A TWO PART ALTERNATIVE
PACKAGE. AND THE FIRST PART OF
THAT IS PROVIDING THAT
ADDITIONAL 9.8 BILLION, TO
SCHOOLS IN 22, 23. SO HAVING THE
BASE BE 9.8 BILLION HIGHER, OR
SOME NUMBER AROUND 9.8 BILLION,
AND THEN SUSPENSION IS THE
SECOND PART OF THAT. AND IT
WOULD BE INVOKED SO THAT THE
STATE WOULD NOT HAVE TO
IMMEDIATELY, PAY FOR ANY
INCREASES IN THE GUARANTEE IN
THE CURRENT AND BUDGET YEAR
RESULTING FROM THE HIGHER 9.8
BILLION IN THE PRIOR YEAR. SO
WHAT MAKES IT CONFUSING IS THAT
ORDINARILY, WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT SUSPENSION, WE'RE THINKING
ABOUT IT AS A TOOL TO REDUCE THE
PROPOSITION 98 GUARANTEE AND
SPEND LESS ON SCHOOLS TO HELP
BALANCE THE BUDGET. BUT THIS
YEAR, IT'S BEING DISCUSSED AS
PART OF A BROADER PACKAGE WHERE
WE'RE ACTUALLY SPENDING 9.8
BILLION MORE ON K 14 EDUCATION
IN THE PRIOR YEAR. AND THEN
SUSPENSION WOULD BE INVOKED TO
PREVENT THAT 9.8 BILLION FROM
GROWING TO AN EVEN LARGER
NUMBER. AND IF THERE IS A
SUSPENSION, ISN'T THERE A
DEFICIT FACTOR RELATED TO IT?
THAT'S CORRECT. SO YOU WOULD
EVENTUALLY SEE YOU WOULD
EVENTUALLY HAVE TO RECOGNIZE
THAT THE EFFECT OF THAT 9.8
BILLION HIGHER BASE IN 2223, BUT
A SUSPENSION ESSENTIALLY ALLOWS
YOU TO DELAY RECOGNIZING IT BY
NOT PROVIDING THAT FUNDING RIGHT
AWAY. BUT CREATING THIS FUTURE
OBLIGATION CALLED MAINTENANCE
FACTOR OR MAINTENANCE FACTOR, TO
EVENTUALLY RATCHET UP FUNDING,
MORE IN THE FUTURE AS REVENUES
GROW. AND SO IF THERE IS A
SUSPENSION AND THEN A DEFICIT
FACTOR, I DON'T KNOW HOW FINANCE
DOES IT, BUT SOMEHOW THAT WOULD
BE CALCULATED AS AN OUTYEAR
PROBLEM THAT WOULD BE REFLECTED
IN SOME OUTYEAR PROJECTION. YES.
SO THE, THE PAYMENT OF THAT
OBLIGATION OR THAT AMOUNT IS
CONTROLLED BY CONSTITUTIONAL
FORMULAS. AND WHEN THAT THE
STATE HAS THAT ON THE BOOKS, THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DOES
INCLUDE IT IN THEIR MULTIYEAR
PROJECTIONS, AS WE DO. AND IT
WOULD BE IT WOULD SHOW UP AS A
COST THAT INCREASES THE
PROPOSITION. BUT THERE'S NO
MANDATED TIME FRAME ON THE
DEFICIT FACTOR, IS THERE? THERE
IT'S CONTINGENT ON, HOW WELL
REVENUE IS DOING, HOW WELL STATE
REVENUES ARE DOING COMPARED TO
THE ECONOMY OVERALL. SO THOSE
FORMULAS DETERMINE THE PAYBACK
SCHEDULE IN SOME CASES, IF STATE
REVENUES ARE VERY STRONG, THE
PAYBACK CAN BE VERY LARGE AND
VERY IMMEDIATE. IF WE HAVE A
WEAK ECONOMIC ENVIRONMENT IN THE
NEXT COUPLE OF YEARS, IT MIGHT
GO A VERY LONG TIME BEFORE THE
STATE MAKES THOSE PAYMENTS.
OKAY. AND THEN, LET'S TALK ABOUT
THE OPTION OF, OF DOING A
DEFERRAL. SO LET'S SAY THAT THAT
AN EXPENDITURE WE CAN CHOOSE TO
NUMBER, LET'S SAY AN $8 BILLION
IS RECOGNIZED AS A DEFERRAL, HOW
WOULD THAT WORK AND HOW WOULD
THAT GO WITH REGARD TO FUTURE
YEARS AND WHEN IT WOULD COME DUE
? I THINK THE WAY TO THINK ABOUT
DEFERRALS IS THAT THEY'RE A ONE
TIME BUDGET SOLUTION, SORT OF
LIKE, RESERVES. SO THE STATE, IF
IT WERE TO DEFER, SAY, 4 BILLION
FROM 24, 25 TO 2526, THAT'S 4
BILLION IN SAVINGS. SO THAT'S
KIND OF ONE ALTERNATIVE WAY OF
OBTAINING SAVINGS WITHIN THE
PROPOSITION 98 BUDGET. BUT IT IS
ADDED AS A $4 BILLION OUTYEAR
COST IN A BUDGET THAT IS NOW
THEORETICALLY BALANCED. THAT'S
RIGHT. THE DOWNSIDE OF DEFERRALS
IS THAT THEN YOU GET TO THE THEY
DON'T REALLY ADDRESS THE
MISMATCH, THE ONGOING MISMATCH
BETWEEN FUNDING AND COSTS OF
PROGRAMS. SO IF YOU MAKE A
DEFERRAL, THE STATE'S
ESSENTIALLY COUNTING ON THE
PROPOSITION 98 GUARANTEE TO GROW
THE FOLLOWING YEAR, BECAUSE IF
IT DOESN'T GROW, THEN YOU NOT
ONLY NEED TO CONTINUE THE $4
BILLION DEFERRAL, BUT YOU HAVE
TO ADD MORE DEFERRALS ON TOP OF
THAT JUST TO KEEP TREADING WATER
AND BREAK EVEN WITH DEFERRALS.
UNLIKE, UNLIKE THE SUSPENSION
MAINTENANCE FACTOR OPTION, THE
STATE DOES A LITTLE BIT MORE
CONTROL OVER THE AMOUNT AND THE
TIMING OF WHEN THEY'RE REPAID.
SO IN SOME CASES, LIKE WITH THE
RECESSION, WE VERY BRIEF
RECESSION IN 2020, THE STATE
CREATED A HUGE AMOUNT OF
DEFERRALS AND PAID THEM
IMMEDIATELY. ON THE OTHER HAND,
IN THE EARLY 2000, WE CREATED A
SMALL DEFERRAL AND JUST KEPT
ROLLING OVER THAT DEFERRAL FOR
ANOTHER 12 YEARS OR SO. SO IT'S,
STATE DECIDES WHEN DEFERRALS ARE
CREATED, HOW MUCH AND WHEN
THEY'RE FINALLY REPAID. OKAY.
NOW, HAVING WALKED THROUGH THOSE
DIFFERENT OPTIONS, FOR THOSE
FOLLOWING AT HOME, THEY COULD
NOT SEE THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE PERSON WAS PERIODICALLY
NODDING, SO LET ME ASK IF YOU
WOULD HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS ON THE WAY WE HAVE
WALKED THROUGH THE DIFFERENT
OPTIONS. NO, I THINK, KEN LAID
THAT OUT QUITE WELL, THE ONE
PIECE THAT I THINK I JUST ADD
CONTEXTUALLY IS, AS WE THINK
ABOUT DEFERRALS, DEFERRALS ARE
GENERALLY SPENDING WITHIN THE
GUARANTEE PACKAGE, NOT
NECESSARILY HOW THE GUARANTEE IS
COMPUTED. SO THAT'S PROBABLY THE
ONE PIECE THAT I ADD TO THAT.
OKAY. I WOULD JUST MAKE A BRIEF
COMMENT THAT IS SORT OF OBVIOUS,
WHICH IS THAT THIS JUST LAYS OUT
A WHOLE SERIES OF OPTIONS AND
THEY ARE ALL DIFFICULT. IT IS,
EVERY SINGLE ONE SORT OF SEEMS
TO REQUIRE US TO PAY MONEY THAT
IS NOT BUDGETED, WITH THE
POSSIBLE EXCEPTION OF THE OF THE
, OF THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
MANEUVER. BUT I THINK HE I WANT
SORT OF AN UNDERSTANDING THAT WE
HAVE TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO PULL
MONEY FROM OTHER PLACES IF WE DO
CERTAIN THINGS THAT REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL COSTS AND, AND YET
THE CONSTITUTION ISSUES MAY WELL
BE THE CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUES AND
THAT MIGHT BE ABOVE SOME OF OUR
PAY GRADE. BUT, WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE INTENSE DISCUSSIONS OVER
THE NEXT FEW WEEKS ABOUT THESE
OPTIONS. AND, AND I THINK IT'S
GOOD JUST TO HAVE ON THE RECORD
WHAT THEY DON'T MEAN. AND I
JUMPED AHEAD. I DON'T KNOW IF
SENATOR CORTESE AND ACTUALLY
THAT COMPLETES MY QUESTIONS ON
ON THIS ISSUE. BUT I DON'T KNOW
IF SENATOR CORTESE HAS COMMENTS
OR ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS ON ANY
PIECE OF THIS. SENATOR CORTESE.
WELL, IN THE INTEREST OF TIME
AND YOU KNOW, PLAYING CATCH UP
HERE, I'VE OBVIOUSLY I'VE, I'M
FAMILIAR WITH, PROP 98 AND THE
OTHER SIDE OF IT, THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT SIDE OF BUDGETING. I'M
ALSO FAMILIAR WITH, BUDGET
COMMITTEE HERE, HAVING SERVED
FOR THE FIRST TWO YEARS OF MY
EXISTENCE AS A SENATOR ON
BUDGET, BUT NOT TAKING THE DEEP
DIVE LIKE WE'RE TAKING TODAY.
AND TO INTO PROP 98. AND, YOU
KNOW, SOME OF THE MACHINATIONS
THAT ARE ON THE TABLE THIS YEAR,
SO I'LL CATCH UP MORE SO AFTER
TODAY'S MEETING AND, YOU KNOW,
WITH YOURSELF, MR. CHAIR AND
STAFF AND, AND OTHERS THAT ARE
HERE TO MAKE SURE I'M, I'M
PREPARED TO, YOU KNOW, TO
CONTRIBUTE FULLY AS, AS WE GET
VERY, VERY CLOSE TO MAKING FINAL
DECISIONS HERE. I WILL SAY THAT
IT'S UNCLEAR TO ME, WITH THE
MANEUVER, IF, FOR LACK OF A
BETTER WAY. I MEAN, IT JUST
SEEMS TO BE CALLED THAT
EVERYWHERE WE LOOK. SO I'LL CALL
I'LL REFER TO IT THAT WAY, ON
PROP 98, THAT IF YOU IF YOU IF
YOU KICK THAT OVER TO THE,
FUTURE YEARS AND YOU HAVE
INCREASED REVENUE, WE HAPPEN TO
HAVE, YOU KNOW, ANOTHER BIG IPO
YEAR OR WHATEVER, AND WE HAVE AN
INCREASE AN INCREASE, THE PROP
98 GUARANTEE, THE FOR GOES UP
AND IT SEEMS TO ME THAT THAT
DOESN'T NECESSARILY CREATE A
BETTER OPPORTUNITY TO REPAY,
DEFERRALS, BUT COMPLICATES
THINGS EVEN MORE BECAUSE
SUDDENLY WE HAVE AN ADDITIONAL
COMMITMENT OR A HIGHER FOR THAT
IN EFFECT TAKES AWAY FROM FROM
OTHER GENERAL FUND PRIORITIES BY
DESIGN AND I FULLY SUPPORT PROP
98. SO THOSE ARE THE KIND OF
QUESTIONS I HAVE. AND I
APPRECIATED, YOU KNOW, IN THE IN
THE PRESENTATIONS, THIS IDEA
THAT IT DEPENDS, REMINDS ME OF
AN OLD, SET OF LAW SCHOOL
QUESTIONS WAY BACK WHEN YOU
KNOW, THE YOU GET INTO THESE
KIND OF SITUATIONS AND THERE'S
NOT JUST A CLEAR RULE THAT YOU
CAN APPLY IT DEPENDS ON, ON WHAT
HAPPENS WITH REVENUE AND SO
FORTH. SO I GOT THAT LOUD AND
CLEAR. BUT, I WANTED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT I NEED TO
PROBABLY PLAY WITH SOME OF THOSE
POTENTIAL FACT PATTERNS. I THINK
THAT'S A WAY FOR ME TO DO IT
ALMOST. LOOK FORWARD AT CASE
STUDIES AND SAY, YOU KNOW, WHAT
HAPPENS IF THIS WHAT HAPPENS IF
THIS WHAT HAPPENS WITH THIS?
I'VE APPRECIATED, MR. CHAIR,
YOUR, INSISTENCE THAT WE LOOK
HARD AT THIS. AND I KNOW YOU'VE
BEEN DOING THIS FOR A WHILE,
INCLUDING NOT JUST IN
SACRAMENTO, BUT INCLUDING, BACK
HOME IN THE DISTRICT, IN THE BAY
AREA AND TRYING TO EXPLAIN TO
PEOPLE THAT, IN SOME SENSE, THIS
IS A ZERO SUM GAME. WHICHEVER
WAY YOU DO IT, AND THEREFORE
IT'S A DEFERRAL OF PAIN, NOT A
DEFERRAL OF, OF ANY KIND OF
PERMANENCY THAT GETS US OUT OF
PAIN. I APPRECIATE THAT VERY
MUCH. AND I'LL STOP THERE FOR
TODAY. OKAY. THANK YOU. I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS AND
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
IN ANY WAY THAT IS HELPFUL. AND
LET ME THANK THE PANEL, BECAUSE
I KNOW THIS IS, GOING TO BE AT
THE HEART OF THE DISCUSSIONS THE
NEXT FEW WEEKS, AND I THINK I
WANTED TO MAKE SURE EVERYBODY
UNDERSTOOD ALL THE PERMUTATIONS
AND WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN. AND
I LOOK FORWARD TO THE
DISCUSSIONS, ON A BOND, BECAUSE
I KNOW THE DEADLINE FOR THAT IS
ALMOST THE SAME DEADLINE AS FOR
THE BUDGET. AND SO WE WILL HAVE
TO DO THAT. SO I APPRECIATE
THAT. AND WE WILL MOVE ON TO
PART B OF THE AGENDA. AND IF IT
IS THE, UNIVERSITY OF, OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM, AND IT
IS THE BASE BUDGET REDUCTIONS,
AND IT WE WILL HAVE, CHRIS
FERGUSON FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE, JENNIFER PEZZELLA FROM
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE, SHIVANAND FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA, CHERYL
IDE FROM THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM, AND, AND WE
WILL HAVE A DISCUSSION IN THAT,
THE GOVERNOR, IN HIS JANUARY
10TH BUDGET, PROPOSED KEEPING
THE CONTACT COMPACTS AND
DEFERRING THE 5% DUE IN THE NEXT
YEAR TO THE SUBSEQUENT YEAR. AND
THERE'S A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
PROPOSAL ON THE TABLE NOW. SO
LET'S BEGIN BY GOING TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. YEAH.
CHRIS FERGUSON WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. SO AS IT
RELATES TO ISSUE ONE, THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSES A COUPLE OF
ADJUSTMENTS IN THE BUDGET YEAR
FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
AND THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY, IN PARTICULAR, IT IS
A ONE TIME REDUCTION OF
125,000,000 IN 2425. AND THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA'S BASE
OPERATIONS SUPPORT AND FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY. IT WOULD BE A
ONE TIME REDUCTION OF 75 MILLION
IN THE BUDGET YEAR TO THEIR BASE
OPERATIONS AND SUPPORT, IN 2526,
THAT WOULD BE REPLACED WITH A
7.95% REDUCTION, TO EACH OF
THOSE BUDGETS. SO THAT
75,000,125 MILLION WOULD BE
ADDED BACK AND THEN REPLACED BY
THAT 7.95% REDUCTION, I DON'T
HAVE THE SPECIFIC FIGURES IN
FRONT OF ME, BUT IT'S JUST UNDER
400 MILLION EACH FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY.
STARTING IN THE 2526 FISCAL
YEAR. HOWEVER, THIS LAYERS ON
TOP OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSALS AROUND THE DEFERRAL,
WHICH IS SUSTAINED IN THE MAY
REVISION, AS WELL AS THE 10,
COMPACT ADJUSTMENTS THAT WOULD
BE PAID IN 2526, WHICH REPRESENT
THE 5% FROM 2425 AND THE 5% FROM
2526. OUR EXPECTATIONS AROUND
THE COMPACTS REMAIN, IN EXCHANGE
FOR THOSE, 5% ADJUSTMENTS, WE
WOULD EXPECT THE SYSTEMS TO
CONTINUE MAKING PROGRESS TOWARDS
THE GOAL OF THE COMPACTS.
JENNIFER PURCELL, LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE SO AS YOU HEARD
FINANCE DESCRIBE, THE MAY
REVISION STILL CONTAINS THE
DEFERRALS, THE ONE TIME
PAYMENTS, BUT THEN IN ADDITION,
LAYERS ON THESE BASE REDUCTIONS.
SO AS BASE INCREASES AND BASE
REDUCTIONS, THE BASE REDUCTIONS
ARE ROLLED INTO A BROADER
PROPOSAL BY THE ADMINISTRATION
AFFECTING STATE OPERATIONS. SO
WE THINK THIS APPROACH THAT HAS
INCREASES AND REDUCTIONS AND
EMBEDDING PROPOSALS WITHIN
PROPOSALS IS RATHER COMPLICATED
AND OPAQUE. SO WE WOULD
RECOMMEND YOU TAKE A MORE
TRANSPARENT, STRAIGHTFORWARD
APPROACH. AGAIN, GIVEN THE
DEFICIT AND GIVEN THE DEFICIT IS
EVEN LARGER NOW THAN IN JANUARY,
WE'D SUGGEST THAT, THE
UNIVERSITIES CONTAIN THEIR
SPENDING, THAT THE STATE NOT
MAKE COMMITMENTS FOR 2526, THAT
IT MIGHT NOT BE ABLE TO FULFILL.
SO WHEN IT COMES TO BALANCING
THE 2425 BUDGET, YOU MIGHT
DECIDE IN YOUR BUDGET, BALANCING
THAT REDUCTIONS TO UC AND CSU IN
2425 ARE REQUIRED, YOU CAN
CHOOSE TO DO THE LEVELS PROPOSED
IN THE MAY REVISION, SO YOU
COULD CUT UC BY 125 MILLION AND
REDUCE CSU BY 75 MILLION. YOU
COULD DECIDE AS PART OF YOUR
BUDGET CLOSEOUT TO CHANGE THOSE
AMOUNTS TO DO MORE OR LESS AS
NEEDED TO BUILD YOUR PACKAGE.
WE'D NOTE THAT THERE ARE A FEW
FACTORS THAT WOULD MITIGATE A
GENERAL FUND BASED REDUCTION.
BOTH SEGMENTS ARE RAISING
TUITION. YOU'VE TALKED ABOUT
THAT IN EARLIER HEARINGS. BOTH
SEGMENTS HAVE CORE RESERVES. NOW
SOME OF THOSE RESERVES ARE
COMMITTED. THE UNIVERSITIES
MIGHT NEED TO GO BACK AND
REVISIT SOME OF THOSE
COMMITMENTS. AND THEN CSU IS
FUNDED FOR APPROXIMATELY 17,000
STUDENTS THAT IT'S NOT
ENROLLING. SO THAT'S ALSO SOME
ROOM TO MAKE BUDGET ADJUSTMENTS.
IN THOSE CASES WHEN IT COMES TO
ACTUALLY MAKING THE REDUCTIONS.
SO REGARDLESS OF THE SIZE OF THE
REDUCTION YOU MAKE, YOU HAVE
CHOICES THERE AS WELL AS TO HOW
YOU GO ABOUT MAKING IT. YOU CAN
TAKE A CORE, AN ALLOCATED CUT TO
THE CORE PROGRAM. YOU CAN FOCUS
ON DIFFERENT SECTORS OF THEIR
BUDGETS, WHETHER IT'S
INSTITUTIONAL SUPPORT, RESEARCH,
STUDENT SUPPORT, TAKE MORE
TARGETED CUTS, OR LOOK AT
EARMARKS THAT HAVE HISTORICALLY
BEEN EMBEDDED IN THE BUDGETS AND
SURGICALLY REMOVE PARTICULAR
LINE ITEMS. ANY APPROACH YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE, PROS AND CONS,
THEY'RE GOING TO APPEAR
DIFFICULT. WE COULD HELP IF YOU
DECIDE YOU WANT TO PURSUE ONE
APPROACH OVER THE OTHER, BUT
AGAIN, OUR BOTTOM LINE IS JUST
TO TAKE A MORE STRAIGHTFORWARD
AND TRANSPARENT APPROACH. IF YOU
NEED TO CUT THEM IN 24, 25,
DECIDE THE LEVEL, THEN REVISIT
IN 2526, YOU'LL HAVE MUCH BETTER
INFORMATION 12 MONTHS FROM NOW
AS TO WHAT 2526 LOOKS LIKE.
THANK YOU. WE'RE MAKING
PANELISTS LIFE MISERABLE BY
HAVING A SIMULTANEOUS HEARING IN
THE ASSEMBLY AND THE SENATE. AND
SO I THINK THAT'S WHERE THE èC
REPRESENTATIVE IS THAT I
ANNOUNCED. AND SO MICHAEL BEDARD
IS HERE FOR èC. IF YOU'D LIKE
TO MAKE ANY STATEMENT, I'LL MAKE
ME GO FIRST. I AM NOT, SAY, A
TENANT. I AM MICHAEL BEDARD.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, MR.
CHAIR, ON BEHALF OF THE
UNIVERSITY, WE RECOGNIZE THE
SIGNIFICANT BUDGET CHALLENGE
BEING FACED AND THE PROPOSED
REDUCTIONS FOR THE UNIVERSITY
REFLECT THAT REALITY. THE MAY
REVISE PROPOSES $125 MILLION CUT
FOR THE UNIVERSITY IN 24, 25 AND
IN 2526. THE PROPOSAL IS TO
PROVIDE UC WITH A SERIES OF
REDUCTIONS AND INCREASES THAT,
ONCE TOTALED, WOULD NET AN
INCREASE OF 2.4, OR 252 MILLION,
OVER THE 2324 BUDGET YEAR, FOR
THE COMING BUDGET YEAR, WITH OUR
CUTS AND OUR EXPECTED BASE, COST
GROWTH ACROSS THE SYSTEM, WE
WOULD EXPECT TO SEE A $258.8
MILLION GAP THAT NEEDS TO BE
COVERED BY CAMPUSES. THIS WILL
IMPACT OUR OPERATIONS AND WILL
BE PAINFUL TO ABSORB, BUT THERE
ARE OPTIONS WE'RE EXPLORING,
INCLUDING THROUGH REVENUE GROWTH
AND COST CUTTING. SO, SOME OF
THOSE OPTIONS REALLY AREN'T ON
THE TABLE MUCH FOR THIS YEAR,
SINCE FEES AND OTHER THINGS HAVE
ALREADY BEEN SET FOR THE COMING
ACADEMIC YEAR IN FISCAL YEAR.
AND SO WE HAVE SOME COST CUTTING
OPTIONS. WE'RE LOOKING AT,
INCLUDING SALARY PROGRAMS AND
SALARY NEGOTIATIONS, UC
RETIREMENT PROGRAM CONTRIBUTIONS
AND NEGOTIATING HEALTH CARE
COSTS FOR 2425. UC IS UNABLE TO
CHANGE SOME OF SOME OF THE OTHER
COSTS THAT WE COULD OTHERWISE
ADDRESS. THE CAMPUSES RECEIVED
THE STATE'S GENERAL FUND
ALLOCATION THROUGH A FORMULA. WE
WILL INTEND TO PASS THOSE
REDUCTIONS ON TO THE CAMPUSES
THROUGH THE SAME FORMULA.
CAMPUSES WILL THEN DETERMINE HOW
BEST TO IMPLEMENT THE REDUCTIONS
AT THOSE LOCATIONS. OPTIONS THE
METHODS USED IN THE PAST. WE
EXPECT, WILL BE PART OF THE
SOLUTIONS AGAIN THIS YEAR,
INCLUDING NOT FILLING POSITIONS
EMPLOYMENT POSITIONS AS THEY
BECOME VACANT. CAMPUSES
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT 8% TURNOVER
IN POSITIONS. SO WHAT THIS MEANS
IN TERMS OF THE REAL IMPACT WILL
BE POTENTIALLY LONGER WAIT TIMES
FOR ADVISING APPOINTMENTS, FOR
FOOD SERVICE, FOR FINANCIAL AID
ASSISTANCE, THINGS LIKE THAT,
BECAUSE THERE IS NO NEW FUNDING
COMING FOR LADDER RANK FACULTY,
CLASSES MAY BE IMPACTED, CLASS
SIZES MAY BE IMPACTED, THEY MAY
NEED TO PUT OFF MAINTENANCE.
THAT WOULD OTHER THAT'S
OTHERWISE NOT ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL. LEADING TO INCREASING
DEMAND FOR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
FUNDING. AND I'LL PUT IN A PLUG
HERE FOR HIGHER EDUCATION
INCLUDED IN THE EDUCATION
FACILITIES BOND. CAMPUSES ALSO
MAY HAVE TO DELAY TECHNOLOGY
PROJECTS THAT WOULD OTHERWISE
BRING EFFICIENCIES, AND
POTENTIALLY ENDING NEW PROGRAMS
THAT HAVE SHOWN PROMISE TO HELP
FIRST GEN STUDENTS AND STUDENTS
FROM OTHER UNDERREPRESENTED
GROUPS, LIKE EARLY SUMMER START
PROGRAMS. THESE CUTS MAY BE
PAINFUL, AND STUDENTS WILL SEE
AN IMPACT. HOWEVER, WITHIN THIS
CHALLENGE IS ALSO AN OPPORTUNITY
TO ENVISION NEW WAYS OF
CONNECTING WITH STUDENTS AND
ENSURING THAT THE UNIVERSITY
EXAMINES EDUCATIONAL PROGRAM
OFFERINGS. A GREAT DEAL OF
UNCERTAINTY REMAINS FOR THE NEXT
FISCAL YEAR. AFTER THAT, 25 TO
26, AND WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT THE
COMPACT FUNDING WILL BE A PART
OF OUR 2526 FUNDING. I WOULD
LASTLY LIKE TO REQUEST THAT THE
COMMITTEE AND GOVERNOR CONSIDER
SOME EXCEPTIONS TO THE PROPOSED
7.9% BASE BUDGET REDUCTION FOR
UC. THE FIRST OF THESE IS THE
EXCLUSION OF BOND DEBT PAYMENTS
FROM THE 7.9% CALCULATION. SINCE
THE UNIVERSITY CANNOT SPEND
THOSE FUNDS ON CAMPUS OPERATIONS
. THE SECOND IS TO ALLOW FOR
REDUCTIONS TO SOME LEGISLATIVE
MANDATED PROGRAM FUNDS THAT
WOULD OTHERWISE BE KEPT WHOLE
WHILE CAMPUS BUDGETS ARE REDUCED
AROUND THEM. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND
NOW WE'LL MOVE TO THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS. I'M
SHIRLEY DOWD, THE DIRECTOR OF
BUDGET ADVOCACY, ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY,
WE APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DISCUSS OUR REACTION TO THE
MAYOR VISION AND ITS IMPACT ON
THE SYSTEM, THE DEFERRAL AND
CUTS IN THE MAYOR VISION
PRESENTS SEVERAL CHALLENGES TO
THE CSU. EACH CAMPUS IS
PREPARING AND DEVELOPING
SPECIFIC STRATEGIES TO ADDRESS
THEIR BUDGETS, WHICH MAY INCLUDE
CONSOLIDATING PROGRAMS,
ADJUSTING CLASS SIZES, FREEZING
NEW HIRES, AND OFFERING
VOLUNTARY SEPARATION PROGRAMS
ALL TO REDUCE EXPENSES WHILE
CAREFULLY MINIMIZING DISRUPTIONS
TO STUDENTS AND STAFF. DESPITE
THE PREPARATIONS AND REDUCTIONS,
THE PROJECTED $345 MILLION
OPERATING BUDGET GAP FOR 2425
REPRESENTS A SIGNIFICANT
FINANCIAL CHALLENGE FOR THE CSU.
THIS GAP IS AKIN TO THE ENTIRE
BUDGET OF CSU BAKERSFIELD AND
CSU STANISLAUS. AN EXAMPLE OF A
SIGNIFICANT COST INCREASE IS THE
HEALTH CARE PREMIUMS. THEY HAVE
BALLOONED OVER HISTORIC
INCREASES SIX FOLD, WITHOUT ANY
INCREASES IN BENEFIT COVERAGE
FOR EXAMPLE, THEY'VE BEEN $12
MILLION ANNUALLY, BUT THEY
BALLOONED TO $78 MILLION IN
BUDGET YEAR, UNALLOCATED CUTS.
WHILE WE ARE PRINCIPALLY OPPOSED
TO CUTS, WE RECOGNIZE THE FISCAL
CLIMATE IN THE STATE IS
CURRENTLY IN AND APPRECIATE THE
FLEXIBILITY OF AN UNALLOCATED
CUT AS OPPOSED AS PROPOSED BY
THE MAYOR. VISION. THIS ALLOWS
THE CSU TO PINPOINT THE
REDUCTIONS WITH THE LEAST
DISRUPTIVE, LEAST DISRUPTION TO
OUR CORE MISSION, AND WE
APPRECIATE THE DIFFERENTIATION
BETWEEN THE SEGMENTS IN THIS
CUT, WHICH RECOGNIZES THE
LIMITATIONS AND CONTRASTS OF
FUNDING BETWEEN THE TWO TWO
SYSTEMS, OUR ENROLLMENT IS ON AN
UPWARD TRAJECTORY WITH
ENROLLMENT FOR THE CURRENT
ACADEMIC YEAR UP 2. MORE THAN
7500 STUDENTS. WE ALSO ENROLLED
THE LARGEST FRESHMAN CLASS IN
CSU'S HISTORY, MORE THAN 64,000
CALIFORNIANS. WE RECOGNIZE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S INTENT TO KEEP
THE COMPACT GOALS INTACT,
INCLUDING ENROLLMENT GROWTH, AS
THIS IS A SHARED GOAL BY ALL
PARTIES. HOWEVER, IT DOES NOT GO
WITHOUT ACKNOWLEDGING THE
ENROLLMENT THREATS THAT WE ARE
FACING HEAD ON, SUCH AS THE
IMPACTS FACED BY OUR MIXED
STATUS STUDENTS AND THE
CHALLENGES TO COMPLETE THE
FAFSA. ADDITIONALLY THE NEED TO
EXTEND THE MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP DEADLINE, WHICH WE
APPRECIATE, IS PROPOSED IN THE
MAY REVISION. THE MAYOR REVISION
WILL ALSO ALSO HAS A
SUBSTANTIALLY REDUCTION TO THE
MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP, WHICH
WOULD IMPACT 200,000 CSU
STUDENTS DECISIONS TO SEEK
HIGHER EDUCATION AND ANY
LEGISLATION THAT WOULD DUPLICATE
THE ROUTE TO THE BACHELOR'S
DEGREE, CAUSING COMPETITION FOR
ENROLLMENT BETWEEN THE CSU AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. DESPITE
THESE CHALLENGES, THE CSU
REMAINS COMMITTED TO AND WE WILL
DO OUR BEST WITH LESS FUNDING TO
FULFILL THE GOALS OUTLINED IN
THE COMPACT AGREEMENT. ALSO, WE
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND LEGISLATURE
FOR THE SPEEDIEST RETURN TO NEW
STATE INVESTMENTS IN THE CSU TO
ENSURE SUCCESSFUL OUTCOMES FOR
OUR STUDENTS. THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR ALLOWING US TO PROVIDE
FEEDBACK, AND I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND
LET ME ASK UC AND CSU TO BEGIN
THE QUESTIONING. THE REVENUE
FROM THE STATE SIDE FOR THE
COMPACTS IS NOT BUDGETED FOR
THIS YEAR. ARE YOU INTENDING TO
CONTINUE TO HONOR THE CONTRACT
COMPACTS EVEN THOUGH THE BUDGET
MONEY ISN'T THERE FOR IT? AND I
DON'T KNOW WHICH ONE OF YOU WANT
BOTH OF YOU LOOK LIKE YOU WANT
THE OTHER ONE TO GO FIRST. YES,
WE INTEND TO, TO HONOR THE TERMS
OF THE COMPACT. AGAIN,
RECOGNIZING THAT THERE'S A
COMMITMENT AND THE DEFERRAL, A
DEFERRED FUNDING FOR NEXT FISCAL
YEAR. YEAH, I WOULD ECHO THAT
SAME SENTIMENT. WE VIEW THESE AS
SHARED GOALS AMONGST ALL
PARTIES, AND WE INTEND TO
FULFILL OUR PART OF THEM. AND
THEN WE WOULD JUST ASK AND
RECOGNIZE THAT IF THE SITUATION
WERE TO CHANGE IN ECONOMICALLY
IN FUTURE YEARS, THAT WE WOULD
BE ABLE TO REVISIT, RESTORING
COMPACT FUNDING TO ITS ORIGINAL
LEVELS. AND THEN LET ME ASK THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IF, HOW
DOES THE ISSUE OF DEFERRALS WORK
INTO THIS? IF I HAD OFFERED THE
OPINION WHEN WE HEARD UC AND CSU
THE FIRST TIME AROUND BEFORE THE
MAY REVISE THAT I THOUGHT THEY
WERE REMARKABLY TRUSTING THAT
THAT THE MONEY COULD BE DEFERRED
AND WOULD SHOW UP IN THE NEXT
YEAR. AND NOW TURNS OUT THAT'S
NOT WHAT'S HAPPENING IN SOME
WAYS. SO IS IT YOUR EXPECTATION
THAT YOU WILL MEET THESE
DEFERRAL OBLIGATIONS SO THAT
THEY'RE KEEPING WITH THE
CONTRACT COMPACTS IS GOING TO
WORK? YEAH, IT'S STILL OUR
EXPECTATION TO MEET THE DEFERRAL
AS WE HAVE BUDGET TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO, TO CODIFY THOSE
PAYMENTS, SO YEAH, CERTAINLY
STILL, FULLY ON BOARD. I WOULD
ACTUALLY SAY THAT RELATIVE TO
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET, THE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS SHOULD HAVE
ADDITIONAL ASSURANCES THAT THOSE
PAYMENTS WOULD BE ABLE TO BE
MADE BECAUSE OUR STRUCTURE AT
THE MAY REVISION IS ATTEMPTING
TO ADDRESS THE BUDGET SHORTFALLS
IN BOTH 2425 AND 2526. AND IF
BUT YOU CAN CODIFY SOMETHING AND
YOU CAN, CODIFY IT. SO THAT IS
BASICALLY THE BEST ASSURANCE
YOU'RE TRYING TO GIVE TO UC AND
CSU. THEN LET ME ASK A COUPLE OF
INDIVIDUAL QUESTIONS. AND TO CSU
YOU HAVE LABOR CONTRACTS THAT,
AND THE ONE I'M MOST FAMILIAR
WITH, BUT I THINK THERE'S TWO
OTHERS. IS WITH THE FACULTY THAT
IF THE BASE FUNDING DROPS,
THEY'RE NOT OBLIGATED FOR A
CERTAIN INCREASE. THAT WAS
NEGOTIATED IN THERE. IS THAT
CORRECT? IS IF THIS IF THIS
HOLDS, WHAT IS PROPOSED FOR THE
CUT IN BASE FUNDING? DOES THAT
MEAN YOU'RE NOT OBLIGATED TO PAY
THAT PIECE OF THE CONTRACT THAT
WAS PREDICATED ON CONTINUED NO
CUTS IN BASE FUNDING? SO WE'RE
STILL REVIEWING IT. WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL INCLUDES A ONE TIME
CUT, BUT I THINK THAT WE'RE
STILL TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THE
TECHNICAL OR THE CONTRACT IS
REALLY CLEAR. IT'S LIKE IF THE
BASE FUNDING IS CUT, YOU'RE NOT
OBLIGATED TO PAY THAT SALARY
INCREASE. ARE YOU STILL SAYING
YOU NEED TO LOOK AT IT TO SEE IF
THAT'S NOT THE CASE? WE'RE STILL
REVIEWING THIS. AS FAR AS IT'S A
MAY PROPOSAL, WE'D LIKE TO SEE
WHAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS IN MIND
AND GO FROM THERE BEFORE WE MAKE
ANY KIND OF DECISION. SO
OBVIOUSLY YOU WON'T MAKE A FINAL
DECISION UNTIL A BUDGET IS
ADOPTED. BUT IF THIS BUDGET WERE
ADOPTED, IT SEEMS FAIRLY CLEAR
THAT THEY'RE NOT GOING TO GET
THAT PAY INCREASE. I THINK I
WOULDN'T WANT TO OPINE ON IT AT
THIS POINT. OKAY, WELL, I LOOK
FORWARD TO SOMEBODY OPINING,
BECAUSE IT'S PRETTY CLEAR WHAT'S
IN THE BUDGET. AND THERE AND
THEN LET ME ASK BOTH OF YOU, AND
YOU SORT OF DID THIS IN YOUR
STATEMENTS, BUT HOW WILL YOU
COMPENSATE FOR THE LOST REVENUE
OVER JUST THE CONTINUED BASE
FUNDING AT THE CURRENT LEVEL AND
A 5% INCREASE? HOW WILL YOU,
REFLECT THAT IN EXPENDITURES AND
THE BUDGET? AND LET'S START WITH
CSU. YEAH, WE'RE STILL WE'RE
STILL REVIEWING IT. OBVIOUSLY,
THIS JUST CAME OUT ON FRIDAY.
AND SO WE WERE OPERATING AND
PLANNING BASED ON WHAT WE SAW IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. AND NOW
SEEING THAT WE HAVE THE CUTS AND
THEN AS WELL AS THE DEFERRAL AND
THE REDUCTION IN THE COMPACT
FUNDS, WE HAVEN'T FULLY FLESHED
OUT WHAT WE'RE GOING TO DO. SO
WE'RE STILL ADJUSTING. AND I
APPRECIATE THAT. BUT WE ARE
HAVING TO MAKE THE DECISION AND
YOU HAVING REVIEWED US, US NOT
KNOWING WHAT IT IS MIGHT
INFLUENCE OUR DECISION. IF WE
HAD A CLEAR UNDERSTANDING. SO
WILL YOU COMMIT TO GETTING US
THOSE ANSWERS THE MINUTE YOU
FIGURE OUT WHAT THEY ARE? YES,
WE CAN FOLLOW UP WITH YOU. OKAY.
THANK YOU. LET'S GO TO èC.
YEAH. I DON'T THINK THAT WE HAVE
ANYTHING, YOU KNOW, 100% FIRMED
UP, PARTICULARLY BECAUSE THIS
FUNDING WOULD BE FUNNELED
THROUGH TO THE CAMPUSES TO MAKE
ALLOCATIONS ON THEIR OWN. I CAN
SPEAK A LITTLE BIT TO WHAT, AS A
SYSTEM, UCOP MIGHT DO, BASED ON
ON PAST HISTORY AND THINGS THAT
I KNOW THAT ARE GOING ON. SO ONE
OF THE THINGS I MENTIONED IS WE
COULD EVALUATE THE AMOUNT OF
CONTRIBUTIONS TO èC RETIREMENT
PLAN. THAT WOULD BE AN OPTION,
WE COULD REEVALUATE WHAT OTHER
SALARY PLANS FOR NON-REPRESENTED
EMPLOYEES. THERE WAS, AN
ANNOUNCED, I THINK 4% OR SO
INCREASE FOR NON-REPRESENTED
EMPLOYEES AT THE UNIVERSITY THAT
, YOU KNOW, WAS, I THINK THE
PRESIDENT'S LANGUAGE HAD IT
PARTIALLY CONTINGENT ON WHAT THE
STATE BUDGET LOOKS LIKE. THERE'S
A POSSIBILITY OF A SYSTEM WIDE
HIRING FREEZE ON CAMPUSES.
AGAIN, THEY COULD INSTITUTE
HIRING FREEZES. THEY COULD CUT
DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS. THEY
COULD, DO PROPORTIONAL
REDUCTIONS TO STUDENT SERVICES
AND OTHER PROGRAMING LIKE THAT.
AND THEN, OF COURSE, DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AGAIN, PLUG THE BOND
HERE FOR INCLUDING HIGHER ED,
THE UNIVERSITY HAS MANY TENS OF
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE ACROSS THE SYSTEM
AND HAS NOT BEEN INCLUDED IN A
FACILITIES BOND THAT HAS PASSED
IN NEARLY 20 YEARS. SO WE WOULD
PROBABLY CONTINUE TO TRY AND
FIND WAYS TO, YOU KNOW, KEEP OUR
FACILITIES OPERATIONAL, WITHOUT
REALLY ADDRESSING SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT NEEDED TO, TO
PREVENT US FROM GETTING TO,
REALLY BAD. YES Þ I JUST ONE
QUICK FOLLOW UP QUESTION AND
THEN I'M GOING TO GO TO SENATOR
CORTESE AND AS I HAVE THIS
RECOLLECTION THAT èC DID NOT
PAY INTO THE PENSION SYSTEM FOR
A NUMBER OF YEARS, IS IT SOLVENT
? IT IS THE OPTION OF NOT PAYING
INTO THE PENSION SYSTEM
SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO AFFECT
THE SOLVENCY OF THE SYSTEM?
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION. I KNOW
THAT FOR SOME TIME THERE WAS
THERE WERE NO EMPLOYEE
CONTRIBUTIONS, BUT I DON'T KNOW
THE DETAILS OF ITS SOLVENCY. I'D
HAVE TO HAVE. OKAY IF YOU'D
REPORT BACK TO US BECAUSE SORT
OF SAYING THAT MIGHT BE A CUT.
THAT IS A VERY RELEVANT, FACT.
SO JENNIFER PETRELLA FROM
ANALYST'S OFFICE. SO WHEN IT
COMES TO USURP IN THE 90S, THERE
WAS WHAT SOME FOLKS CALL LIKE A
CONTRIBUTION HOLIDAY. THERE WERE
NO CONTRIBUTIONS MADE ON THE
EMPLOYER OR EMPLOYEE SIDE, AS MY
UNDERSTANDING, WHEN THE STOCK
DURING THE GREAT DEPRESSION,
THINGS REALLY TURNED AROUND. AND
SO èC HAS HAD A GREAT
RECESSION, RIGHT? I'M SORRY.
WHAT DID I SAY? OH, I'M SO
SORRY. BECAUSE I KNOW IT DIDN'T
TURN AROUND IN THE 1930S, YEAH,
SO THEY HAVE REINSTITUTED
EMPLOYER AND EMPLOYEE
CONTRIBUTION RATES. I THINK WHAT
MIGHT BE ON THE TABLE, IF I'M
HEARING CORRECTLY, IS JUST AN
ADJUSTMENT TO WHETHER IT'S A 14%
OR A 16. AND I THINK THEY HAVE
TO CONTINUE. I THINK THAT
HOLIDAY WENT WAY PAST THE 1990S
OF PAYMENTS IN, BECAUSE I WASN'T
IN THE LEGISLATURE UNTIL 2002,
AND I KNOW IT WAS GOING IN THAT
DECADE. SO THAT'S NEITHER HERE
NOR THERE. IT STILL BEGS THE
QUESTION OF SOLVENCY. AND
THEY'RE GOING TO REPORT BACK.
AND THANK YOU. WE APPRECIATE
YOUR ANSWER, SENATOR CORTESE,
THANK YOU. JUST ON THIS ISSUE OF
, WHAT HAPPENS WITH THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING, TRIGGERS
OR PROVISIONS, WHAT? I'M JUST
WANTING TO DO SOME ACTIVE
LISTENING HERE, AND CORRECT ME
IF I'M NOT HEARING THIS
CORRECTLY, BUT WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT THINGS LIKE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE BEING A IS WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT DEFERRED MAINTENANCE,
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THAT AS
BEING A POTENTIAL ONE TIME
OFFSET TO MEET THOSE
OBLIGATIONS, I'M OR WAS THAT
JUST A COMPLETELY SEPARATE
THOUGHT? WHAT I THOUGHT I WAS
HEARING IS, WELL, SOME CONTINUED
CAMPUSES MIGHT LOBBYING FOR
FURTHER DELAY. SOME PROJECTS
THAT ARE NOT DIRECTLY, AFFECTING
LIFE, HEALTH AND SAFETY. YEAH.
I'M NOT SAYING I'M OPPOSED TO
IT. I'M JUST TRYING TO GET
CLEARER. WAS THAT A KIND OF A
LITANY OF THINGS THAT. OH, YEAH,
LITANY OF THINGS THAT OF THINGS
THAT CAMPUSES COULD CHOOSE FROM.
AND I'M SURE CIA OR OTHERS IN
OUR OFFICE OR ON THE CAMPUSES
COULD GIVE A BETTER, EXPLANATION
OF WHAT'S ON THE TABLE. I'M
SORRY, I'M PINCH HITTING, AND
THAT'S GOOD ENOUGH FOR ME FOR
TODAY. AT HIGH LEVEL, IT SOUNDS
LIKE YOU HAVE SOME OPTIONS UNDER
CONSIDERATION THAT MIGHT,
PRECLUDE THE NECESSITY OF, OF
NOT MEETING WHAT WOULD OTHERWISE
BE THE COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
OBLIGATIONS AND JUST TRYING TO
MAKE SURE TO BE CLEAR, WE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA HAS NOT
SUGGESTED WE WILL NOT MEET THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING OBLIGATION
THAT WE'VE ALREADY AGREED TO
WITH THE CHAIR DID SUGGEST THAT
IT SOUNDED LIKE YOU WERE
RESPONDING WITH, SOME POTENTIAL
WAYS TO AVOID THAT FROM
HAPPENING, I MENTIONED THE
NON-REPRESENTED SALARY AS AN
OFFSET AGAINST IT. JUST SOUNDED
LIKE THERE WAS ONE PLACE THAT
YOU SAID THAT THAT IF THERE WAS
A DECREASE, IT MIGHT REFLECT IN
THE SALARIES. WAS THAT A
MISINTERPRETATION, THE NOTES I
HAVE, SAY, REEVALUATE THE SALARY
PLAN FOR NON-REPRESENTED
EMPLOYEES. OKAY. I DON'T THINK
IT CAME OUT THAT WAY. SORRY, BUT
IT'S GLAD THAT. YEAH, I, I MAY
HAVE MISHEARD THAT. I THOUGHT
THAT WAS PART OF, THAT WAS ONE
OF THE WAYS THAT THE UNIVERSITY
MIGHT THAT èC MIGHT TRY TO, MY
A BUCKET THAT èC MIGHT REACH
INTO TO DEAL WITH THE, THE
BARGAINED, THE CONTRACTUAL
OBLIGATIONS THAT HAS BY GOING
INTO NON-REPRESENTED SALARIES
WHERE THERE WAS NO COMMITMENT TO
MAKE THOSE PAYMENTS, IF THERE
WERE BUDGETARY CONSIDERATIONS
AND MAYBE MOVED MONEY OVER ON A
TEMPORARY BASIS. THAT'S THAT'S
WHAT I THOUGHT I WAS HEARING. TO
MY KNOWLEDGE, THERE IS NO THERE
HAS BEEN NO DISCUSSION TO MY
KNOWLEDGE OF REDUCING ANY
CONTRACTUALLY AGREED TO SALARY
INCREASES. WE ARE CONSTANTLY
HAVE ROLLING CONTRACTS, YOU
KNOW, WITH OUR WHATEVER 17
SYSTEM WIDE UNITS AND 1518. I
CAN UNDERSTAND THE
NON-REPRESENTED BECAUSE THAT'S
NOT ASSIGNED. THAT'S RIGHT.
OKAY. AND JUST FOR THE RECORD,
CSU DID DO A DISTINCTLY
DIFFERENT ONE WHERE THEY REALLY
TIED SOME OF THEIR SALARIES TO
THE BUDGET ALLOCATIONS. YEAH, IT
SOUNDED LIKE TWO VERY DIFFERENT
APPROACHES. ONE, I'M NOT SURE
WHAT CSU'S APPROACH IS AT
LISTENING TODAY IN TERMS OF
CONTINGENT, YOU KNOW,
CONTINGENCIES THAT THAT MIGHT BE
, YOU KNOW, UNDER REVIEWED TO
TRY TO MAKE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING OBLIGATIONS. I
THOUGHT I WAS HEARING FROM èC
THAT THERE'S, YOU KNOW, SOME
CONTINGENT POSSIBILITIES FOR
BALANCING THOSE THINGS OUT, IF
I'M CONFLATING OR YOU KNOW, THEN
LET ME KNOW. AND I THOUGHT WHAT
I WAS ALSO HEARING FROM, YOU
SEE, IS THAT TO THE EXTENT AND
I'M READING INTO THIS, TO THE
EXTENT THAT THE LEGISLATURE
CONTINUES TO MOVE FORWARD WITH A
THE NOTION OF A FACILITIES BOND
THAT WOULD INCLUDE HIGHER
EDUCATION, THAT THAT FREES UP
PERHAPS DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
DOLLARS THAT COULD BE USED TO
MITIGATE SOME OF THE IMPACT OF
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET. AGAIN, IF
I'M MISSTATING YOUR THOUGHTS, NO
, THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING AS
WELL. ALL RIGHT. THANK HELPFUL
TO KNOW THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AND WE APPRECIATE THE COMPLEXITY
OF THIS. WE KNOW THAT THIS WILL
BE A REAL SUBJECT OF DISCUSSION
GOING FORWARD. AND THERE WERE A
FEW THINGS THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
REPORT BACK ON. AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO GETTING THOSE
REPORTS. SO THANK YOU. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
TWO. IT'S VARIOUS GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISION PROPOSAL WITH UC AND UC
COLLEGE OF THE LAW IN SAN
FRANCISCO. WE HAVE CHRIS
FERGUSON HERE. AND I THINK HE'S
GOING TO BE JOINED BY IAN.
EXCUSE ME, I KNOW THERE'S BEEN
SOME SWITCH OUTS, SO HE'S GOING
TO BE JOINED BY JENNIFER FROM
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
. SO WE'LL GO TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. YEAH. ONCE AGAIN,
CHRIS FERGUSON FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THERE ARE
A FEW SMALLER ADJUSTMENTS. CGRTS
IN THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BUDGET, IN PARTICULAR, THAT I
WOULD NOTE, ONE IS AN ONGOING
REDUCTION OF $13 MILLION IN
SUPPORT FOR THE UC LABOR CENTERS
, AND OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND
HEALTH PROGRAMS, THERE IS AN
ONGOING REDUCTION OF ROUGHLY
13.5 MILLION INCREASES, SLIGHTLY
IN THE OUT YEARS, IN SUPPORT
FOR, GRADUATE MEDICAL EDUCATION,
IN PARTICULAR, IT'S THE
PROPOSITION 56 GRADUATE MEDICAL
EDUCATION PROGRAM. FOR THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS, THE STATE HAD
BEEN MATCHING THOSE PROP 56
REVENUES WITH GENERAL FUND
REVENUES TO TRY AND GET TO A $40
MILLION LEVEL EACH YEAR. WE
WOULD FOREGO, THE UNDER THE MAY
REVISION, WE WOULD FOREGO THAT
GENERAL FUND PIECE OF THE
BACKFILL. AND THEN THE OTHER
THAT I WOULD NOTE IS A $5
MILLION ONE TIME, PULLBACK OF
RESOURCES THAT SUPPORT EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. THIS
ONE TIME ALLOCATION IS ACTUALLY
FROM THE 2021, BUDGET ACT AND IS
CURRENTLY UNUSED. AND THAT'S OUR
UNDERSTANDING, THE NEXT TWO THAT
I WOULD NOTE ON ONE TIME, I
WOULD NOTE THAT THERE IS A $13.7
MILLION REDUCTION IN ONE TIME
SUPPORT FOR THE UCLA LATINO,
POLICY CENTER, POLITICS AND
POLICY CENTER, AND THEN THERE IS
A $5 MILLION, ONE TIME REDUCTION
OR PULLBACK IN SUPPORT FOR THE
UC DAVIS EQUINE CENTER, OTHER,
PIECES THAT I WOULD NOTE IN
HERE, INCLUDE THE, 7.95%
REDUCTION APPLYING TO THE
COLLEGE OF THE LAW, SAN
FRANCISCO, STARTING IN 2526. WE
ESTIMATE THAT'S PROBABLY IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD OF AROUND $2
MILLION ONGOING TO THE COLLEGE
OF THE LAW, SAN FRANCISCO. AND
I'LL END MY COMMENTS WITH THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND THEN
WE'LL MOVE TO THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST, JENNIFER PORCELLA.
AGAIN, I'M JUST TESTIFYING WHY
MY COLLEAGUES ARE IN THE OTHER
HOUSE. SO OF ALL THE ISSUES
BEFORE YOU, I THINK I'LL JUST
FOCUS ON THREE. SO AS FINANCE
SET FORWARD, THERE IS A PROPOSAL
RELATED TO GRADUATE MEDICAL
EDUCATION OR RESIDENCY SLOTS AT
UC. SO THE PROP 56 PROGRAM, THE
STATE DOESN'T HAVE MUCH CONTROL
OVER IT, UC ADMINISTERS IT VIA A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION, SO GIVEN
THE LIMITED CONTROL, THE
LEGISLATURE MIGHT DECIDE THAT IT
DOESN'T WANT TO PUT GENERAL FUND
TO THIS PURPOSE. IT'S NOT
REQUIRED TO, UNDER PROP 56,
BACKFILL FOR THIS. IT COULD
SUPPORT GME IN OTHER WAYS. THAT
MIGHT BE MORE DIRECT IF THE
STATE DOES REDUCE FUNDING FOR
RESIDENCY SLOTS, IT'S LIKELY
THAT STATEWIDE, THE NUMBER OF
EMERGENCY CARE OR PRIMARY CARE
DOCTORS THAT ARE TRAINED IN
CALIFORNIA WOULD BE REDUCED.
BUT, IT'S NOT ENTIRELY CLEAR
RIGHT NOW HOW PROVIDERS ARE
MAKING ENDS MEET. THEY'RE USING
SOME STATE MONEY FOR THESE
SLOTS, A SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF
FEDERAL MONEY, MAYBE EVEN SOME
LOCAL MONEY TO SUPPORT RESIDENTS
, SO JUST SOME FACTORS TO
CONSIDER. IT'S UNCLEAR WHETHER
PROVIDERS WOULD BE ABLE TO
BACKFILL IF THE STATE DID REDUCE
FUNDING IN THIS AREA. REGARDING
THE ONE TIME PROPOSAL. SO MAY
REVISE DOES GO AFTER DOES PURSUE
REVERTING SOME PRIOR YEAR
UNSPENT FUNDS. WE'D RECOMMEND
AGAIN GOING EVEN FURTHER, WE
THINK FOR èC EVEN SETTING ASIDE
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT WE
DISCOVERED WERE PROBLEMATIC OVER
THE COURSE OF THE LAST FEW
MONTHS, THERE ARE STILL
SOMETHING LIKE $175 MILLION IN
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER ON
THE UC SIDE. ALSO, ON THE CSU
SIDE, THERE'S ABOUT 150 MILLION.
IF YOU DON'T LOOK AT DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE FUNDS. SO AGAIN,
WE'RE EMPHASIZING GOING AFTER
MORE REVERSION OF ONE TIME MONEY
BECAUSE YOU MIGHT DECIDE YOU
WANT TO SWAP IT OUT WITH SOME OF
THE MAY REVISED PROPOSALS THAT
YOU'RE LESS INTERESTED IN,
BECAUSE SOME OF THE SOLUTIONS
BEFORE YOU MIGHT END UP ERODING
AND YOU MIGHT END UP NOT
ACHIEVING EVERYTHING THAT WAS
PROPOSED. AND BECAUSE YOU MIGHT
JUST WANT TO PROTECT YOUR CORE
ONGOING PROGRAMS EITHER NOW OR
NEXT YEAR. FINALLY TURNING TO
COLLEGE OF THE LAW. THIS IS
ANOTHER INSTANCE WHERE WE THINK
THE BASIC MAY REVISE APPROACH IS
UNNECESSARILY COMPLICATED. SO
THEY PROPOSE A $2.2 MILLION
INCREASE IN 2425 AND A $2.1
MILLION REDUCTION IN 2526. WE
THINK IT'S MORE JUST ERUPTIVE
PROGRAMMATICALLY TO THE
PERSONNEL TO INCREASE FUNDS,
JUST TO REDUCE THEM. SO WE
RECOMMEND HOLDING THE COLLEGE OF
THE LAW'S BUDGET FLAT OR GENERAL
FUND SUPPORT FLAT. BUT FOR 2425,
THE OTHER PIECE OF THIS IS, I
THINK, WHY SOME FOLKS BELIEVE
THERE'S A LACK OF CLARITY AS
WHETHER IT'S FOR UC, CSU, THE
COLLEGE OF THE LAW, LOTS OF
OTHER STATE AGENCIES THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO BE HEARING ABOUT. THE
PROPOSAL ON THE STATE OPS SIDE
IS ONE AGGREGATE AMOUNT. SO YOU
CAN ACTUALLY SEE THE 125 MILLION
FOR UC OR SEE THE 75 MILLION FOR
CSU. OR IN THIS CASE IN 2526,
SEE THE $2.1 MILLION REDUCTION
FOR COLLEGE OF THE LAW. IT'S
ROLLED UP INTO A MUCH HIGHER
LEVEL NUMBER. NOW THAT UNWRITTEN
AMOUNT IS CONNECTED TO A CONTROL
SECTION BEFORE YOU. AND THAT
CONTROL SECTION GIVES THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE GIVES THE
ADMINISTRATION THE ABILITY TO
FIND THAT SAVINGS. AND THERE
ISN'T DETAIL ABOUT THE CRITERIA
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION WILL USE
TO GO ABOUT FINDING THAT
SAVINGS. IT ISN'T CLEAR HOW THE
LEGISLATURE WILL BE NOTIFIED
WHEN SAVINGS ARE ACHIEVED. IT
WON'T BE CLEAR IF SAVINGS AREN'T
ACHIEVED WHEN YOU WOULD BE AWARE
OF IT, AND THERE MIGHT BE SOME
INSTANCES WHERE THE SOLUTION,
AGAIN, DOES ERODE AND MAKES THE
SITUATION FOR 2526 MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT. ALL REASONS WHERE
WE'RE RECOMMENDING JUST TAKE A
MORE STRAIGHTFORWARD APPROACH.
CUT AGENCIES. IF YOU DETERMINE
YOU NEED TO, TO BALANCE THE
BUDGET IN 2425. OKAY. LET ME ASK
A COUPLE OF AND THANK YOU BOTH.
YOU SAID KEEP THE LAW SCHOOL
FLAT YEAR TO YEAR. KEEP THE LAW
SCHOOL FLAT WHERE YOU TAKE THE
INCREASE FOR ONE OF THE YEARS
AND SPREAD IT OVER TWO YEARS.
KEEP IT FLAT AT A HIGHER LEVEL,
OUR RECOMMENDATION IS AS A
STARTING POINT TO KEEP THEM FLAT
WHERE THEY ARE IN 2324. SO
RATHER THAN PROVIDING THEM 2.2
MILLION AUGMENTATION AND THEN
TAKING BACK THE AUGMENTATION IN
2526, NOT PROVIDING ANY. OH NO,
I UNDERSTAND WHAT YOUR
RECOMMENDATION IS. I DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND WHY IF THERE'S AN
ADDITION OF 2.2 MILLION, YOU
DIDN'T MAKE IT FLAT YEAR TO YEAR
AND HAVE THE 2.2 MILLION IN IT
OVER TWO YEARS, THAT'S WHAT I
DIDN'T UNDERSTAND. YOU KEEP IT
FLAT AT THE LOWER LEVEL AND
DON'T ADD AT ANY TIME, THAT'S.
AND BELIEVE ME, THAT'S BUDGET
DUST IN WHAT WE'RE TALKING. BUT
I THOUGHT THAT MIGHT BE
SOMETHING TO CONSIDER. LET ME
ASK THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
ASIDE FROM THE FACT THAT YOU
HAVE TO MAKE CUTS TO CLOSE THE
SHORTFALL, WHAT WAS THE
PRIORITIZATION IN DECIDING TO
JUST GO ALL THE WAY WITH THE
LABOR CENTERS AND A FRACTION OF
OTHERS AND OTHER THINGS? WHAT
WAS THE PRIORITIZATION PROCESS
IN THE CUTS? YEAH,
UNFORTUNATELY, I CAN'T SHARE YOU
KNOW, THAT THERE WAS A SPECIFIC
PRIORITIZATION PROCESS THAT I
COULD SHARE WITH YOU TODAY. I
THINK IT REALLY JUST FOCUSED ON,
ATTEMPTING TO ADDRESS THE TWO
YEAR BUDGET PROBLEM BEFORE US.
YEAH. AND THAT THAT WAS MY
POINT. IT BUT WHAT YOU
RECOMMENDED SUGGESTED
PRIORITIZATION BECAUSE SOME
THINGS ARE BEING FUNDED AND THE
LABOR CENTERS ARE COMPLETELY
BEING ZEROED OUT. SO THAT MAYBE
THERE'S SOMETHING YOU CAN'T TELL
US, BUT THERE WAS CLEARLY A
PRIORITIZATION. AND I SUSPECT
THAT MIGHT BE A QUESTION.
ANOTHER QUESTION. SO LET ME JUST
GO TO SENATOR CORTESE WITH ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ON THIS
SIDE. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION YOU JUST
ASKED. YOU JUST CONTINUING ALONG
THAT LINE, WHEN I LOOK AT AND
WHAT I'M GOING TO SAY IS REALLY
ACTUALLY AT THIS POINT, YOU
KNOW, BASED ON BRIEFINGS WE'VE
RECEIVED, IN OUR OWN CAUCUS AND,
YOU KNOW, AS, AS MEMBERS OF THE
STATE SENATE IN GENERAL, NOT
JUST IN THE SUBCOMMITTEE OR
RELATIVE TO EDUCATION, BUT IT
SEEMS LIKE A BIT OF A PATTERN IS
, YOU KNOW, PROGRAMS THAT WE
STOOD UP, YOU KNOW, OVER THE
LAST TWO YEARS, THIS ONE èC
LABOR CENTERS GOES BACK TO 2022,
THAT THERE'S ALMOST A DISCUSSION
IN THE ROOM ON YOUR SIDE OF THE
TABLE THAT GOES SOMETHING LIKE
THIS. LOOK, WE WOULDN'T HAVE
FUNDED THIS HAD WE KNOW THAT
KNOWN THAT WE WERE GOING TO HAVE
A DRAMATIC, YOU KNOW, DROP IN IN
PROJECTED THE INCOME TAXES THAT
WE WERE PROJECTED TO HAVE IN
2024, WE WOULDN'T HAVE DONE IT.
SO LET'S ELIMINATE IT. AND, AND
THAT'S A DIFFERENT KIND OF A
PATTERN THAN A PRIORITIZATION
PATTERN THAT'S BASED ON
SOMETHING THAT MIGHT GO LIKE
THIS. WELL, THE èC LABOR
CENTERS HAVE BEEN ABSOLUTELY
INSTRUMENTAL IN, IN PROVIDING
ANALYSIS FOR US, ALMOST LIKE AN
EXTENDED BRANCH OF
ADMINISTRATIVE AGENCY WHEN IT
COMES TO MASSIVE INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS THAT THAT WE HAVE
MOVED OUT OVER THAT SAME PERIOD
OF TIME FROM 2022 THROUGH
CURRENT, RANGING FROM CLIMATE
INVESTMENTS DOWN TO BILL MATCH
TO, TO, TO, TO INFRASTRUCTURE,
THE INFRASTRUCTURE ACT AND YOU
KNOW, TO COME IN I THINK IT'S
CONFUSING FOR PEOPLE TO COME IN
AND BASICALLY YOU KNOW, KNEECAP
THAT PROGRAM OR CUT THAT OUT
WHEN FROM A LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIZATION STANDPOINT, I
CAN'T SPEAK FOR THE WHOLE
LEGISLATURE OR EVEN THE CHAIR
FOR THAT MATTER. BUT THERE WOULD
BE AN ARGUMENT THAT YOU WANT TO
TRY TO, YOU KNOW, TO CONTINUE TO
MAINTAIN TÍNH PROGRAMS EVEN IF
THEY'RE EXTERNAL, THAT, THAT ARE
DESIGNED TO, TO COMPLEMENT, YOU
KNOW, THESE MASSIVE INVESTMENTS
THAT THE STATE IS MAKING, WHICH
AREN'T GOING AWAY, WHAT DO YOU
DO IF YOU DON'T HAVE A èC LABOR
CENTER TO COME IN AND, AND HELP
US FIGURE OUT WHETHER OR NOT,
YOU KNOW, WORKFORCE STANDARDS
UNDER BILLS LIKE SB 150 OR AS
APPLIED TO MANUFACTURING, AS
APPLIED TO LITHIUM, AS APPLIED
TO THE CHIPS ACT, IT'S èC LABOR
CENTER OUTSIDE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION ITSELF THAT'S
PROVIDING THAT KIND OF HELP, SO
I THINK THAT'S THE HEART OF THE
QUESTION. AND I THINK IT WITH
ALL DUE RESPECT, YOU'VE BEEN
TERRIFIC TODAY, BUT I THINK IT
MERITS A BETTER ANSWER THAN, YOU
KNOW, I CAN'T REALLY I CAN'T
REALLY SAY WHAT THE
PRIORITIZATION PATTERN IS. I
THINK IT'S FAIR TO IT'S FAIR IN
TERMS OF THE THREE WAY
NEGOTIATION, YOU KNOW, TO BE
CANDID AND SAY, IF IT IS INDEED
THE CASE, THAT NO, IT REALLY
ISN'T BASED ON THAT KIND OF
PRIORITIZATION, THE KIND OF
PRIORITIZATION THAT CREATES
SYNERGY. IT'S BASED ON WHAT YOU
SAID, SENATOR CORTEZ, THAT THIS,
THIS, THIS LOOKS LIKE SOMETHING
THAT WAS STOOD UP THAT WE MIGHT
HAVE WE MIGHT NOT HAVE DONE HAD
WE KNOWN WHERE WE WERE HEADED.
AND THEN WE CAN TAKE THAT INTO
ACCOUNT AND SAY, WELL, DO WE
WANT TO BEHAVE THAT WAY AS A
LEGISLATURE, OR DO WE WANT TO
BEHAVE DIFFERENTLY AND SAY,
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A MORE,
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A DIFFERENT
TACT AND TRY TO LOOK AT WHERE DO
WE GET GROWTH, SYNERGY, WHERE DO
WE GET, WHERE DO WE WHERE DO WE
GET A CALIFORNIA FOR ALL COMING
OUT OF EVEN A TOUGH BUDGET? AND
I THINK THAT'S A LITTLE BIT MORE
THEMATIC, AT LEAST ON THE SENATE
SIDE RIGHT NOW. DEFINITE
QUESTION. BUT OBVIOUSLY THAT WAS
MORE OF A COMMENT. IF YOU'D LIKE
TO RESPOND, PLEASE, PLEASE DO.
NÓ JUST WANTED TO SAY THAT I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS AND
WILL CERTAINLY TAKE BACK THAT
CONCERN FOR CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU. GREAT. THANK YOU. AND IT
JUST AS A COMMENT CLOSING
COMMENT, IT JUST SEEMS BRUTAL TO
COMPLETELY CUT THE LABOR CENTERS
. AND I JUST HOPE IN THE BUDGET
PROCESS WE CAN FIND A WAY TO
DEAL WITH THAT. SO, WE ARE GOING
TO MOVE, TO ISSUE NUMBER THREE,
WHICH IS THE AUGMENTATION TO
SUPPORT EXPANDED UNIVERSITY FEE
WAIVER. AND WE HAVE CHRIS
FERGUSON, AND WE HAVE JENNIFER
PANELLA, SITTING IN FOR, FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST AND THEN
CHERYL IDE FOR THE, CSU SYSTEM.
AND THIS REALLY IS NOT AS,
SIGNIFICANT ITEM COMPARED TO OUR
PREVIOUS ONE. SO, IT'S JUST
IMPORTANT FOR US TO AIR THIS
BEFORE WE. SO LET'S GO.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. YEAH.
CHRIS FERGUSON WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. SO
CHAPTER 695 OF THE STATUTES OF
2023 AUTHORIZED AN EXPANDED FEE
WAIVER FOR MEDAL OF HONOR
RECIPIENTS, CHILDREN OF MEDAL OF
HONOR RECIPIENTS OR DEPENDENTS
OF SERVICE INJURED VETERANS AT
THE CSU, THE UC AND CSCS, THAT
IS THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA,
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY,
AND CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES, THIS PARTICULAR, MAY
REVISION INVESTMENT IS 5.5
MILLION ONGOING GENERAL FUND TO
SUPPORT THE COSTS OF THOSE FEE
WAIVERS AT THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY, WE DID NOT SEE A
SIMILAR, REQUEST OR ASK FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. AND
THE TRADITIONAL, FEE WAIVERS AT
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES,
ALONG WITH THE TWO YEARS OF FREE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AVAILABLE TO
MOST STUDENTS, NEGATES THE
PROJECTED OR WOULD NEGATE THE
PROJECTED IMPACT OF THIS TYPE OF
FEE WAIVER, AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM, WITH THAT, I
CONCLUDE MY REMARKS. GREAT. AND
LET'S GO TO THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST, WE JUST NOTE,
OBVIOUSLY, SINCE LEGISLATION WAS
ENACTED, THE STATE BUDGET
CONDITION HAS DETERIORATED. SO
AT THIS POINT, IT'S JUST A
MATTER OF YOUR PRIORITIES TO
MAKE ROOM FOR THE 5.5 MILLION.
AUGMENTATION MEANS YOU'RE TAKING
FROM OTHER PROGRAMS THAT CSU IS
OPERATING. SO IT'S JUST A MATTER
OF YOUR PRIORITIES AT THIS
POINT. THANK YOU. CSU, GOOD
MORNING AGAIN, SHIRLEY DI WITH
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY.
WE APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S MAY REVISION
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE ONGOING
SUPPORT RECOGNIZING THE FISCAL
IMPACT OF AB 1745. THIS NEW LAW
CREATED NEW COSTS AND IS
IMPORTANT FOR THE STATE TO
FOLLOW THROUGH AND PROVIDE
FUNDING TO COVER THESE NEW
COSTS. AND WE HOPE TO SEE THAT
AGAIN IN THE FUTURE FOR ANY NEW
LEGISLATION. I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS DURING THIS TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, SENATOR
CORTESE. ANY QUESTION OR
COMMENT? NO. AND NOR DO I. SO WE
JUST APPRECIATE THIS AND
APPRECIATE WHAT WAS STATED ABOUT
THIS BEING A DECISION. WE'LL
MOVE TO ISSUE NUMBER FOUR.
VARIOUS, MAY REVISION PROPOSALS
IN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM,
WE'LL HAVE CHRIS FERGUSON AND
JENNIFER VOZZELLA ON THIS. AND
AND DAVID O'BRIEN IS HERE TO AT
LEAST ANSWER QUESTIONS. IF NOT,
MAKE A COMMENT FROM THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM. SO
LET'S START WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. YES, CHRIS FERGUSON
WITH FINANCE, THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSES A FEW AUGMENTATIONS.
WITHIN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
BUDGET AND WITHIN PROPOSITION
98, MANY OF WHICH HAVE ALREADY
BEEN COVERED BY MY COLLEAGUE
EARLIER. SO I WON'T REPEAT
THOSE, I WOULD JUST ADD THAT
THERE ARE FOUR DEMONSTRATION
PROJECTS THAT HAVE BEEN
PROPOSED. THOSE FOR ONE TIME.
INVESTMENTS ARE ROUGHLY $12
MILLION TO SUPPORT A
DEMONSTRATION PROJECT OR PROJECT
OR PROGRESS AROUND Â.
TRANSCRIPT CALIFORNIA, $12
MILLION TO SUPPORT A ONE TIME
DEMONSTRATION PROJECT AROUND
COMMON CLOUD DATA PLATFORMS, AND
THEN A $6 MILLION, ONE TIME
DEMONSTRATION PROJECT TO SUPPORT
, CREDIT FOR PRIOR LEARNING AND
A $5 MILLION, ONE TIME,
AUGMENTATION TO SUPPORT A
DEMONSTRATION PROJECT THAT WOULD
FOCUS ON EDUCATIONAL PATHWAYS
FOR LOW INCOME WORKING LEARNERS,
WE WOULD SAY THAT ALL FOUR OF
THESE ARE BEING FUNDED FROM,
REAPPROPRIATED MONIES FROM PRIOR
YEARS THAT HAD BECOME AVAILABLE
WITHIN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
PORTION OF THE PROPOSITION 98
GUARANTEE PACKAGE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THEN WE'LL GO TO THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST. AND SO THE
MAY REVISE, YOU KNOW, INCREASES
THE SIZE OF THE FUNDING
MANEUVER, INCREASES THE AMOUNT
OF NEW COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SPENDING, DESPITE THE DOWNWARD
REVISIONS IN THE GUARANTEE,
WHERE LARGELY RELIES ON AN EVEN
LARGER AMOUNT OF ONE TIME MONEY
TO SUPPORT ONGOING COLLEGE COSTS
AND USES ALL RESERVES, SO
INCREASES THE AMOUNT OF PROP 98
RESERVES BEING USED ON FOR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. SO WE
CONTINUE TO RECOMMEND REJECTING
THE FUNDING MANEUVER, REJECTING
THE PROPOSED COLA AS WELL AS ALL
OF THE NEW DISCRETIONARY
SPENDING INITIATIVES. AGAIN AT
THIS TIME, ALL OF THOSE THINGS
ARE COMING AT THE EXPENSE OF
EXISTING PROGRAM, WE THINK THIS
APPROACH, AGAIN, GIVEN ALL OF
THE TRADE OFFS THAT YOU'RE
FACING, STILL HAS ADVANTAGES.
YOU AVOID PUTTING A BURDEN ON
THE NON 98 SIDE OF THE BUDGET.
YOU, MINIMIZE IS THE ONGOING
SHORTFALL THAT YOU'LL HAVE
ENTERING 2526. WE THINK THERE
ARE ONE TIME WE'VE IDENTIFIED
ABOUT 600 MILLION IN ADDITION TO
THE MAY REVISE AND UNSPENT ONE
TIME MONIES THAT YOU STILL HAVE
AVAILABLE WHERE YOU TO CHOOSE.
AGAIN, DOING SO HAS SEVERAL
BENEFITS FOR YOU MOVING FORWARD,
INCLUDING MINIMIZING DISRUPTION
TO ONGOING PROGRAMS. THANK YOU.
AND YOU'RE HERE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS, CORRECT? YES, SIR.
DAVID O'BRIEN OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE. HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LET ME ASK ONE OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE, AND THAT IS, IS
THAT, THERE WAS LANGUAGE TO BE
RETURNED FOR THE STATEWIDE LEASE
REVENUE BOND FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE HOUSING PROJECTS. AND I
UNDERSTAND YOU'VE RELEASED THAT
LANGUAGE IN THE LAST 24 HOURS.
COULD YOU JUST BRIEFLY WALK US
THROUGH WHAT IT IS? CERTAINLY.
SO WE'VE RELEASED, LANGUAGE
WITHIN THE LAST 24 HOURS. THAT
IS CORRECT. TO SUPPORT A
STATEWIDE, LEASE REVENUE BOND
APPROACH FOR, I BELIEVE IT'S 13
PROJECTS AT THE STATEWIDE OR AT
LOCAL COMMUNITY COLLEGES THAT
WOULD BE SUPPORTED, THROUGH THAT
STATEWIDE LEASE REVENUE BOND.
THE GENERAL STRUCTURE IS REALLY
CENTERED AROUND HOW WE CAN, MEET
THE REQUIREMENTS TO USE THE
LEASE REVENUE BOND STRUCTURE TO
SUPPORT THOSE PROJECTS, IT IS
OUR INTENT TO HAVE THAT
LANGUAGE, BE SUPPORTED
ULTIMATELY BY COSTS THAT ARE IN
THE MULTI-YEAR, IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE BUDGET RIGHT NOW, SO
ULTIMATELY, WE'RE HOPING THAT
ALL 13 OF THOSE PROJECTS WILL
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD. THE
STRUCTURE IS DESIGNED TO TRY AND
ENSURE THAT ALL 13 CAN MOVE
FORWARD. OKAY. THANK YOU. AND
THEN LET ME JUST ASK IF WE'RE
GOING TO SENATOR CORTESE, LET ME
JUST ASK ONE QUESTION OF THE OF
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE, WHICH IS
HOW WOULD YOU DESCRIBE THE
IMPACTS OF SUGGESTED CUTS TO
STATE OPERATIONS? WHAT WOULD THE
IMPACTS BE TO YOU? THANK YOU.
SENATOR THAT IS A VERY GOOD
QUESTION. WE'RE IN THE EARLY
STAGES OF EVALUATING ALL
POSSIBLE SORT OF WAYS TO ACHIEVE
THOSE SAVINGS, RECOGNIZING THE
VERY DIFFICULT POSITION THE
STATE'S IN. WE JUST FEEL IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE TO THE
COMMITTEE AND TO THE LEGISLATURE
THAT A NUMBER OF NEW EDUCATIONAL
INITIATIVES HAVE BEEN PASSED VIA
STATUTE IN RECENT YEARS,
INCLUDING REFORMS TO REMEDIAL
EDUCATION, OVERSIGHT OF FULL
TIME FACULTY HIRING FUNDS, AMONG
MANY OTHERS. THE TRANSFER
PROCESS WORKING ON STREAMLINING
THE TRANSFER PROCESS FOR
STUDENTS TRANSFERRING TO UC OR
CSU. ALL OF THOSE INVOLVE
VARYING DEGREES OF OVERSIGHT AND
LEADERSHIP AND COMPLIANCE
MONITORING AND SUPPORT FOR 116
CAMPUSES AT THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE, SO ANY AND ALL OF THOSE
COULD BE AFFECTED, AS WELL AS
ANY OF THE SORT OF VARIOUS NEW
PROPOSALS COMING THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE THIS YEAR, IF IT
REQUIRES SOME LEVEL OF OVERSIGHT
FROM THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. SO
WE'RE LOOKING INTO, YOU KNOW,
WAYS TO ACHIEVE THOSE SAVINGS
RIGHT NOW. OBVIOUSLY, OUR LAST,
LAST, LAST RESORT WOULD BE
ANYTHING INVOLVING OUR EMPLOYEES
OR OUR STAFF. SO CONSIDER
EVERYTHING FROM WHAT CAN WE LOOK
AT IN TERMS OF OUR LEASE FOR OUR
HEADQUARTERS ON QUÊ STREET,
TRAVEL REDUCTIONS, THINGS OF
THAT NATURE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, SENATOR CORTESE. ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS AT THIS
TIME? OKAY. I WOULD JUST DO ONE
FINAL COMMENT ON THIS ITEM AND
THAT IS IN THE LOCAL ASSISTANCE
REAPPROPRIATION. THERE'S JUST
SOME THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN
PRIORITIES OF THE LEGISLATURE
THAT ARE IN THERE. SO I'M
GRATEFUL FOR THAT, HAPPENING.
THEN WE'LL MOVE TO ISSUE NUMBER
FIVE, WHICH IS OUR SAME PANEL,
AND IT IS THE NURSING PROGRAM
SUPPORT AT COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
AND LET ME JUST MAKE A COMMENT,
WHICH IS THAT THIS IS AGENDIZED
BECAUSE IT HADN'T BEEN AGENDIZED
. BUT WHEN THE CHANCELLOR WAS
HERE, WE HAD AN EXTENSIVE
CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS. SO IT
HADN'T BEEN AGENDIZED, BUT WE
TALKED ABOUT THIS IN A IN A
PREVIOUS HEARING. SO LET ME, GO
IN IN THE ORDER OF DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE, LEGISLATIVE ANALYST AND
IF THERE ARE ANY COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE, CERTAINLY.
SO THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSED 60,000,001 TIME
PROPOSITION 98, TO EXPAND
NURSING PROGRAMS AND BACHELOR OF
SCIENCE AND NURSING PROGRAMS TO
GROW, EDUCATE AND MAINTAIN THE
NEXT GENERATION OF REGISTERED
NURSES THROUGH THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM. I'LL KEEP MY
REMARKS BRIEF. THANK YOU, SO I
THINK AT THAT SUBCOMMITTEE
HEARING A MONTH OR SO AGO, YOU
WERE, THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
SHARED A NURSING DEMONSTRATION
PROJECT THAT WAS INTRIGUING.
PERHAPS TO YOU, IT'S STILL
UNCLEAR HOW THAT'S CONNECTED TO
THIS PARTICULAR $60 MILLION POT
OF MONEY. SO I THINK YOU MIGHT
JUST WANT TO GET SOME CLARITY ON
WHAT IS THIS 60 MILLION GOING TO
BE USED FOR, DURING THE
PANDEMIC, THERE WAS AN INCREASE
IN THE NURSING SHORTAGE. THE
LATEST STUDIES THAT HAVE COME
OUT IN THE FALL OF 23 AND WINTER
OF 24 ARE SHOWING THAT NURSING
ENROLLMENTS ARE BACK ON TRACK,
AND THAT THE SUPPLY OF NURSING
SHOULD MEET DEMAND BY 2027 OR
2028. SO WITHIN 3 OR 4 MORE
YEARS, EVEN IF STATEWIDE SUPPLY
AND DEMAND COMES BACK INTO
ALIGNMENT, YOU MIGHT STILL SEE
SOME REGIONAL SHORTAGES. THE
COLLEGES HAVE A FEW POTS OF
MONEY THEY CAN USE TO ADDRESS
NURSING ENROLLMENTS LOCALLY. SO
THEY HAVE APPORTIONMENTS. THEY
HAVE NURSING CATEGORICAL MONEY,
THEY HAVE STRONG WORKFORCE
PROGRAM MONIES. IN PARTICULAR,
THE STRONG WORKFORCE PROGRAM
MONIES ARE FOR THESE KINDS OF
THINGS LIKE REGIONAL LABOR
SHORTAGES. AND SO THERE IS
SUBSTANTIAL STRONG WORKFORCE
MONEY AVAILABLE. DISTRICTS HAVE
NOT BEEN USING THEIR ENTIRE
ALLOCATION FOR THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS. SO WE CONTINUE TO
RECOMMEND AGAINST THE
INITIATIVE. AGAIN, WERE YOU TO
DO WHAT YOU WOULD HAVE TO FIND
SOME OFFSETTING SAVINGS
ELSEWHERE IN YOUR BUDGET? THANK
YOU. ANY COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMUNITY CHANCELLOR COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE? THANK YOU
SENATOR. I PROMISE TO STAY
SEATED FOR THE ENTIRE DURATION
OF THE RIDE THIS TIME. ON THIS
ONE, I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT WE
CONTINUE TO BE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. I'LL, HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT
OUR DEMONSTRATION PROJECT, BUT I
THINK THAT, YOU KNOW, FOR US,
IT'S AN ACCESS AND AN EQUITY
ISSUE, OUR PARTNERS AT THE LAO
DO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THERE ARE
LIKELY TO STILL BE REGIONAL GAPS
, IN THE NURSING SHORTAGE, EVEN
IF THIS THIS, THE, THE SHORTAGE
DOES SORT OF SELF RESOLVE OVER
THE NEXT SEVERAL YEARS, WHICH I
THINK, WE HAVE A SLIGHT
DIFFERENCE OF OPINION ON, BUT
WE'RE STRONGLY SUPPORTIVE, AND
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU. AND LET ME JUST ASK
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, IS
THIS INTENDED TO BE A ONE TIME I
WAS CONFUSED. MAYBE IT WAS CLEAR
ONE TIME 60 MILLION? OR IS THIS
IN A BASE ONGOING 60 MILLION A
YEAR. SO IT'S A LIMITED TERM
INVESTMENT. SO THE AGREEMENT
LAST YEAR WAS 60 MILLION FOR
FIVE YEARS. SO IT IS TERMED AS
ONE TIME INVESTMENTS. UNTIL WE
WOULD GET TO THAT TOTAL. SO IT'S
A FIVE YEAR ONE TIME INVESTMENT.
IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE SAYING? I
BELIEVE SO, YES. UNIQUE BUT I
THINK WE EXPRESSED OUR OPINION
IN THE HEARING ABOUT HOW
IMPORTANT THIS IS AND HOPE TO
MAKE IT OR I RESPECT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYSTS AS WE GO
DOWN THE CRUNCH HERE, TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE FUND
EVERYTHING. SO THANK YOU ON THAT
ONE. WE'RE GOING TO GO TO, ISSUE
SIX, WHICH IS THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT AID COMMISSION. AND IT
IS VARIOUS PROPOSALS RELATING TO
STUDENT AID. AND IN THIS ONE WE
DO HAVE CHRIS FERGUSON AND
JENNIFER PACELLA, BUT WE HAVE
PEOPLE FROM OTHER, AGENCIES THAT
WILL BE HERE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS. SO LET'S START WITH
THE, THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
S ONCE AGAIN, CHRIS FERGUSON
WITH FINANCE, I WOULD NOTE THAT
FIRST AND PRIMARILY THE MAY
REVISION DOES MAINTAIN AND FULLY
FUND ALL OF THE PROJECTED
CASELOAD FOR THE CAL GRANT
ENTITLEMENT PROGRAM, BUT WITH
THAT, THERE ARE A SERIES OF
REDUCTIONS PROPOSED IN THE MAY
REVISION, SPECIFIC ONLY TO THE
MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM
. THE TOTALITY OF THE REDUCTION
IS ROUGHLY 530 MILLION, WHICH
WOULD LEAVE JUST OVER 100
MILLION ONGOING TO SUPPORT THAT
PROGRAM, WE DON'T TAKE THE
ADJUSTMENT LIGHTLY, BUT IN LIGHT
OF THE BUDGET SHORTFALL, THAT'S
WHY WE ULTIMATELY FELT IT
NECESSARY TO PROPOSE. WE ALSO
PROPOSE PULLING BACK ROUGHLY
485,000,000 IN 1 TIME FUNDING
THAT HAD BEEN ALLOCATED IN THE
2021 AND 2022 BUDGETS TO SUPPORT
THE LEARNING ALIGNED EMPLOYMENT
PROGRAM THAT REPRESENTS THE
BALANCE OF AVAILABLE ONE TIME
RESOURCES, AND THEN WE ALSO
PROPOSE TO REDUCE SUPPORT,
REMAINING SUPPORT FOR THE GOLDEN
STATE TEACHER GRANT PROGRAM BY
ROUGHLY 60,000,001 TIME. AND
THAT WOULD LEAVE ROUGHLY 50
MILLION REMAINING TO SUPPORT
THAT PROGRAM. WE PROPOSE SOME
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE, AROUND
THE GOLDEN STATE TEACHER GRANT
PROGRAM AS WELL, TO CLARIFY
ELIGIBILITY, ADD SOME INCOME
REQUIREMENTS, AND ALSO TO ADJUST
THE SIZE OF THE AWARDS, THEN
LASTLY, THE 7.95% REDUCTION,
STATEWIDE REDUCTION WOULD APPLY
TO THE STATE OPERATIONS OF THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION. THANK YOU.
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST. SO
BEGINNING WITH THE MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP, PROPOSAL, THIS
PROGRAM WAS ONE OF THE STATE
PROGRAMS THAT WAS AUGMENTED
SIGNIFICANTLY, SINCE 2223, IN
COMPARISON TO THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAM THAT IS MORE TARGETED TO
LOW INCOME AND MIDDLE INCOME
STUDENTS. THE MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM IS LESS
TARGETED WITH STUDENTS THAT HAVE
FAMILY INCOMES, EVEN UP TO
226,000 ELIGIBLE FOR AWARDS IN
2425, AND COMPARED TO THE CAL
GRANT PROGRAM, THE MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM IS ALSO MUCH
NEWER AND MORE DIFFICULT TO
IMPLEMENT. THAT SAID, ANY ALMOST
ANY REDUCTION YOU TAKE IN THE
FINANCIAL AID AREA, IS GOING TO
HAVE IMPACTS ON STUDENTS AND
THERE IS SOME TIMING ISSUES WITH
THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSAL IN THAT
SOME UC AND CSU CAMPUSES HAVE
NOTIFIED STUDENTS OF A
PRELIMINARY MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP AWARD FOR 2425, SOME
OF THEM MIGHT HAVE MADE CERTAIN
DECISIONS ABOUT ENROLLMENT AND
WORK AND LOANS BASED UPON THAT
INFORMATION. TURNING TO THE
LEARNING LINE EMPLOYMENT
PROGRAM, WE RECOMMEND YOU GO
AHEAD AND ADOPT THIS. IT GIVES
YOU SUBSTANTIAL BUDGET SOLUTION
WITH MINIMAL IMPACT ON STUDENTS.
SINCE THE PROGRAM IS STILL IN AN
EARLY IMPLEMENTATION PHASE ON
THE GOLDEN STATE TEACHER GRANTS,
IT'S COME TO LIGHT JUST OVER THE
LAST 48 HOURS THAT THERE MIGHT
NOT BE 50,000,001 TIME SUPPORT
REMAINING, MAYBE ABOUT 15
MILLION OF THAT IS BEING USED
FOR EXISTING STUDENTS WHO HAVE
EXISTING AWARDS THAT ARE GOING
TO BE PAID OUT HERE THE NEXT FEW
YEARS. SO THERE'S NOT NOT MUCH
ONE TIME MONEY LEFT. AFTER YOU
TAKE THAT INTO ACCOUNT, WE'D
RECOMMEND AGAINST ANY TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE THAT WOULD JUST
DELAY GETTING WHATEVER POT OF
MONEY DOES REMAIN OUT THE DOOR
JUST USING THE EXISTING RULES,
YOU MIGHT HAVE A LITTLE BIT MORE
YOU COULD TAKE HERE. THERE'S NOT
CLEAR EVIDENCE THIS IS ACTUALLY
INCREASING THE SUPPLY OF
TEACHERS, RATHER THAN JUST
GIVING SOME TEACHER INDIVIDUALS
WHO OTHERWISE WOULD HAVE BECOME
TEACHERS, A FISCAL BENEFIT,
THERE'S ALSO SOME SMALL POTS OF
MONEY FOR THE GOLDEN STATE
TEACHER GRANT. AND AGAIN, ONE IS
ONE POTS 500,000, THE OTHER IS 6
MILLION. BUT FOR A STATEWIDE
PROGRAM, THOSE ARE SMALL AMOUNTS
OF MONEY THAT WE THINK YOU COULD
REDIRECT JUST DIRECTLY TO
DISTRICTS, RATHER THAN HAVING A
MORE COMPLEX STATE LEVEL PROGRAM
FOR SUCH A SMALL AMOUNT OF MONEY
ON THE FINAL ISSUE REGARDING
CSAC STATE OPS, WE HAVE ALL THE
SAME CONCERNS WE HAVE WITH THE
OVERARCHING, STATE OPS PROPOSAL
WHEN IT COMES TO DELEGATING LOTS
OF AUTHORITY TO THE
ADMINISTRATION, NOT KNOWING HOW
THOSE CUTS WOULD BE IMPLEMENTED,
NOT KNOWING IF THEY WOULD AFFECT
CORE SERVICES THAT THE
DEPARTMENT IMPLEMENTS, AND A
CONCERN THAT POTENTIALLY SOME OF
THE SOLUTION WOULD ERODE,
LEAVING YOU WITH A PROBLEM NEXT
YEAR. AND I KNOW YOU'RE
TECHNICALLY HERE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS. IS THAT OKAY? YEAH.
OKAY LET ME ASK A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS AND THEN WE'LL GO TO
SENATOR CORTESE. AND ONE IS ON
THE MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP.
AND MAYBE I SHOULD START WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. IT
SAYS THAT THE, THE MONEY IS
GOING BACK TO THE PREVIOUS
LEVELS BEFORE THE AUGMENTATION.
BUT THERE HAVE BEEN MANY MORE
PEOPLE THAT HAVE COME ON. SO IT
THE AVERAGE GRANT LEVEL DOESN'T
GO BACK. IT GOES BACK TO
SUBSTANTIALLY LESS GRANT LEVEL.
IS THAT YOUR UNDERSTANDING?
YEAH, THAT WOULD BE AN ACCURATE
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT WOULD
OCCUR OKAY. THAT THAT THAT IS
I'LL BE DIPLOMATIC. THAT'S VERY
UNPLEASANT. THAT'S NOT WHERE WE
WOULD WANT TO GO BECAUSE THE
IMPLICATION WAS, OH, WE'RE GOING
BACK TO PRE AUGMENTATION. BUT
SINCE THERE'S SO MANY MORE, IT
AS HARD AS IT IS TO BELIEVE THAT
WE WOULD HAVE AVERAGE GRANTS
THAT WOULD BE SUBSTANTIALLY
BELOW THE PRE AUGMENTATION, I
THINK THAT'S SOMETHING THAT THAT
NEEDS TO BE LOOKED AT. I THOUGHT
I'D GET THAT OUT OF THE WAY
BEFORE ASKING THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION TO DESCRIBE THE
IMPACTS TO THE INDIVIDUAL
PROGRAMS. OF COURSE, MADISON
SHEFFIELD CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION. OUR ESTIMATE IS THAT
THE FOR THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSAL AS OF OUR MAYOR VISION
ESTIMATES OF THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS WHO WOULD GET MIX IN
2425 THAT EIGHT A STUDENT WOULD
GET AN AVERAGE OF A $340 AWARD.
AND MY QUESTION WAS INTENDED
ALSO TO BE BROADER. IT'S LIKE
THE IMPACT OF OTHER PROGRAMS
THAT ARE WITHIN THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION THAT ARE IN THIS ITEM
AS WELL. Þ BROADER COMMENTS ON
THE ON ALL THE PROPOSALS. YEAH.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO GO TILL THE
END OF THE EVENING, BUT BUT JUST
A GENERAL FLAVOR OF WHERE WE
COULD SEE. YEAH, WE WOULD
GENERALLY AGREE WITH, WITH YOUR
COMMENTS AROUND, IT MAY MAKE
SENSE FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONSIDER MAKING THE MIX PROGRAM
MORE TARGETED. AND WE CAN, OF
COURSE, PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE IN THAT WAY TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE AWARD SIZES ARE
SOMETHING MORE SUBSTANTIAL FOR,
FOR STUDENTS, SO THAT WOULD
GENERALLY BE OUR COMMENT ON THE
MIX PROGRAM. AND OF COURSE,
WE'RE VERY, VERY HAPPY THAT THE
CAL GRANT PROGRAM IS MAINTAINED
FOR A VERY IMPORTANT NEED BASED,
NEED BASED AID PROGRAM. AND HERE
IN CALIFORNIA FOR THE HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS, AND
THEN, OF COURSE, WE HAVE SIMILAR
COMMENTS TO MANY COLLEAGUES HAVE
PRESENTED TODAY ON THAT. WE ARE,
WE ARE LOOKING INTO THE STATE
OPERATIONS AND DOING OUR INITIAL
ANALYSIS OF HOW POTENTIALLY A
7.95% CUT COULD BE, COULD BE
OPERATIONALIZED IF IT WERE
MAINTAINED IN THE FINAL BUDGET
ACT, JUST BRIEFLY, THE CUT THAT
WE ESTIMATE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT AID COMMISSION IN 2425
WOULD BE AROUND 1.8 MILLION,
WHICH IS ACTUALLY, 300,300,000
LARGER THAN OUR OUR OPERATING
EXPENSES BUDGET, SEPARATE FROM
PERSONNEL SERVICES. WE ALSO HAVE
A VERY LOW VACANCY RATE OF 6.6%
CURRENTLY, MEANING THAT WE HAVE
JUST VERY, VERY ROOM, VERY, VERY
LITTLE ROOM TO CUT, IN ADDITION
TO THINKING ABOUT THE VACANCY
FREEZE THAT HAS BEEN ALSO
PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET, SO WE ARE LOOKING FOR
WAYS TO MINIMIZE IMPACT TO STAFF
AND TO, OF COURSE, TO STUDENTS,
WITH, WITH, WITH THE IF THIS
PROPOSAL WERE MAINTAINED, SOME
EXAMPLES OF, CUTS WOULD HAPPEN
TO BE MADE POTENTIALLY ON THE
OPERATIONAL SIDE WOULD BE, YOU
KNOW, PARTICIPATION AND TRAVEL
TO STUDENT WORKSHOPS AND
TRAININGS THAT WE WOULD HAVE TO
DO VIRTUALLY. AND THAT COULD BE
A REAL IMPACT TO STUDENTS IN
TERMS OF ACCESS TO FINANCIAL AID
KNOWLEDGE AND APPLYING. AND WE
HAVE IT PROJECTS, OF COURSE,
THAT WERE PLANNED THAT WERE
RELATED TO AUDIT FINDINGS IN
RECENT YEARS THAT WE WOULD HAVE
TO BE DELAYED FOR FUTURE YEARS,
THINGS LIKE THAT. AND THEN, OF
COURSE, BECAUSE THIS IS ACROSS
OUR ENTIRE BUDGET AND WE HAVE A
VERY LOW VACANCY RATE, WE WOULD
HAVE TO CONSIDER, IMPACTS TO
PERSONNEL SERVICES THAT ARE NOT
DESIRABLE, OF COURSE, AS WELL.
SO VERY, VERY SERIOUS AS MY
OTHER OTHER STATE DEPARTMENTS
HAVE MENTIONED TODAY FOR HOW TO
IMPLEMENT THIS. 7.9% 5% CUT.
OKAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
SENATOR CORTESE OKAY, THEN LET
ME MAKE, MAYBE A WHILE AND JUST
CONFIRM WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST OR MAYBE THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE, THE ISSUE THAT SEEMS
TO HAVE COME UP A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE GOLDEN STATE, TEACHER
PROGRAM IS THAT, THEY'RE SORT OF
REDUCTION OF, OF MONEY. AND SO
IT'S UNCLEAR. WHEN IT'S GOING TO
RUN OUT AND IS THERE ANY BETTER
ASSESSMENT OF THAT? BECAUSE THIS
IS A PROGRAM PEOPLE REALLY
DEPEND ON THAT'S BEEN REALLY
POPULAR AND WELL USED. YEAH. I
DON'T THINK WE HAVE AN
ASSESSMENT AT THIS POINT. WE'RE
CERTAINLY WORKING WITH THE
COMMISSION TO LOOK AT WHAT THOSE
IMPACTS ARE. I THINK WHAT CAME
TO LIGHT, REALLY FOR US IS THAT
THE PROJECTIONS WERE BASED ON
ACTUAL EXPENDITURES THAT DID NOT
INCLUDE, ENCUMBRANCES FOR AWARDS
AND THAT SORT OF WHAT'S CAUSING
SOME OF THE, THE HEARTBURN RIGHT
NOW OVER. IS THERE ENOUGH
FUNDING TO SUPPORT THE PROGRAM?
WOULD IT ENABLE NEW AWARDS TO BE
MADE IN 2425? WE'RE CERTAINLY
ASSESSING ALL OF THOSE IMPACTS
RIGHT NOW, BUT WE DON'T HAVE A
SPECIFIC A SPECIFIC RESPONSE
BEYOND THAT. OKAY I THINK I JUST
ADD THAT WE KNOW THAT RATHER
THAN 50 BEING 50 MILLION BEING
AVAILABLE, 35 MILLION IS
AVAILABLE BASED UPON THE BEST
ESTIMATES TO DATE. THERE ARE
SOME CHOICES BEFORE YOU, THOUGH,
BECAUSE EVEN THAT 35 MILLION
THAT WE KNOW EXISTS TODAY COULD
RUN DRY VERY QUICKLY. SO THERE
ARE SOME STUDENTS WHO HAVE
APPLIED FOR AWARDS. SO ONE
DECISION YOU'LL NEED TO MAKE IS
IF THEY'VE ALREADY APPLIED, BUT
THEY HAVEN'T BEEN AWARDED A
GRANT. DO YOU STILL WANT TO
ALLOW THEM TO STAY IN THE MIX,
OR DO YOU JUST WANT TO SAY
SORRY? THIS PROGRAM IS GONE,
EVEN IF YOU JUST ACCOUNT FOR
THOSE STUDENTS WHO ALREADY HAVE
DONE THAT, OR MIGHT APPLY OVER
THE COURSE OF THE NEXT MONTH OR
SO, IT SEEMS LIKE THE MONEY
MIGHT EVAPORATE. STUDENT AID
COMMISSION YEAH, IF I MAY JUST
ADD, AS WE HAVE BEEN RAISING IN,
LEGISLATIVE HEARINGS AND VARIOUS
OTHER SETTINGS THAT WE HAVE
ALWAYS BELIEVED THAT THE, THE
MONEY, THE, THE ENTIRE 500
MILLION APPROPRIATION WOULD BE
EXPENDED SOME TIME IN 24, 25.
BUT THE RATE OF INCREASE OF THIS
PROGRAM IN TERMS OF INTEREST HAS
BEEN SO, SO FAST BECAUSE THE
ELIGIBILITY EXPANDING THAT IT'S
BEEN REALLY HARD TO KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT MONTH AND WHEN EXACTLY.
BECAUSE WE DO PROVIDE AWARDS AND
THERE'S LAG TIME BETWEEN WHEN A
STUDENT RECEIVES AN AWARD LETTER
SAYING YOU'RE ELIGIBLE AND WHEN
THE MONEY, ACTUALLY THEY RECEIVE
THE CHECK IN HAND. THERE'S A BIG
LAG TIME BETWEEN THAT. AND SO WE
HAVE, IT'S BEEN WE'VE BEEN
TRYING TO PROJECT EXACTLY WHAT
DAY TO CLOSE OFF THE WORD. SO
WE'RE NEVER MAKING A PROMISE TO
A STUDENT THAT THAT THE STATE
CAN'T FULFILL. SO WE PROJECTED
THAT WOULD BE SOMETIME IN EARLY
TO MID 2425, SO THAT IS STILL
TRUE, BUT WE MAY HAVE NOT
ACCOUNTED FOR KIND OF ALL THAT
IN AS, AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE MENTIONED,
THAT THAT WOULD MEAN THAT THE 50
IT WOULD BE DIFFICULT TO HONOR
THE 50 MILLION BECAUSE WE HAVE
PEOPLE THAT IN 23, 24 STILL NEED
TO BE PAID OUT IN 24, 25. AND WE
ALSO HAVE, AS, THE LEGISLATURE
IN THE RECENT YEARS, MADE IT SO
THAT STUDENTS CAN APPLY ALMOST A
YEAR IN ADVANCE OF RECEIVING AN
AWARD SO THAT THEY CAN MAKE A
DECISION ON IF THEY WANT TO GO
INTO TEACHING BECAUSE OF
RECEIVING THIS AWARD. AND WE
HAVE STUDENTS THAT ARE APPLYING
RIGHT NOW FOR 24, 25 AND AS AS
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE MENTIONED,
WE'D HAVE TO DECIDE WHAT TO DO
WITH WITH THOSE AWARDS RELATED
TO THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. AND
LET ME JUST SAY THAT IT SEEMS
LIKE THERE'S HOW DO YOU WANT TO
CHARACTERIZE IT? JUST SOME
CHANGING INFORMATION OR CHANGING
OF UNDERSTANDING OF CERTAIN
INFORMATION. AND I HOPE THIS IS
A SUBJECT OF DISCUSSION IN THE
NEXT FEW WEEKS TO TRY TO BEST
PROTECT PEOPLE, BECAUSE WE'RE
WE'RE SO FOCUSED ON TRYING TO
ACHIEVE BUDGET REDUCTIONS THAT
THE SHORTAGE OF TEACHERS
SURVIVES. THIS, INDEPENDENTLY.
AND THIS HAS BEEN ONE OF THE
MAJOR THINGS IN THE MIDDLE OF
THAT SHORTAGE. THAT HAS BEEN A
GOOD INCENTIVE. AND SO I REALLY
HOPE WE CAN CONTINUE TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO DO THAT. AND THEN MY
OTHER LAST COMMENT IS, IS THAT
WE HAD BEEN FOCUSED IN THE WHOLE
STUDENT AID WORLD ON THE FAFSA
DECISION. THÀNH, AND I APOLOGIZE
FOR DOING AN ACRONYM. I CAN'T
EVEN DEFINE AT THIS POINT, BUT I
KNOW WHAT IT IS AND THE WITH THE
DEADLINE PUT OFF FOR ACCEPTANCES
TO SCHOOLS SO PEOPLE KNOW ABOUT
FAFSA IN THE MIDDLE OF IT. WE
HAVE THROWN THIS AND THERE ARE
PEOPLE THAT MIGHT HAVE MADE
DECISIONS ABOUT THE MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP AND WANT TO MAKE A
DECISION ABOUT GOING INTO SCHOOL
AND THEN IT'S NOT JUST BEING
CUT, BUT THE GRANTS ARE GOING TO
BE CUT SIGNIFICANTLY OVER THE
EXISTING THING. IF YOU CAN
FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET IN, AND
THAT IS GOING TO AFFECT
DECISIONS. THAT AND SOME OF
THESE OTHER PROGRAMS. AND SO IN
THE, THE, THE CUT TO THE MIDDLE
CLASS TAX, MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP WAS BRUTAL. AND
DISPROPORTIONATE. AND SO I
REALLY HOPE THAT IN THE REMIX OF
THINGS WE RECOGNIZE TOO, THAT
THAT WE CAN DO SOMETHING THERE
AND THE PROBLEM IS, IS THAT BY
THE TIME WE DO IT, SOME PEOPLE
WILL HAVE HAD TO MAKE THEIR
DECISIONS ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT.
AND THE WORST THING THAT COULD
HAPPEN IS WE FIGURE OUT HOW TO
RESTORE SOME OF IT. AND PEOPLE
PASSED UP ON GOING INTO A
COLLEGE BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T
THINK IT WAS GOING TO BE THERE.
AND WE HAVE PUT THEM IN A IN A
GROSS SITUATION BY THIS
DISCUSSION. SO I JUST HOPE WE
CAN SEE IF WE CAN FIGURE
SOMETHING OUT. AND RIGHT NOW,
OBVIOUS THERE'S BRUTAL CUTS
EVERYWHERE ACROSS THE BUDGET,
AND WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO TRY
TO FIGURE OUT ON HOW SOME OF
THEM TO TRY TO MITIGATE THE
IMPACTS. AND THIS IS PROBABLY
ONE OF THOSE. SO, I WOULD JUST
CALL THAT OUT AS WE, CLOSE THIS
DISCUSSION. BUT I APPRECIATE, IT
AND I APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE
AND HELPING US WITH THIS. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO THE LAST ISSUE
ON THE BUDGET, WHICH IS ISSUE
SEVEN, WHICH IS THE CALIFORNIA
STATE LIBRARY. AND I KNOW THAT
IT'S, CHRIS FERGUSON AND
JENNIFER PURCELL AGAIN. AND WE
DO HAVE THE STATE LIBRARIAN HERE
WHO I AM CERTAIN WILL BE ANXIOUS
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS IF WE IF WE
PUSH HIM, NOTHING WOULD PLEASE
ME MORE, SENATOR. NO, IT'S
CLEARLY THE LIBRARIANS. NOT
UNDER OATH. SO LET'S START WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND GO
TO THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST CHAIR
CHRIS FERGUSON, WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I'LL
START WITH THE MORE TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENT, WHICH IS THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WE HAD
PROPOSED TO REVERT ROUGHLY 131
MILLION FROM, THE LIBRARY
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT PROGRAM, AS
WE AS YOU NOTED IN PRIOR
DISCUSSIONS, THERE WAS, A NOTE
THAT WE WOULD ADJUST THIS BASED
ON WHAT ACTUAL GRANTS HAD BEEN
AWARDED AND PROVIDED OUT TO
LOCAL LIBRARIES. THE MAY
REVISION DOES THIS. THAT 131
MILLION IS NOW, 4.4 MILLION ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND. WHAT WAS THAT
SECOND NUMBER? 4.4 MILLION. SO
IT'S LARGELY BEEN ERODED, WITH
THAT, THOUGH, I WOULD NOTE,
THREE OTHER, SORT OF CORE
ADJUSTMENT AT WELL, AT THE STATE
LIBRARY THAT WE PROPOSED, THE
FIRST BEING WE PROPOSE TO REDUCE
SUPPORT FOR THE DOLLY PARTON
IMAGINATION LIBRARY, BY
40,000,001 TIME GENERAL FUND, WE
PROPOSE TO ELIMINATE ONGOING
SUPPORT FOR THE LUNCH AT THE
LIBRARY PROGRAM, YOU KNOW, WITH
THE HOPE BEING THAT, SCHOOLS
THROUGH EXPANDED LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES, PROGRAMS AND
OTHER SUMMER PROGRAMS MAY BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE MEALS TO
STUDENTS, ON THEIR CAMPUSES, AND
THEN LASTLY, TO REDUCE SUPPORT
FOR THE, CALIFORNIA LIBRARY
SERVICES ACT BY ROUGHLY 1.75
MILLION. ONGOING GENERAL FUND.
THAT PROGRAM PROVIDES A
DISCRETIONARY SUPPORT TO LOCAL
LIBRARIES FOR THINGS LIKE BOOK
ACQUISITION, BOOK LOANS BETWEEN
LIBRARIES, ITEMS OF THAT
CRITERIA. LASTLY, I WOULD NOTE
THAT THE LIBRARY WOULD ALSO BE
SUBJECT TO THE 7.95% STATEWIDE
REDUCTION. LEGISLATIVE ANALYST,
SO JUST A FEW COMMENTS HERE. SO
ON THE IMAGINATION LIBRARY, AS
YOUR AGENDA NOTES, EVEN UNDER
THE MAY PROPOSAL, THEY LEAVE 28
MILLION OF UNSPENT PRIOR YEAR
MONIES FOR THE PROGRAM BECAUSE
IT IS ONE TIME MONEY, AND
BECAUSE BECAUSE YOU ARE FACING A
MULTI YEAR BUDGET DEFICIT, WE
WOULD RECOMMEND SCOOPING ALL
REMAINING FUNDS FROM THAT
PROGRAM FOR LUNCH AT THE
LIBRARY, THIS WOULD ELIMINATE
THE ONGOING PROGRAM. IT WAS
CREATED IN 2223. THERE HAS BEEN
SINCE THAT TIME A SUBSTANTIAL
INCREASE IN SCHOOL MEAL
OPPORTUNITIES THROUGH SCHOOLS,
THIS PARTICULAR PROGRAM, WHEN
THE STATE FUNDED IT, PROVIDED
TWO POSITIONS. SO AS AN
ALTERNATIVE TO DOING THIS,
UNALLOCATED 7.95% REDUCTION,
WHERE FINANCE DECIDES SOMEWHERE
DOWN THE LINE HOW THAT CUT IS
TAKEN, THE LEGISLATURE COULD
TAKE A MORE STRATEGIC APPROACH.
AND JUST IF YOU DO DECIDE THERE
ARE ANY ONGOING PROGRAMS THAT
YOU CHOOSE AS PART OF YOUR
BUDGET, BALANCING PACKAGE TO
ELIMINATE, YOU COULD SWEEP
ASSOCIATED POSITIONS IN A MORE
DIRECT WAY. SO THAT'S ALL I
THINK. THANK YOU. GREAT. AND
WOULD YOU LIKE TO MAKE ANY
COMMENT, MR. LIBRARIAN? WOULD IS
THE MICROPHONE NOW IT'S ON.
WELL, I NOTICED ON THE AGENDA,
YOUR IT SAYS YOU'D LIKE TO HEAR
FROM US. DO WE HAVE ANY DATA ON
CURRENT PARTICIPATION AT LUNCH?
AT THE LIBRARY? LUNCH AT THE
LIBRARY WAS A PROGRAM. WELL, YOU
KNOW THIS THAT WAS CREATED BY
HOLLY MITCHELL, IT WAS DESIGNED
TO HELP FEED MORE HUNGRY, POOR
KIDS DURING THE SUMMER, OF WHICH
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
THÀNH WHICH WHICH DOES PROVIDE
MEALS FOR HUNGRY, POOR KIDS IN
THE SUMMER, SAYS THAT THERE'S 2
MILLION KIDS IN CALIFORNIA,
RIGHT? THE MOST AWESOME STATE IN
THE RICHEST COUNTRY ON EARTH.
THERE'S 2 MILLION KIDS WHO
QUALIFY FOR FEDERAL FREE OR
SUBSIDIZED MEALS, WHO GO HUNGRY
EVERY SUMMER, EVEN WITH PROGRAMS
WHERE SCHOOLS AT SCHOOLS CONDUCT
MEAL SITES IN THE SUMMER. SO THE
INTENT OF THIS PROGRAM WAS TO
USE THE SORT OF THE SECRET
WEAPON OF LIBRARIES TO HELP
INCREASE BOTH THE NUMBER OF
MEALS THAT WENT OUT AND USE
LIBRARIES AS THE COMMUNITY
CENTERS THAT THEY ARE TO CONNECT
OTHER ENTITIES AROUND THE
COMMUNITY TO BETTER COORDINATE
EFFORTS TO FEED HUNGRY, POOR
KIDS IN THE SUMMER. SO IN SUMMER
OF 2023, 270,000 MEALS SERVED AT
189 LIBRARIES, ONE OF THE
COOLEST THINGS THAT SENATOR
MITCHELL PUT IN THIS BILL WAS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR MICRO GRANTS SO
THAT LIBRARIES THAT WERE TOO
SMALL TO FEED THE KIDS THERE, OR
OTHER MEAL SITES OPERATED BY
OTHER COMMUNITY ENTITIES, RIGHT.
THE LIBRARIES WOULD GET, I THINK
IT'S LIKE 1500 BUCKS. I MEAN, WE
AIN'T BREAKING THE BANK AT MONTE
CARLO, BUT ALLOWING LIBRARIES TO
COME AND SET UP POP UP LIBRARIES
AT THESE OTHER SITES TO TRY AND
INCREASE USAGE RIGHT BY, PARENTS
AND CAREGIVERS AND OTHER
FAMILIES. IT'S, I'M TELLING YOU
WHAT YOU KNOW ALREADY, BUT, I
MEAN, THE FEDERAL PROGRAM IS
IT'S RIDICULOUSLY BYZANTINE. IT
WORKED BETTER DURING THE
PANDEMIC WHEN ALL THE RULES WERE
WAIVED. BUT I THINK I THINK THE
LIKE I SAID, THE MAGIC OF THIS
PROGRAM, IF YOU WILL, IS THAT IT
INVOLVES LIBRARIES. AND I'VE
BEEN TO FIVE, SIX, MAYBE SEVEN
OF THESE LUNCH AT THE LIBRARY
EVENTS AROUND THE STATE. AND
ALMOST TO A PERSON LIKE THE KIDS
WALK OUT OF THE COMMUNITY ROOM
AND SAY, WHERE DO WE SIGN UP FOR
SUMMER READING? AND I ALSO
RECALL, I DON'T THAT THERE WAS
125,000 BOOKS HANDED OUT TO KIDS
THROUGH THIS PROGRAM, WHICH IS
SEPARATE FROM ALL THE OTHER FREE
BOOKS THAT LIBRARIES HAND OUT.
AND IT TURNS OUT I HAD NO IDEA.
BUT IT'S NOW BECOME THE CHEAPEST
WAY TO CREATE A STRONG READER IS
TO GIVE THEM BOOKS TO READ AT
HOME. SO, YOU KNOW, MY
GRANDMOTHER WOULD SAY, THIS IS
KIND OF A PENNY WISE AND POUND
FOOLISH THING. IN ADDITION,
WE'VE BEEN ADVOCATING DATING, TO
MAINTAIN A PROGRAM, A PILOT
PROGRAM THAT WAS CREATED THAT
OFFERS US, FREE ONLINE, 24 OVER
SEVEN LIVE TUTORING TO ANY
STUDENT WHO WANTS IT IN ENGLISH,
SPANISH, FIVE LANGUAGES, FIVE
OTHER LANGUAGES IN STEM AND
LANGUAGE ARTS. THERE'S 1,000,007
KIDS USING AT 1.7 MILLION HITS
IN THE LAST SCHOOL YEAR. AND
IT'S A YEARLY SUBSCRIPTION OF
3.5 MILLION, WHICH IS LESS THAN
$1 PER SCHOOL KID. AND BOTH OF
BOTH THAT PROGRAM AND LUNCH AT
THE LIBRARY SEEMED TO ME, IF YOU
KNOW, THEY TELL YOU IN
MANAGEMENT AND LEADERSHIP STUFF
THAT OKAY, WHAT'S THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING TO DO RIGHT NOW?
THESE ARE PROGRAMS THAT ARE
BEING USED THAT ARE BENEFITING
HUNGRY, POOR KIDS AND HELPING
STUDENTS DO BETTER IN SCHOOL.
AND IF WE DON'T HAVE THEM, THEN
WE GO BACK TO THE CRAPPY STATUS
QUO, WHERE IF YOU GOT DOUGH,
RIGHT, YOU GET YOU, YOU GET FOOD
AND YOU GET THE ONLINE TUTORING
AND BOTH OF THEM ARE RELATIVELY
SMALL IN COMPARISON TO WHAT I'VE
HEARD FOR THE LAST HOUR OF THE
SPENDING THAT'S GOING ON
ELSEWHERE IN OTHER PARTS OF THE
EDUCATION BUDGET. I SHOULD STOP
NOW. YOU MAY TERMINATE MY
ACCIDENTALLY TERMINATE MY CAREER
. YOU MIGHT HAVE ALREADY DONE
THAT, BUT. BUT I APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS. AND IT IS THE FIRST
TIME, I THINK THIS SESSION THE
WORD CRAPPY HAS BEEN USED IN
FRONT OF US. SO, THANK YOU FOR
DOING THAT. I DIDN'T QUOTE JOHN
BURTON JUST IN DEFERENCE TO THE
I CAN DEPORTMENT OF THE SYSTEM.
I USED ONE OF THE SEVEN FCC
WORDS ON A RADIO SHOW LAST
FRIDAY MORNING. I DIDN'T KNOW
THAT WAS STILL IN EFFECT, BUT IT
IS FOR PUBLIC RADIO. YES, I YEAH
, I DESCRIBED A CERTAIN KIND OF
SHOW THAT WE WERE IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE SHOW BEING THE SECOND
HALF OF THE WORD I USED, AND I
HAD THE SEVEN, SEVEN, IT HE
SAID, STOP RIGHT THERE. AND HE
READ A COMPLETE STATEMENT FOR
THE FPC, FCC, BE CAREFUL, WE'RE
BEING STREAMED HERE. THAT'S
EXACTLY WHY I USED JUST THE SHOW
PART OF THAT WORD INTERNALLY.
RIGHT. THE 7.8. I MEAN, THAT'S I
MEAN, I GET THAT THAT'S IN
ACROSS THE BOARD THING THAT I
HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT. I WAS
GOING TO ASK YOU ABOUT THAT, BUT
I THINK WE'RE GOOD. YOU'VE BEEN
QUITE ARTICULATE, THE OUTGOING
SENATE PRESIDENT PRO TEM WILL
PROBABLY BE UNHAPPY THAT YOU
DIDN'T MENTION THE DOLLY PARTON,
PART, BECAUSE THAT WAS SHE WAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN THAT. WELL, THE
REMAINING FUNDS RIGHT. IS IT
IDEAL? NO, BUT IT'S A DIFFICULT
BUDGET YEAR. I MEAN, WE'VE HEARD
THAT OVER AND OVER AGAIN. THE
REMAINING FUNDS ALLOW US TO
SIGNIFICANTLY GROW THE PROGRAM
AND ADD, ADD, ADD MORE AT, AT AT
LEAST. RIGHT. WE CAN GET UP TO A
HALF A MILLION KIDS. YOU GET YOU
EACH. ADDRESS THE QUESTIONS I
WAS GOING TO ASK IN YOUR
COMMENTS. AND IT'S VERY
SIGNIFICANT THAT IT WENT DOWN TO
4 MILLION IN THE GRANTS. GIVEN
WHAT WE TALKED ABOUT FIRST, THAT
MEANS THAT MOST OF THAT WAS
OBLIGATED. SO ARE THERE. WELL,
AND THE 4 MILLION IN SAVINGS
COMES FROM PEOPLE WHO WE GAVE
THE WE SAID, HEY, LOOK IT. YOU
GOT TO TURN IN YOUR PAPERWORK BY
DECEMBER 31ST. AND THEY DIDN'T.
SO IT'S A FROM MY PERSPECTIVE,
IT'S A SELF-INFLICTED WOUND ON
THOSE JURISDICTIONS. AND NOW
YOU'VE SAID THAT IN PUBLIC AND
YOU'LL BE ABLE TO TELL THEM WITH
CLARITY. I'VE ALREADY TOLD THEM
WITH CLARITY, WELL, CLARITY IS
CLEARLY YOUR GUIDING STAR RIGHT
NOW. THAT'S NOT THE WORD THAT'S
OFTEN USED. YEAH. YES, BUT
THAT'S ONE OF THE SEVEN AND
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GET INTO
THAT. SO GOD BLESS YOU. SENATOR
CORTESE, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
RESCUE US HERE? YEAH, I PROBABLY
SHOULDN'T TRY TO DO THAT, SO I
WON'T, YOU KNOW, I APPRECIATE
EVERYTHING THAT'S BEEN SAID AND
THE PASSION WITH WITH WHICH IT'S
BEEN SAID. WE HAVE ACROSS THE
BOARD, YOU KNOW, CHALLENGES THAT
PREEXIST THIS BUDGET, WITH
REGARD TO KIDS, ESPECIALLY,
ESPECIALLY DURING THE SUMMER
MONTHS, WE GOT THIS WEEK, NEXT
WEEK, WE'LL BE GRADUATING 15,000
MCKINNEY-VENTO KIDS OUT OF OUR
SCHOOLS, AND THAT'S JUST THE
ONES THAT ARE SENIORS WHO ARE
DEFINED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, AS HOMELESS AND OF
COURSE, GET BENEFITS WHILE
THEY'RE IN SCHOOL. SO THE GOOD
NEWS IS THEY CROSS THE STAGE AND
GET THE DIPLOMA. THE BAD NEWS IS
THEY STEP OFF THE STAGE AND
THEY'RE OUT OF LUCK, NO MORE
FOSTER KIDS, RIGHT? AND I'M SURE
THOSE ARE SOME OF, OF THE FOLKS
WHO ARE LOOKING FOR, ANY SOURCE
OF, OF BENEFITS, WHETHER IT'S,
YOU KNOW, MEALS AT THE LIBRARY
OR MEALS AT COMMUNITY CENTERS OR
MEALS SOMEWHERE ELSE, SO, YOU
KNOW, IT'S HEARTBREAKING TO
THOSE OF US THAT HAVE BEEN IN
THE PROCESS, SUCCESSFULLY AT
SOME LEVEL OF STAYING UP
PROGRAMS TO, TO MITIGATE THAT
HISTORIC PERIOD OF TIME THAT
HASN'T RECEIVED ENOUGH ATTENTION
, YOU KNOW, THROW THIS IN THE
MIX IF THERE'S A WAY FOR US TO,
YOU KNOW, MITIGATE THIS, THIS
PARTICULAR CUT SOMEHOW OR FIGURE
SOMETHING OUT, YOU KNOW,
CERTAINLY THAT THAT SHOULD BE
DONE, YOU KNOW, GIVEN THE
VULNERABILITY AND THE REAL PAIN
THAT IS GOING TO CAUSE I THINK
DURING THE ENTIRE BUDGET
PROCESS, WE USE THE TERM PAIN
PRETTY LOOSELY BECAUSE THERE'S
PAIN FOR US, THERE'S PAIN FOR
THOSE WHO, WHO, WORK HERE, YOU
KNOW, IN GENERAL, IN THE OVERALL
STATE SYSTEM, ONE WAY OR THE
OTHER. AND THEN THERE'S THIS
SORT OF REAL PAIN THAT OCCURS
WHEN, YOU KNOW, MEALS ARE CUT.
YOU KNOW, FOR YOUTH OR, YOU
KNOW, OLDER ADULTS, FOR EXAMPLE.
WE'VE SEEN THAT IN PAST
BUDGETARY CRISES, IT'S, IT'S
THAT KIND OF PAIN THAT THERE
REALLY ISN'T A WAY TO MITIGATE,
YOU KNOW, OTHER THAN TO JUST
REPLACE, THE RESOURCES AS
QUICKLY AS YOU POSSIBLY CAN. SO
ANYWAY, I APPRECIATE THE
TESTIMONY, AND I'LL BE ONE TO
TRY TO HELP. DO OUR BEST TO
FIGURE OUT A WORKAROUND. THANK
YOU, SENATOR, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND I THINK THOSE ARE VERY
ELOQUENT CLOSING REMARKS. AND WE
HAVE MADE OUR OUR POSITION
CLEAR. WE THANK EVERYBODY FOR,
FOR THE WORK THAT THEY MIGHT DO
AND TRYING TO DEAL WITH WHAT
WE'VE BROUGHT UP. SO THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE TODAY. WE REALLY
APPRECIATE IT. THAT COMPLETES
OUR CONSIDERATION OF THE ISSUES
IN PART B, LET ME TAKE A SURVEY
HERE, BY HAND OF WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN PUBLIC COMMENT.
123456789 1011 1213 14 1516 1718
1920 2122. WE'RE GOING TO DO
THIS, AND WE'RE GOING TO TRY TO
LIMIT YOU TO 45 SECONDS BECAUSE
BECAUSE I'M, I'M DIVIDING IT BY
THE AMOUNT OF TIME WE HAVE LEFT
IN THE HEARING. SO IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE COME TO THE PODIUM, YEAH.
AT SOME POINT YOU HAVE TO GET UP
AND THERE'S A FEW MORE PEOPLE.
SENATOR CORTEZ SAID IF THERE'S
MORE SPEAKERS IN THE TIME IS
RUNNING, HE WOULD BE HAPPY TO
PRESIDE FOR THE LAST SPEAKERS.
SO IF YOU'RE WILLING TO DO THAT,
I'M WILLING TO CHANGE IT TO A
MINUTE, BECAUSE I WILL PROBABLY
HAVE TO WALK OUT OF HERE IN 10
TO 15 MINUTES. AND THEN SENATOR
CORTEZ CAN CONTINUE. SO GIVE US
YOUR NAME, YOUR ORGANIZATION,
AND YOUR POSITION ON, ANY OF
THESE ITEMS. GOOD AFTERNOON. MY
NAME IS CODY VAN FELD, AND I'M
REPRESENTING JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH. I'M ALSO
HERE AS A FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
AND A STUDENT WHO DID QUALIFY
FOR THE CAL GRANT. BUT MANY OF
MY PEERS DO NOT. SO I URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO ADOPT THE PHASED IN
APPROACH TO THE CAL GRANT REFORM
PROPOSED BY THE CAL GRANT REFORM
COALITION TO MAKE THIS
ACCESSIBLE TO MORE FOSTER YOUTH
LIKE MYSELF. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WE APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS. GOOD AFTERNOON,
JESSICA SACCO, ON BEHALF OF
CHILDREN. NOW, DITTO THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKERS COMMENTS AND
ALSO IN OPPOSITION TO THE
PROPOSED CUTS TO THE GOLDEN
STATE TEACHER GRANT PROGRAM, FOR
THE REASONS THAT WERE
ARTICULATED EARLIER BY THE
COMMITTEE. THIS IS A SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAM. WE ARE STRUGGLING TO
RECRUIT ENOUGH TEACHERS, AND
THIS IS A DECISION POINT FACTOR
WHEN TEACHERS, WHEN POTENTIAL
CANDIDATES ARE MAKING A DECISION
ON WHETHER OR NOT TO PURSUE A
CAREER IN TEACHING OR NOT, SO
FUNDAMENTALLY OPPOSE THE CUTS TO
THAT PROGRAM. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS.
WELCOME. KIMBERLY ROSENBERGER
WITH SEIU. WE ARE APPRECIATIVE
OF TRYING TO MAKE SCHOOLS WHOLE
IN K THROUGH 12. HOWEVER, BY
PIECEMEALING CERTAIN PROTECTIONS
GO AWAY, ESPECIALLY THOSE OF THE
CLASSIFIED AND CERTIFICATED
WORKFORCE. WITH LATE LAYOFFS, WE
WOULD ENCOURAGE GUARDRAILS TO
ENSURE THAT WHILE WE ENCOURAGE
STABILITY IN K THROUGH 12, WE
MAINTAIN THE WORKFORCE THAT
SERVES THOSE STUDENTS. ALSO ON
CSU, THE COMMITMENT TO THE
COMPACT IS IMPORTANT TO US, BUT
WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE LABOR CONTRACTS AND THE
PROGRESS TO ADDRESS INEQUITIES
AREN'T IMPACTED BY THE FUNDING
MECHANISM. AND THEN FINALLY, WE
HAVE REAL CONCERNS ABOUT THE
SMALL BUDGET THAT IT TAKES TO
FUND THOSE èC LABOR CENTERS
BEING CUT WHEN THE IMPACT AND
VALUE OF THOSE èC LABOR CENTERS
ARE MONUMENTAL. SO WE WOULD
DISCOURAGE THAT CUT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS. WELCOME. GOOD
MORNING. I'M JACQUELINE PEREZ,
I'M AN ACADEMIC WORKER AT UCLA
AND THE MEMBER OF THE EXECUTIVE
BOARD OF UNITED AUTO WORKERS,
LOCAL 4811. MY UNION, THE
LARGEST LABOR UNION AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SYSTEM,
IS OPPOSED TO THE $13 BILLION
BUDGET CUTS TO THE LABOR
CENTERS, RESEARCH AND EDUCATION
AT THE èC, UAW REPRESENTS THE
VAST MAJORITY OF PEOPLE WHO WORK
IN THE UC LABOR CENTERS,
INCLUDING GRADUATE, STUDENT,
POSTDOCTORAL AND CAREER
RESEARCHERS, MANY OF WHOM ARE MY
COLLEAGUES. OUR MEMBERS DO THE
RESEARCH THAT CALIFORNIA NEEDS
TO PROTECT WORKERS ON THE JOB,
PROMOTE EQUITABLE PATHS FOR
BLACK WORKERS, UNDOCUMENTED
WORKERS, FEMALE WORKERS TO GET
GOOD JOBS AND DEVELOP PLANS TO
TRANSITION WORKERS TO GREEN JOBS
TO HELP CALIFORNIA MEET ITS
CLIMATE GOALS. SOME OF THIS WORK
IS TACKLING BIG BUSINESS
MONOPOLIES SUCH AS UBER AND
LYFT, PRICING OUT INDEPENDENT
TAXI WORKERS, UNDERCUTTING WAGES
AND DRIVING THEM INTO POVERTY,
OR ON HOW THOUSANDS OF UNITED
FOOD AND COMMERCIAL WORKERS WHO
WORK IN MEATPACKING PLANTS HAD
THEIR JOB TITLES ARBITRARILY
CHANGED BY THEIR EMPLOYER AND
WERE CUT ACCESS TO UNION
GUARANTEED HEALTH CARE, SICK
TIME, AND OTHER CRITICAL
PROTECTIONS. THE STATE HAS MADE
AN IMPORTANT INVESTMENT TO
EXPAND THE WORK OF THE LABOR
CENTERS ACROSS THE STATE, BUT
THIS INVESTMENT WILL BE WASTED
IF THE STATE CHOOSES TO CUT
FUNDING. NOW, WE URGE YOU TO CUT
THIS VITAL PROGRAM. WE URGE YOU
NOT TO CUT THIS VITAL PROGRAM
AND FULLY FUND THE UC LABOR
CENTER. SO UAW MEMBERS CAN GET
BACK TO WORK. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WELCOME WELCOME. MY NAME
IS KEN JACOBS. I WORK AS
CO-CHAIR OF THE UC BERKELEY
LABOR CENTER, AND I'M HERE AS AN
INDIVIDUAL TO EXPRESS MY CONCERN
ABOUT THE PROPOSED CUTS OF THE
$13 MILLION TO THE UC LABOR
CENTERS. AS SENATOR CORTEZ
NOTED, THE LABOR CENTERS PROVIDE
VITAL RESEARCH AND ANALYSIS THAT
INFORMS POLICIES ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE, AND
CUTTING THESE FUNDS WOULD
DEPRIVE THE STATE LEGISLATURE
WITH IMPORTANT RESEARCH AND NOT
JUST THE LEGISLATURE AND BEYOND,
WITH IMPORTANT RESEARCH AND
RIGOROUS DATA TO MAKE INFORMED
POLICY DECISIONS THAT AFFECT OUR
WORKFORCE GOING INTO THE FUTURE.
ON IMPORTANT ISSUES LIKE THE
CHANGING OF CLIMATE AND GREEN
JOBS, AI AND TECHNOLOGY, THE
FUTURE OF THE DIRECT CARE
WORKFORCE. SO WE HOPE YOU WILL,
MAINTAIN THOSE FUNDS. THANKS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS. WELCOME. GOOD
AFTERNOON. ALEXIS MANZANILLA.
I'M AN ACADEMIC RESEARCHER AT
THE UC BERKELEY LABOR CENTER,
AND MEMBER OF UAW 4811 AT THE UC
BERKELEY LABOR CENTER. ACADEMIC
RESEARCHERS LIKE MYSELF DO
RESEARCH ON IMPORTANT POLICY
ISSUES, SUCH AS EXPANDING HEALTH
COVERAGE REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS, HOW WORKERS
CAN HAVE A VOICE IN
TECHNOLOGICAL CHANGES IN THEIR
WORKPLACE, AND DEVELOPING
WORKFORCE STANDARDS AND
STRATEGIES NEEDED TO HELP
CALIFORNIA TRANSITION TO A CLEAN
ECONOMY AT THE UC BERKELEY
OCCUPATIONAL HEALTH PROGRAM,
ACADEMIC RESEARCHERS LEAD WORKER
EDUCATION RELATED TO THEIR
HEALTH AND SAFETY RIGHTS, NOT
ONLY AM I CONCERNED THAT THESE
CUTS COULD POTENTIALLY LEAD TO
MY FELLOW UNION MEMBERS LOSING
THEIR JOBS, BUT THAT THEY WILL
IMPEDE STATE SUPPORTED RESEARCH
THAT CAN ADVANCE CALIFORNIA
LABOR STANDARDS AND PUBLIC
POLICIES THAT SUPPORT AN ECONOMY
FOR ALL. I URGE YOU TO OPPOSE
THESE CUTS. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WELCOME
HELLO. MY NAME IS ANNA PADILLA
AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE UC MERCED COMMUNITY AND
LABOR CENTER. I'M HERE AS AN
INDIVIDUAL TO EXPRESS MY CONCERN
WITH THE MAY REVISED PROPOSED
BUDGET CUTS TO THE UC LABOR
CENTER'S ONGOING FUNDS. FOR
DECADES, UC LABOR CENTERS HAVE
PLAYED A LEADING ROLE IN
PRODUCING WORLD CLASS RESEARCH
AND PUBLIC EDUCATION THAT HAS
INFORMED MAJOR POLICIES IN
CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AT THE INTERSECTION OF
WORK AND IMMIGRATION, HEALTH
CARE, SHIFTING INDUSTRIES,
CLIMATE CHANGE AND PUBLIC
DISASTERS. THE PROPOSED BUDGET
CUTS WOULD HAVE A DISASTROUS
IMPACT ON POLICY MAKING FOR
THOSE FURTHEST ON THE MARGINS,
AND IT WOULD ELIMINATE THE
STATE'S ONLY APPLIED RESEARCH
CENTER IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY,
ONE OF THE MOST ECONOMICALLY AND
ENVIRONMENTALLY DISADVANTAGED
REGIONS IN THE NATION. WE
PROPOSE THAT THE UC LABOR
CENTER'S ANNUAL ONGOING
ALLOCATION NOT BE CUT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WELCOME. HI. GOOD AFTERNOON,
JANICE O'MALLEY WITH AFSCME
CALIFORNIA, DITTO THE COMMENTS
THAT SEIU MADE ON K-12 FUNDING,
ALSO, WE OPPOSE, ISSUE TWO, WE
OPPOSE THE ELIMINATION OF
FUNDING FOR UC LABOR CENTERS.
AND THANK YOU, SENATOR CORTEZ,
FOR YOUR COMMENTS ON ON ITS
IMPORTANCE TO THE STATE AND TO,
WORKERS ACROSS THE STATE, ALSO,
WE SUPPORT ISSUE FIVE FUNDING
FOR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
NURSING PROGRAMS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WELCOME. GOOD AFTERNOON. MARY
WASHINGTON, ON BEHALF OF THE CAL
STATE STUDENT ASSOCIATION, WHICH
REPRESENTS THE NEARLY HALF A
MILLION CSU STUDENTS ACROSS THE
STATE. I'M JOINED BY OUR
PARTNERS AT NEXT GEN POLICY IN
CALIFORNIA COMPETES AS WELL AS
THE CAL GRANT REFORM COALITION.
TO SAY THAT, WE ASK THAT YOU
MAINTAIN THE COMMITMENT MADE IN
THE 2022 BUDGET TO ENACT CAL
GRANT REFORM TO ENSURE THAT OVER
130,000 NEW STUDENTS WILL HAVE
THE FINANCIAL MEANS TO OBTAIN A
HIGHER EDUCATION. OUR REQUEST IS
THAT THE LEGISLATURE INITIATES
CAL GRANT REFORM THIS YEAR
THROUGH A ONE TIME INVESTMENT
THAT IMPLEMENTS Kò STRUCTURAL
AND ELIGIBILITY CHANGES. USING
THE 60 MILLION SAVINGS FROM THE
JANUARY BUDGETS INCREASED CAL
GRANT SPENDING. FINALLY, ON
BEHALF OF CSSA, WE ALSO ASK THAT
YOU CONTINUE TO SUPPORT STUDENTS
AND THEIR SUCCESS BY MAINTAINING
THE GOVERNOR'S COMPACT AND DO
NOT CUT FUNDING TO THE CSU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WELCOME. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
AND SENATOR CORTEZ, JONATHAN
LIGHTMAN, ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA, WE WANT TO THANK THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR THEIR SUPPORT
FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES REFLECTED
IN THE MAY REVISE, PARTICULARLY
BY THE INCREASED COLA AND
MAINTAINING THE ONE TIME FUNDS
FOR NURSING FOR THE REASONS
SHARED BY THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU AND THE
ADMINISTRATION AS WE CONCLUDE
THIS BUDGET PROCESS AND HOPE TO
FIND A WAY FORWARD WITH A PHASED
IN APPROACH FOR CAL GRANT
REFORM, PERHAPS ALONG THE LINES
DESCRIBED BY THE JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR FOSTER YOUTH.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HI, TIFFANY MACK, ON BEHALF OF
CFT, A UNION OF EDUCATORS AND
CLASSIFIED PROFESSIONALS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THIS HEARING. WE
OPPOSE THE CUTS TO THE UC LABOR
CENTER. THE PROPOSED REDUCTION
TO THE UC BASED FUNDING FOR 2526
AND THE PROPOSED PROPOSITION 98
MANEUVER. WE ARE FURTHER
REVIEWING POSITIONS ON EITHER
OTHER ITEMS AT THIS TIME, BUT TO
LEAVE ON A POSITIVE NOTE, WE
SUPPORT THE APPLICATION OF THE
STATUTORY COLA TO THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SEGMENTS AND THE
EDUCATION CATEGORY, AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO DISCUSSIONS TO
PREVENT FURTHER PINK SLIPPING OF
OUR EDUCATION STAFF. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WELCOME. THANK YOU. AND GOOD
AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR. MALIK
BYNUM WITH UAW, ASC LOCAL 3930,
REPRESENTING OVER 171,000 IHSS
AND CHILD CARE PROVIDERS ACROSS
THE STATE HERE, IN SOLIDARITY
WITH OUR UC LABOR CENTER
PARTNERS TO REJECT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO
PULL BACK FUNDING FOR EXPANDED
LABOR RESEARCH AND SERVICE
ACROSS THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. THE LABOR CENTER HAS
ALWAYS BEEN A PIVOTAL RESOURCE
PROVIDING ANALYSIS AND COUNSEL
TO LEGISLATORS AND LABOR
ADVOCATES ALIKE IN WAYS THAT
MANY OTHER RESOURCES CANNOT.
WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY URGE
THE COMMITTEE TO REJECT THIS
PROPOSAL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WELCOME HI, KELLY BURNS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU, OF COURSE, FOR YOUR
COMMITMENT TO PUBLIC HIGHER ED.
WE ASK THAT YOU CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT THE COMPACT AND THE
COMMITMENT TO OUR STUDENTS AND
FACULTY. WE ALSO ASK THAT YOU
MAKE SURE TO HONOR THE VERY HARD
FOUGHT LABOR CONTRACTS AND
PROGRESS THAT WE HAVE MADE.
ADDITIONALLY WE ECHO THE
COMMENTS TO PROTECT THE UC LABOR
CENTERS THAT ARE SO CENTRAL TO
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WELCOME, NEIL SWEENEY. I'VE A
MEMBER OF UAW 4811, THE UNION OF
48,000 ACADEMIC WORKERS AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. I'VE
SERVED AS PRESIDENT FOR MANY
YEARS, AND I'M HERE ALONG WITH
MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES, TO OPPOSE
THE ELIMINATION OF FUNDING FOR
LABOR CENTERS. THEY PROVIDE VERY
VALUABLE POLICY ANALYSIS. I'VE
SEEN MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES, WHO
WORK AT THE LABOR CENTERS,
TESTIFY AT HEARINGS AND THIS
BUILDING AND AT THE CAPITOL IN
JUST IN THE PAST WEEKS. AND THEY
HAVE PROVIDED ANALYSIS FOR MANY
DIFFERENT AGENCIES, INCLUDING
THE DEPARTMENT OF LABOR
STANDARDS ENFORCEMENT, WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY, AGRICULTURAL
LABOR BOARD, AND DIVISION OF
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND HEALTH
AND SAFETY, AND ONE OF YOUR
COLLEAGUES, OF COURSE, SENATOR
SAMUEL CUEVAS, WORKED FOR MANY
YEARS AT THE BLACK WORKER CENTER
AND DID A LOT OF VERY VALUABLE
WORK THERE. SO I'D ENCOURAGE YOU
TO TALK TO HER MORE ABOUT WHY
THIS IS SUCH AN IMPORTANT
FUNDING. THANK YOU. I'M NOT
SUPPOSED TO SPEAK IN RESPONSE,
BUT BELIEVE ME, SHE'S TALKED TO
US. HI. I'M ED FLORES, FACULTY
DIRECTOR OF THE UC MERCED
COMMUNITY AND LABOR CENTER. I'M
HERE TO EXPRESS MY CONCERN WITH
PROPOSED BUDGET CUTS TO THE UC
LABOR CENTER'S ONGOING FUNDING.
THE PROPOSED BUDGET CUTS WOULD
HAVE A DISASTROUS IMPACT ON
POLICY MAKING, PARTICULARLY FOR
THOSE IN RURAL REGIONS AND THOSE
FURTHEST ON THE MARGINS. IN THE
PAST YEAR, WE RELEASED A STUDY
THAT INFORMED A FEDERAL $65
MILLION INITIATIVE TO STABILIZE
AND PROTECT AGRICULTURAL JOBS,
OF WHICH CALIFORNIA HAD THE MOST
APPLICATIONS. ALSO LAST YEAR,
FOLLOWING EPIC FLOOD DISASTERS,
WE CONDUCTED AN UNPRECEDENTED
EVIDENCE BASED STUDY ON UNMET
NEED THAT LED TO $40 MILLION IN
AID FOR TWO CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES IN RURAL AREAS, AND
WE CREATED A RESEARCH TOOLKIT
FOR FUTURE DISASTERS. EACH OF
THOSE TWO STUDIES INCLUDED
CURRENT AND FORMER UC MERCED
STUDENTS WHO ARE LATINO AND WERE
PREVIOUSLY UNDOCUMENTED, AND
FOUND THE POLICY RESEARCH LIFE
CHANGING. WE ASKED THE STATE NOT
CUT LABOR CENTER FUNDING, WHICH
IS SO CRITICAL FOR THE STATE'S
EFFORTS TO COMPETE FOR HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
FEDERAL ECONOMIC RESOURCES TO
PROTECT WORKERS THAT POWER THE
WORLD'S FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY,
AND TO EDUCATE STUDENTS WHO ARE
OUR FUTURE POLICYMAKERS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR
AND MEMBERS, MICHAELA
HUTCHINSON, ON BEHALF OF THE
STUDENT SENATE FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES, REPRESENTING
ALL 2 MILLION COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS. WE DEEPLY APPRECIATE
THE EFFORTS TO RETAIN ADEQUATE
FUNDING FOR THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES, EVEN IN A DEFICIT
YEAR. HOWEVER, WE ARE
DISAPPOINTED THE GOVERNOR DID
NOT TRIGGER THE FUNDING
MECHANISM FOR THE CAL GRANT
REFORM ACT TO MOVE CAL GRANT
REFORM FORWARD. WE ENCOURAGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO IMPLEMENT Kò
STRUCTURAL AND ELIGIBILITY
CHANGES TO THE CAL GRANT PROGRAM
THIS YEAR. THIS PHASED IN
APPROACH ALLOWS THE STATE TO
MEET ITS BUDGET GOALS, WHILE
MAINTAINING ITS TWO YEAR PROMISE
TO STUDENTS AND BUILDING UP OUR
ECONOMY AND WORKFORCE OF THE
FUTURE. THANK YOU FOR
RECOGNIZING THE VALUE OF
CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND ITS STUDENTS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WELCOME HI, CHAIR AND
SENATOR CORTESE, ANNA MATHEWS,
ON BEHALF OF MESA MATH
ENGINEERING SCIENCE ACHIEVEMENT
WITH THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THE
COLA AND ARE HOPING FOR AN
EXTENSION OF THE COLA TO OTHER
CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS. AND WE
APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATURE'S
COMMITMENT TO MESA AND ARE
REQUESTING AMENDMENTS TO
EXISTING BUDGET LANGUAGE TO
EXPEDITE FUNDING DISTRIBUTION
AND CREATE MORE STABILITY FOR
OUR PROGRAMS IN THEIR SUPPORT OF
OUR MOST MARGINALIZED COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS, WE WOULD HOPE
THAT FUNDS WOULD NOT BE SWEPT,
AND WE HOPE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
WILL HELP US TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE MONEY THAT THE STATE HAS
PROVIDED US MAKES ITS WAY OVER
TO OUR LOCAL PROGRAMS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON,
SENATORS. THANK YOU SO MUCH. MY
NAME IS SABA WAHEED. I'M THE
RESEARCH. I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
THE UCLA LABOR CENTER HERE. AS
AN INDIVIDUAL TO EXPRESS MY
CONCERNS AROUND THE FUNDING CUTS
TO THE TO THE NINE UC LABOR
CENTERS AND THE UCLA LATINA
FUTURES LAB AND WHY WE WERE
TARGETED OVER OTHER CENTERS
GIVEN OUR VALUE ADD AND CLOSE
WORK WITH THE WORKING CLASS
COMMUNITIES. WE HAVE A TEMPLATE
HERE FOR THE ENTIRE COUNTRY
ABOUT HOW TO PUSH THE PUBLIC,
HOW EXACTLY PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES
CAN INVEST IN PROJECTS THAT
SUPPORT THE PUBLIC GOOD AND
SERVE THE LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
LET'S NOT ROLL BACK THIS
IMPORTANT RESOURCE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND
SENATOR CORTESE, I'M HEATHER
KALAMEES WITH EDVOICE. I'M HERE
TO EXPRESS OUR OPPOSITION TO THE
GOVERNOR'S, 2024 2020 5TH MAY
REVISION BUDGET PROPOSAL THAT
REDUCES THE $6,060 MILLION IN
ONE TIME SUPPORT FOR THE GOLDEN
STATE TEACHER GRANT PROGRAM, AS
WELL AS MAKING SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES TO THE PROGRAM,
INCLUDING REDUCING THE GRANT
AWARD TO $10,000 AND ALSO
REDUCING THE REQUIREMENT FROM
TEACHING A PRIORITY SCHOOL FROM
4 TO 2 YEARS, WHICH WOULD
DECREASE THE INCENTIVE TO WORK
IN A PRIORITY SCHOOL. IN
ADDITION, THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION WOULD HAVE TO MAKE A
NUMBER OF CHANGES TO THE
PROGRAM, WHICH COULD LEAD TO
SIGNIFICANT IMPLEMENTATION
CHANGES WITH FUNDING SET TO RUN
OUT, THERE IS NO NEED TO MAKE
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES TO A PROGRAM
THAT IS WORKING AT AT THIS POINT
IN ITS TENURE. WE STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE YOU TO PROTECT THE
INVESTMENTS AND TO PRESERVE THE
IMPACT OF THE GST PROGRAM BY
MAINTAINING THE REMAINING,
FUNDING IN THE PROGRAM AND ALSO
MAINTAINING THE PROGRAM'S
CURRENT STATUTORY LANGUAGE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WELCOME. GOOD AFTERNOON.
MICHELLE MCCANN NORWOOD, ON
BEHALF OF THE COALITION FOR
ADEQUATE FUNDING FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION, WE ARE HERE TO OPPOSE
TWO NEW PROPOSALS IN THE MAYOR
REVISION RELATED TO OUR EARLIEST
LEARNERS WITH DISABILITIES.
THESE ARE PRESCHOOLERS AGED 0 TO
5 AND THEIR INCLUSIVE SETTING.
THE FIRST PROPOSAL THAT WE
OPPOSE IS GOVERNOR STOPPING THE
SET ASIDE OF SLOTS FOR
PRESCHOOLERS WITH DISABILITIES
AT THE CURRENT 5, IT IS
IMPORTANT FOR THESE CHILDREN TO
BE WITH THEIR TYPICAL PEERS IN
PRESCHOOL. SECOND, WE OPPOSE THE
EXPANSION OF FUNDING FOR ZERO
EMISSION BUSSES COMING AT THE
EXPENSE OF INCLUSIVE SETTINGS
FOR PRESCHOOLERS. JUST LAST
MONTH, LEE SUBMITTED A FUNDING
APPLICATIONS FOR THE INCLUSIVE
EARLY EDUCATION EXPANSION
PROGRAM. AGAIN, THIS IS TO
PROVIDE MORE INCLUSIVE SETTINGS
WHICH IS BOTH A SMART INVESTMENT
AND A MORAL IMPERATIVE FOR
CALIFORNIA TO DO. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WELCOME
HELLO. MY NAME IS JASON
WHISTLER. I AM THE SENIOR
RESEARCH SPECIALIST AT THE UC
DAVIS LABOR CENTER. I'M HERE AS
AN INDIVIDUAL TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE CUTS TO THE
LABOR CENTERS, PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION MUST BE FOR ALL OF THE
PUBLIC, AND NOT JUST RESEARCH
AND TRAINING FOR THE PRIVILEGED
OR CORPORATE INTERESTS. THE
LABOR CENTERS PROVIDE EFFECTIVE
RESEARCH, TEACHING, AND SERVICES
THAT SUPPORT WORKING PEOPLE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. I'M NEW TO
CALIFORNIA. I PREVIOUSLY WORKED
ON A DISSERTATION AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF IOWA ON WORKING
CLASS CONSERVATISM. I ALSO
WORKED AT IOWA'S LABOR CENTER. I
WATCHED AS IOWA REPUBLICANS
ATTACKED THE LABOR CENTER, THEN
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES, AND MOST
RECENTLY, PUBLIC K-12 EDUCATION.
ONE OF THE REASONS I MOVED TO
CALIFORNIA IS THAT I EXPECTED IT
TO BE DIFFERENT WITH DEMOCRATIC
MAJORITIES. BASED ON MY RESEARCH
ON WORKING CLASS CONSERVATISM
AND MY EXPERIENCE IN IOWA WHEN
DEMS FAILED TO SUPPORT WORKING
PEOPLE, IT OPENS UP WHAT SHOULD
BE A SOLID BASE OF TWO WAY
SUPPORT TO THE CULTURE WAR WEDGE
ISSUES EXPLOITED BY THE OTHER
PARTY. THIS INCLUDES
ANTI-INTELLECTUALISM EMBEDDED IN
A BELIEF THAT HIGHER ED DOES NOT
ADDRESS THEIR ISSUES UNLESS TO
MAKE THEM WORSE. THE LABOR
CENTERS HELP ALLEVIATE THAT AND
MUST NOT FACE THIS FUNDING CUT.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. JUST
BEFORE MY VERY VOCIFEROUS FORMER
STAFFER SET STEPS TO THE
MICROPHONE, LET ME JUST
APOLOGIZE THAT I HAVE TO LEAVE.
I'M GOING TO TURN THE GAVEL OVER
TO SENATOR CORTESE, AND I WANT
TO REMIND EVERYONE THAT IF YOU
WERE LISTENING AND YOU DIDN'T
GET TO, SUBMIT COMMENTS OR THIS
WAS TOO BRIEF FOR WHAT YOU
REALLY WANTED TO SAY, WE WELCOME
YOUR COMMENTS EITHER, CARE OF
OUR WEBSITE, THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE AND SUBCOMMITTEE ONE
OR BY LETTER DIRECTLY TO THE
ADDRESS THAT'S ON THAT WEBSITE.
SO WE APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS.
AND I APPRECIATE SENATOR CORTESE
FOR TAKING THE LAST CEREMONY.
I'M GOING TO SQUEEZE IN HERE. I
AM VERONICA TERRIQUEZ. I DIRECT
THE CHICANO STUDIES RESEARCH
CENTER AT UCLA. I'M HERE AS A,
AS A, AN INDIVIDUAL AND ALSO AS
A RESIDENT OF SANTA CRUZ, SO
THANK YOU, AND IT WAS A FORMER
RESIDENT OF SANTA CRUZ THAT JUST
DEFERRED TO YOU. SO BUT KEEP,
KEEP GOING. I HAVE TO GO. SO I
AM HERE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THE
LABOR CENTERS AND ALSO TO
REGISTER THAT THE GOVERNORS MAY
REVISE PROPOSALS, PULLBACKS TO
13.7 MILLION FOR THE LATINO
POLICY AND POLITICS INSTITUTE,
WHICH IS FUNDING FOR THE LATINA
FUTURES 2050 LAB. THIS LAB
INVOLVES UC SANTA CRUZ, UC
MERCED, UCLA WELL, ALL UCS AND
ADDITIONALLY SOME CSU'S. WE'RE
SUPPORTING RESEARCHERS TO
CONDUCT COMMUNITY ENGAGED WORK
THAT INFORMS POLICY AIMED AT
IMPROVING EQUITY AND INCLUSION
FOR LATINAS, PARTICULARLY AROUND
ISSUES OF HEALTH EQUITY AROUND
INCREASING THE PIPELINE OF
LATINA TEACHERS AND THE
RETENTION OF LATINA TEACHERS.
WE'RE ADDRESSING THE PAY GAP.
WE'RE ADDRESSING LGBTQ ISSUES,
AND IT'S REALLY EXCITING WORK
THAT AIMS TO IMPACT THE
PLURALITY OF WOMEN IN CALIFORNIA
. THE MAJORITY OF MOTHERS IN THE
STATE ARE LATINA. 78% OF CHILD
CARE WORKERS ARE LATINA. AND SO
THIS HAS IMPLICATIONS FOR THE
CHILDREN OF OUR STATE. AND WE
HOPE THAT YOU MAINTAIN THE
FUNDING FOR THIS, LATINA FUTURES
LAB LISTED UNDER LATINO POLICY
AND POLITICS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS. I'LL
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING YOU DOWN
THERE. I'M GOING TO TURN THE
GAVEL OVER TO SENATOR CORTEZ.
NEXT SPEAKER, OF COURSE. THANK
YOU, SENATOR CORTEZ, CHRIS
BRIEF, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION, FIRST, WANT TO
ASSOCIATE OURSELVES WITH THE
COMMENTS MADE BY MY COLLEAGUE ON
BEHALF OF THE COALITION FOR
ADEQUATE, SPECIAL EDUCATION
FUNDING, WE ARE ALSO OPPOSED TO
THE SHIFTING OF THE INCLUSIONARY
PRESCHOOL FUNDING TO FUND THE
EXPANSION OF THE ELECTRIC SCHOOL
BUS, PROGRAM, SPECIFICALLY,
THOUGH, WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE EMPHASIZE THAT WE ARE
STRIDENTLY OPPOSED TO THE
GOVERNOR'S PROP 98 MANEUVER. WE
WOULD THINK WE BELIEVE IT RUNS
COUNTER TO THE SPIRIT, PURPOSE,
AND CONSTITUTIONALITY OF
PROPOSITION 98 AND STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
LOOK AT THE EXISTING STATUTORY
AND CONSTITUTIONAL AUTHORITY
THAT IT HAS TO BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS PUBLIC EDUCATION
FUNDING. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
HELLO. MY NAME IS SOFIA CARDENAS
. I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
SACRAMENTO CENTRAL LABOR
COUNCIL, REPRESENTING 200,000
UNION FAMILIES HERE IN THE
CAPITAL REGION. I'M ALSO HERE IN
SOLIDARITY TO DISCOURAGE BUDGET
CUTS FOR THE èC LABOR CENTERS.
MY REASON IS WE TOOK IN TWO
YOUNG COLLEGE STUDENTS LAST
SUMMER AS LABOR SUMMER
INTERNSHIPS, WORKING WITH THE UC
DAVIS LABOR CENTER. WE'VE
DEVELOPED BOTH OF THOSE INTERNS
INTO EFFECTIVE LEADERS IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. AND SO I ASK YOU TO
PLEASE NOT CUT THIS FUNDING AND
DON'T DENY KIDS THE RIGHT TO BE
LEADERS IN THEIR COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT
SPEAKER. HI, I'M LETICIA
SALCIDO. I'M A LAW PROFESSOR AT
UC DAVIS, AND I'M ALSO THE
CO-DIRECTOR OF THE UC DAVIS
LABOR AND COMMUNITY CENTER. I'M
HERE TO EXPRESS MY CONCERN OVER
THE BUDGET CUTS TO THE UC LABOR
CENTERS. THEY'RE IMPORTANT
BECAUSE THEY PROVIDE VITAL
RESEARCH AND ANALYSIS THAT
INFORMS POLICIES IMPACTING ALL
OF CALIFORNIA FROM MINIMUM WAGE
INCREASES, INCOME TAX CREDITS TO
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS. THE
CENTERS HAVE BEEN INSTRUMENTAL
IN DEVELOPING EVIDENCE BASED
SOLUTIONS THAT UPLIFT WORKING
FAMILIES ACROSS THE STATE, AND
CUTTING THIS FUNDING WOULD
DEPRIVE POLICYMAKERS OF
RIGOROUS, IMPARTIAL DATA THAT
THEY NEED TO CRAFT SOUND LABOR
AND ECONOMIC POLICIES. AS A
LATINA, I'M ALSO HERE TO SUPPORT
THE LATINA FUTURES LAB, AND AS A
MEMBER OF THE FAST, ONE OF THE
FASTEST GROWING POPULATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA, I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT THAT KIND OF WORK. THANK
YOU. NEXT SPEAKER. GOOD MORNING.
SENATOR CORTEZ TÊ ACCOUNTS WITH
THE UCLA LABOR CENTER, ALSO HERE
IN OPPOSITION TO THE PROPOSED
CUTS. I WON'T BELABOR THE POINT,
BUT YOU KNOW US. YOU LOVE US.
WE'RE HERE ALL THE TIME BECAUSE
WE PROVIDE EXPERT TESTIMONY. WE
PROVIDE THE DATA THAT YOU NEED
TO DO YOUR JOB. AND AS WE HEAD
INTO THE FUTURE, CERTAINLY WE
NEED ALL NINE UC CAMPUSES TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE THIS KIND OF
SUPPORT AND INFRASTRUCTURE
AROUND THE WHOLE STATE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU. NEXT
GOOD AFTERNOON. KATIE HARDIMAN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION, THE CTA CONTINUES
TO OPPOSE THE GOVERNOR'S
APPROACH TO PROP 98 FUNDING. THE
MAY REVISION PROPOSES AN
UNCONSTITUTIONAL REDUCTION TO
PROP 98 THAT WILL LOWER SCHOOL
FUNDING THIS YEAR AND FOR YEARS
TO COME. THE STATE HAS MADE
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS IN RECENT
YEARS AROUND SCHOOL FUNDING, AND
THIS PROPOSAL WILL TAKE SCHOOL
FUNDING BACKWARDS. SO WE URGE
YOU TO ADOPT A BUDGET THAT'S
CONSISTENT WITH THE CONSTITUTION
AND PROTECTS LONGTERM EDUCATION
FUNDING. THANKS. THANK YOU. NEXT
HI. GOOD AFTERNOON. CAROL
GONZALEZ HERE ON BEHALF OF LONG
BEACH CITY COLLEGE, HISPANAS
ORGANIZED FOR POLITICAL EQUALITY
AND AT TRUST WEST FOR OUR
MEMBERS OF THE CAL GRANT REFORM
COALITION, HERE WE UNDERSTAND
THE BUDGET CIRCUMSTANCES.
HOWEVER, WE BELIEVE IT'S
IMPORTANT TO PRIORITIZE COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY OF ADULT LEARNERS,
WORKING PARENTS AND LOW INCOME
STUDENTS. THEREFORE WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO TAKE A PHASED IN
APPROACH, TOWARDS IMPLEMENTING
CAL GRANT REFORM BY IMPLEMENTING
KEY STRUCTURAL AND ELIGIBILITY
CHANGES USING THE 60 MILLION.
SAVINGS FROM THE JANUARY BUDGET
INCREASED OF CAL GRANT SPENDING
AS A FOUNDATION FOR THIS ONE
TIME INVESTMENT. WE ALSO WANT TO
URGE THE LEGISLATURE AND
GOVERNOR, WE WANT TO THANK THE
GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE FOR
PROTECTING COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FUNDING, LONG BEACH IS
ESPECIALLY APPRECIATIVE OF THE
NURSING PROGRAM FUNDING AND
TRUST. WEST ALSO WANTS TO
RESPECTFULLY ASK, FOR MORE
SPECIFICITY ON THE FUNDING THAT
THE CSU AND UC COMPACTS WILL
ACTUALLY RECEIVE AND CLARIFY
WHAT FUTURE OUTLOOK OUT YEARS
WILL ACTUALLY LOOK LIKE. WE'D
LIKE TO ENSURE THE PROTECTION
AND INVESTMENT AND PROGRAMS
DESIGNED TO ADVANCE STUDENT
ACCESS AND SUCCESS AND CLOSE
RACIAL EQUITY GAPS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU. NEXT GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHRISTOPHER SANCHEZ
WITH THE MESA VERDE GROUP HERE
ON BEHALF OF CARECEN, THE
CENTRAL AMERICAN RESOURCE CENTER
AND IMMIGRANT LEGAL DEFENSE, WE
WOULD LIKE TO BRING TO THE
COMMITTEE'S ATTENTION AN ISSUE
THAT OVERLAPS WITH SUBS SUB
THREE IN THIS HOUSE AND THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET AND
INCLUDED IN THE MAY REVISE. HE'S
CUTTING IMMIGRATION LEGAL
SERVICES THAT ARE PROVIDED AT
THE CSU. CUTTING 5.2 MILLION OF
THOSE DOLLARS, WHICH IS OVER 70%
OF THE FUNDING THAT'S CURRENTLY
OFFERED. OUR ORGANIZATIONS ARE
OPPOSED TO THESE CUTS BECAUSE OF
THE TREMENDOUS IMPACT THAT IT
HAS TO STUDENTS, FACULTY AND
STAFF AT THOSE CAMPUSES AND THE
GENERAL COMMUNITY. WE FIRMLY
BELIEVE THE TIMING IS OFF FOR
THESE CUTS, ESPECIALLY WITH THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION, POSSIBLY
COMING NEXT YEAR, THIS ITEM HAS
BEEN HEARD IN ASSEMBLY SUB THREE
AND IN SUB TWO, WE WOULD JUST
URGE THIS COMMITTEE TO ALIGN ITS
ACTIONS WITH THE OTHER THREE
COMMITTEES THAT HAVE ALREADY
HEARD THIS, AND WOULD ALSO URGE
YOU TO REJECT THE, THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED CUTS AND
FULLY FUND IMMIGRATION LEGAL
SERVICES. THANKS. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS UNI
LYNDON. WITH PUBLIC ADVOCATES,
WE OPPOSE CUTS TO THE GOLDEN
STATE TEACHERS GRANT PROGRAM,
WHICH IS ESSENTIAL TO RECRUITING
DIVERSE TEACHERS, WHICH STUDIES
SHOW LEADS TO IMPROVED OUTCOMES
FOR STUDENTS OF COLOR. IN LIEU
OF CUTS, WE BELIEVE IT'S
IMPORTANT TO CONSIDER NEW
REVENUE OPTIONS THAT ARE MORE
STABLE THAN CAPITAL GAINS, SUCH
AS TAXING SERVICES OR WEALTHY
ESTATES, OR TWEAKING PROP 13,
AND WE AGREE ON THE NEED FOR AN
EDUCATION BOND THIS YEAR. BUT AS
WE REQUESTED IN A RECENT LETTER
TO STATE OFFICIALS, THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION
MUST FIRST FIX THE REGRESSIVE
AND UNCONSTITUTIONAL STRUCTURE
OF OUR PUBLIC SCHOOL CAPITAL
FINANCE SYSTEM. UNDER THE
CURRENT ALLOCATION SCHEME, THE
STATE 60% CONTRIBUTION FOR ALL
DISTRICT MODERNIZATION PROJECTS
HAS SENT TWICE AS MUCH PER PUPIL
TO THOSE IN THE WEALTHIEST
DISTRICTS AS THE POOREST
DISTRICTS. NOW IS THE TIME TO
FIX THIS UNLAWFUL 25 YEAR DENIAL
OF EQUAL EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITY
IN OUR SCHOOL CAPITAL FINANCE
SYSTEM. AND WE CAN DO THAT BY
EMPLOYING AN EQUITABLE SLIDING
SCALE, MUCH LIKE THE SYSTEMS FOR
FUNDING SCHOOL OPERATIONS. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU.
NEXT GOOD AFTERNOON, PAIGE CLARK
WITH THE NATIONAL CENTER FOR
YOUTH LAW. I WANT TO THANK YOU,
SENATOR, FOR YOUR EARLIER
COMMENTS REGARDING CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY ASKING THE
LEGISLATURE TO MAINTAIN THE
PROPOSED $2.5 MILLION IN FEDERAL
FUNDING FOR HOMELESS EDUCATION
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE CENTERS
OUTLINED IN THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISE. THESE CENTERS PROVIDE
CRITICAL GUIDANCE AND RESOURCES
TO COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION
TO BETTER SERVE THEIR STUDENTS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON,
SENATOR CORTEZ. FIRST, THANK YOU
FOR STICKING AROUND. TROOPING IT
OUT. DAVID NEVIN, ON BEHALF OF
THE INSTITUTE FOR COLLEGE ACCESS
AND SUCCESS, WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL
TO THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE FOR, NOT MAKING
SIGNIFICANT CUTS TO THE CAL
GRANT PROGRAM IN THE MAY REVISE,
AS WELL AS IN EARLY BUDGET
ACTION, WE ARE A LITTLE
DISAPPOINTED TO SEE THAT THE CAL
GRANT REFORM WAS NOT IMPLEMENTED
IN THE OR WAS NOT EXERCISED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET OR MAY
REVISE, WE'RE HOPING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CAN FIND A WAY TO
CREATE THIS PIECEMEAL OR PHASED
IN APPROACH, ESPECIALLY USING
WHAT IS PROPOSED FOR THE $60
MILLION IN CUTS THAT MY
COLLEAGUES FROM THE CAL GRANT
REFORM COALITION SPOKE TO
EARLIER, WE'RE ALSO HOPING THAT
THE LEGISLATURE CAN SUPPORT THE
CONTINUED INVESTMENT FOR THE KGI
AND THE TRAILER BILL
MODIFICATIONS FOR THE CRADLE TO
CAREER DATA SYSTEM, AND WE DO
HAVE TO UPLIFT THE STRUCTURAL
FUNDING DEFICIT FACED BY THE
BUREAU FOR PRIVATE
POST-SECONDARY EDUCATION. THE
BUREAU DOES NEED ADDITIONAL
REVENUE TO CARRY OUT ITS
CRITICAL MISSION TO PROTECT
STUDENTS AND OVERSEE
INSTITUTIONS THAT EVENTUALLY
BECOME PREDATORY, AND END UP
COSTING STUDENTS A LOT OF MONEY
AND TIME AND THEIR HIGHER
EDUCATION. OAN, AND THEN JUST
REALLY BRIEFLY, ON BEHALF OF
CERRITOS COLLEGE, WE DO REMAIN
CONCERNED ABOUT THE CURRENT
LEASE REVENUE BOND, FOR STUDENT
HOUSING PROPOSAL, OUR COLLEGE
WAS RANKED NUMBER ONE BY THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE LAST YEAR IN
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET PROCESS, AS
BEING THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE
AND SHOVEL READY PROGRAM AND
PROJECT FOR GETTING UNHOUSED
STUDENTS INTO AFFORDABLE STUDENT
HOUSING AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE,
OUR PROJECT IS SHOVEL READY.
READY TO GO, ON THE CAMPUS
GROUNDS, ALL WE NEED IS JUST A
LITTLE BIT OF HELP FROM THE
LEGISLATURE TO PUSH US IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY. AND WE'RE HAPPY
WE WERE ABLE TO GET EVERYBODY ON
THE RECORD WHO WANTED TO BE ON
THE RECORD TODAY WITH PUBLIC
COMMENT. THANK YOU TO ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED. IF
YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY, IF
YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY
TODAY, PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE. YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US.
THANK YOU AND WE TRULY
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION.
WE'VE CONCLUDED THE AGENDA FOR
TODAY'S HEARING. THE SENATE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE, NUMBER ONE
ON EDUCATION IS ADJOURNED